Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 89. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer neuen rockigen Ausgabe vom Express. Wir schreiben den 18. Juni 2008, die Zeit schreitet voran. Letzter Zeit gab es nicht ganz so viele Sendungen, das hatte diverse Gründe, die nicht weiter wichtig sind, aber man hat nicht immer so viel Zeit und es ist auch nicht mal so einfach, wirklich interessante Gesprächspartner zu bekommen. Manchmal geht es leichter, manchmal geht es schwieriger. Und jemanden, dem ich schon etwas länger auf der Spur bin, um auch häufig schon ein gewünschtes Thema anzusprechen, der ist nun heute endlich da. Das Thema soll heute sein Computerspiele im weitesten Sinne. Wir wollen ein bisschen in die Geschichte schauen und ein wenig das Wesen der Computerspiele-Szene, die ja so besonders ist und so anders ist, beleuchten. Und ich begrüße dazu Teut Weidemann. Hallo Teut. Hallo. Ja, du lebst in dieser Welt, das kann man jetzt schon mal vorwegnehmen. Das ist auf jeden Fall dein Gebiet. Wir haben uns von der Weile kennengelernt bei einer Veranstaltung, wo es auch ein bisschen um die Zukunft der Computerspiele ging. Ja, vielleicht steigen wir mal kurz mit dir ein. Du bist ja schon auch sehr lange dabei mit den Computern. Wann hast du so deinen Einstieg gehabt in die Rechnerwelten?
Ende 1980.
Ende 1980. Und was ist da passiert?
Ja, ich bin da nach Bayern gezogen durch meinen Vater. Der ist alle drei Jahre umgezogen, weil er beim Militär war oder beim Diplomatischen Dienst. Und Bayern war halt eine harte Schule. Da musste ich die zehnte Klasse wiederholen, was ein Glücksfall war. Weil mein Banknachbar hat mich da ein bisschen beeinflusst. Der Mathematiklehrer fragte uns, ob wir dieses Jahr Informatik oder Oberflächengeometrie machen wollen. Oberflächengeometrie sagte mir was, Informatik sagte mir gar nichts. Und dann hat er mich angeschubst und dann gesagt, komm, wir machen Informatik, das war was mit Computern. Da dachte ich, ja, okay, kein Problem. Die Mehrheit hat sich dann für Informatik ausgesprochen. Und das Gute war, dass dieses Gymnasium, wo ich war, war einer der wenigen, die einen Computerraum hatten.
Das war nicht so verbreitet in der Zeit?
Nee, also sie hatten ganz wenig Rechner. Sie hatten also eine Menge altes Zeug, so Lochkarten und Rechner mit Röhren noch drin und so ein Zeug. Also so ein bisschen so die Historie, wo die Computer herkommen. Und hatten einen Pad 2001 mit Datasette. Da war es Commodore Pad 2001, der mit der viereckigen Tastatur, wo die Tasten noch nicht so richtig schön angeordnet waren. Und daneben war eine Datasette fest eingebaut, das Speichermedium. Einen, aber sie waren Teil von einem Programm, und zwar von einem mobilen Computerraum. Da ist also ein Lastwagen gekommen, alle 14 Tage, und hat 30 Rechner ausgeladen. Die konnten wir dann eine Woche benutzen, und dann gingen wir zur nächsten Schule, und dann hat sie da ausgeladen.
Sowas gab es in Deutschland?
In Deutschland, in Bayern, ganz hervorragend wirklich. Und wenn diese neuen Rechner kamen, das war eigentlich der Commodore 3016, das war nämlich schon sehr geil, weil der hatte eine richtige Tastatur, und der hatte halt 16 Kilobyte-Speicher, im Gegensatz zum Pad 2001, der hatte also sehr, sehr wenig. Und die Rechner waren richtig hardcore, also man konnte diese Rechner, die waren so stabil, die waren unverwüstlich einfach, die waren perfekt für die Schule.
Wer hat denn diesen Lastwagen organisiert?
Ich weiß nicht, woher das kam, es passierte einfach. Und dann ging es aber auch ganz schnell, dass die Schule den Computerraum erweitert hatte, weil der Bedarf der Schüler doch da war. Und ich bin da recht schnell eingestiegen, ich habe halt Basic programmiert, das ist was jeder am Anfang macht. Und schon ein paar Monate später war das nicht langweilig, aber ich stieß so an die Limits des Rechners. Mir ging die Sache nicht schnell genug. Und dann bin ich in die Bücherei gegangen, da hat man die ganzen Bücher, was heißt die ganzen Bücher, die paar wenigen immer durchgelesen, die da waren über das Thema. Und da war einer in der Jagenstufe höher als ich.
Über welches Thema? Über Computer überhaupt?
Generell, Computersprachen, Computerprogrammierung, die waren ja alle in Englisch. Und damals waren wir in Englisch zwar ein bisschen bewandert durch die Schule, aber man hat halt nicht Englisch geredet, gelesen und sowas. Ich hatte den Vorteil, ich habe sieben Jahre in Rammstein gewohnt, American Air Force Base, da durch meinen Vater. Das war so Kleine Amerika. Da habe ich sieben Jahre gewohnt, habe halt nur Englisch reden müssen auch. Und da war eine Bowling-Airline, so die typische amerikanische, zum Bowlen und sowas. Und da standen hinten die ganzen Spielautomaten drin. Da habe ich mein ganzes Taschengeld gelassen. Da kam so die erste Spielerei überhaupt, dieser Bedarf da, dass es sowas gibt, elektronisches Spielzeug.
Was gab es denn da für Spiele?
Asteroids, Lunar Lander, dieses, wie hieß es, Battlesong von Atari mit dem Panzer mit dem 3D. Also viele Sachen, die hatten alle aktuellen Automaten damals. Und mein absoluter Favorit war Defender.
Und Defender fand ich auch super.
Ich habe da 1200 DM reingeschmissen. Ich weiß es noch wie heute. Aber wie gesagt, dieser Computerraum, das war faszinierend, weil er sich dann halt erweitert hat. Und dieser Kerl, den ich in der Bibliothek getroffen habe, der hatte auf dem Bildschirm Dinge am Laufen in so einer Affengeschwindigkeit, wo ich gesagt habe, sag mal, das kriege ich nicht hin, wie machst du das? Dann drehte er sich nur kurz um und sagte, Assembler drehte sich wieder zu seinem Rechner und das war's. Dann bin ich zu meinem Lehrer gegangen und hab gesagt, du...
Ich muss unbedingt Assembler lernen.
Ich wusste noch nicht mal, dass man das lernen kann. Ich hab aber gesagt, was ist Assembler? Und dann ging der Lehrer einfach zu seinem Schrank und holte ein Buch raus, die Programming of the Six-Five-Four-Two von Rodney Sex.
Rodney Sex. Hab ich ja auch noch im Regal. Ja, echt? Ja, mit allen Fehlern, die ich gefunden habe noch mit ihm.
Wenn ich dem mal begegne, dem habe ich meine Karriere zu verdanken. Ich hab dieses Buch verschlungen, habe 6502 Assembler gelernt. Ich kenne, haben wir eben schon mal darüber gesprochen, ich kenne heute noch Opcours von 6502 auswendig.
A9?
A9 ist LDA. Der 6.0 ist RTS, aber mein Lieblingsbefehl ist EA. Hexedys mal EA, weil das die Abkürzung von Electronic Arts. Und das war No Operation. Schöner Vergleich.
Ja, den braucht man auch, nicht? So viel Timing und so.
Und ich habe rasant Assembler gelernt. Ich war nachher so, sag mal, Profi in dem Computerraum, dass der, ich war der einzige Schüler, den ein Schlüssel zu dem Computerraum hatten. Ich konnte auch so rein und raus, wann ich will. Andere Schüler sind dann zu mir gekommen, wenn sie reinwollten. Und ich habe nachher auch sogar Unterricht gehalten. Also im Abitur habe ich Informatik-Grundkurs gegeben. Und ich habe dann mal versucht, den Lehrern-Assembler beizubringen. Ich habe also einen Assembler-Grundkurs für Lehrer gemacht. Da waren am Anfang zwölf Lehrer und Lehrerinnen da. Ich habe also angefangen mit wirklich Prozessoraufbau, Binär, Hexadezimal, den ganzen Zeug und so was. Und in der dritten Stunde waren nur noch zwei übrig. Aber so fing ich an. Das war also so die Anfang der 80er Jahre. Der Computerraum hatte damals auch schon VC20, C64. Wir haben damals auch das erste Spiel gemacht, was verboten worden ist. Welches denn? Wir haben Sado Killer hieß das. Nein, ganz harmlos. Links eine Schule, rechts das Paradies mit einer Brücke verbunden. Und die Schüler sind also auch in Assembler programmiert damals sehr, sehr schnell von der Schule in das Paradies gelaufen. Und dahinter war der böse Lehrer mit zwei großen Fäusten. Man musste mit zwei Tasten rechtzeitig die Schüler zerquetschen. Und die zerquetschte man halt so richtig mit der kleinen Blutlacher und so was. Und dieses Spiel war so phänomenal erfolgreich in der Schule. Der Direktor hat das verboten. Aber das waren so die Anfänge, dass man auf der Schule dann halt mit Kassetten seine eigenen kreierten Programme getauscht, verkauft und...
Und die Plattform war damals dann der Pad oder diese andere Commodore-Maschine?
Die gesamte Commodore-Serie. Also von den ganzen Varianten. Wir hatten Pad 2001, die sind nachher herausgeschoben worden, die 3016er, 3032er, nachher kamen auch die 8000er und 9000er-Serie dazu. Wir hatten dann eine Menge VC20 und VC64, weil die preisgünstiger waren.
Und darauf lief dann auch das Programm?
Genau, das war ein VC20-Spiel. Die erste Version davon, die zweite Version war eine VC64. Und da war es schon so, dass wir uns in München regelmäßig getroffen haben, so ein Freundeskreis, so ein enger. Und wir haben jedes Wochenende Freitagstabend nach München gefahren und Sonntagabend alle wieder zurück. Und da haben wir alle dort übernachtet, in Schlafsäcken, auf Couchen, keine Ahnung was. Und haben da unseren eigenen Rechner aufgebaut. Und ich war damals stolzer Besitzer eines SX64. Kennt ihr ihn jemand noch?
Ja, ich kenne ihn natürlich. Das war dieser schicke Portable, der auch extrem sturdy gebaut war.
Den habe ich heute noch mit selber eingebautem Speed-DOS.
Das ist also diese Beschleunigung von, wie hieß er noch gleich, der das gemacht hat?
Jäschke hieß er glaube ich. Irgendwas mit Jäschke, ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ganz alte Zeit. Der geht heute noch.
Speeddoors brachte den, das muss ich gleich mal nachdenken, den Disketten-Transfer glaube ich um Faktor 10 nach oben.
Der hat einen Speicher, der Floppy. Das Speed-DOS erst mal und dann ging es ruckzuck. Das waren so die Anfänge und da haben wir natürlich viel gespielt. Die ganzen klassischen Spiele, die Ultimas, die Elites und wie sie alle hießen. Wir haben aber auch selber eine Menge programmiert, weil wir die Technik ausnutzen wollten. Wir wollten wissen, wie es funktioniert und wir wollten die Grenzen dieser Maschinen ausloten. Und haben dann, wann war das? 1984 haben wir die ersten Spiele verkauft an einer Firma namens Kingsoft. Damals gab es die Magazine 64er, die war Mark und Technik, und auf der Rückseite immer eine große Werbung mit 30 Spielen drauf. Immer so ein kleines Kästchen, einen Screenshot mit Kursbeschreibung, einen Satz und einen Preis. Das war alles Amiga C64. Und an die Firma haben wir die verschachtert und das erste Spiel haben wir für 2500 Mark verkauft. Das war für so Studenten.
Für so kleine Jungs war das auf jeden Fall ein großes Ereignis, kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Es wurde aber auch immer mehr, weil die Spiele immer besser wurden. Das war natürlich kein Vergleich zu den anderen internationalen Spielen, aber es war ein Anfang. Das hat sich dann herumgesprochen, weil wir, ich weiß nicht, wie man das sagen darf, wir waren so in München der zentrale Anlaufpunkt von neuen Spielen für Robkopiere. Also immer, wenn jemand was Neues haben wollte, was Neues aus den USA kam, wir hatten es immer zuerst. Und wir waren eine der wenigen Jungs, die in der Lage waren, den Kopierschutz mitzukopieren. Weil wir hatten damals nämlich ein Programm, das heißt Error-Kopie. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das erkennt.
Wir sind noch beim C64 jetzt?
C64, genau. Und zwar war der Kopierschutz so angelegt damals auf C64, dass da Fehler auf der Spur draufgeschrieben werden.
Das war sehr beliebt.
Und da kamen immer Fehlermeldungen. Und das Spiel hat nachgeguckt auf diese Spur. Und wenn die Fehlermeldung kam, war das eine legale Kopie. Und wie macht man denn eine Spur kaputt absichtlich? Das ist sehr schwer. Und wir hatten ein Programm, damit konnte man einfach angeben, hör mal zu, auf dem Track, dem Sektor, mach mir einen Error 23 drauf. Und dann war das ein Error 23.
Das heißt, die Software lief dann im Diskettennauwerk?
Genau, das war eine Software, die das in den Diskettennauwerk reingetan hat und einfach dann direkt auf den Schreiblesekopf angedeutet hat.
Das war damals so die populäre Methode, das hat auch so Data und so weiter.
Das waren Frankfurter Programmierer, der das uns gemacht hat. Und wir hatten dieses Programm und dadurch ein ziemliches Monopole im Münchner Bereich, weil die Spiele, bis sie geknackt waren, konnten wir sie als einziger kopieren.
Das klingt jetzt wieder so böse, aber man muss ja auch mal sagen, damals war ja auch eigentlich das, ich hasse diesen Begriff Raubkopieren, aber dieses Kopieren von Software, das war einfach das Salz in der Suppe der Computerszene an sich.
Genau, die ganze Szene hat sich herumgebaut, weil diese Raubkopiererei, so negativ sie ist, ich lebe von der Branche, deswegen tut sie mir sehr, sehr weh, weil die gesamten Spiele in Deutschland verkaufen sich nicht mehr so gut wegen den Raubkopien, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Das, was aber passiert ist, damals war so, der Markt war noch gar nicht entwickelt. Das heißt, wir hatten viele, viele Spiele, 80% der Spiele waren, konnte man im Laden gar nicht kaufen. Die waren einfach nicht verfügbar. Also hat man sie kopiert. Man wollte so viel konsumieren. Wir haben ja, ich weiß nicht, 100, 200 Spiele an jedem Wochenende durchgeguckt. Da gab es so einen prünten Ausdruck, der nannte sich Fack-Click. Den habe ich aufgebracht, weil immer, wenn ich ein neues Spiel angeguckt habe, was scheiße war, habe ich Fack gesagt und habe Reset-Knopf auf den C64 gedrückt. Wir haben jeder oben so einen Reset-Knopf drauf gehabt.
Und es gab eine ganze Menge schlechte Spiele damals.
Eine Menge, ja. Aber es gab auch eine Menge Highlights, die einen richtig zu die Augen geöffnet haben, die dann auch einen selber motivierten, warum kann ich das nicht? Wo sind diese kreativen Leute, die diese Ideen hernehmen und diese wunderbaren Welten erschaffen? Ich weiß noch genau, wir waren noch so auf dem Niveau von International Corrater und Pluton. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das noch kennt.
Irgendjemand kennt das. Ich kenne das jetzt gerade nicht. Aber wir haben ja sehr aufgeklärte und gebildete Hörer.
Das waren die einfachen Spreisspielchen, sage ich mal. Aber wenn man sich mal zurückversetzt, wenn man die Zeit miterlebt hat, haben diese Spiele eigentlich mehr Spaß gemacht als viele heute. Weil viel mehr im Kopf abgegangen ist und eben nicht auf dem Monitor. Das war halt abstrakter, die Grafik. Die Interaktion war aber ähnlich. Also eine Autorin, damals, mein Lieblingsautorin, hieß Rally Speedway. Das war so ein 8-Wege-Scroller, auf dem C64 von oben gesehen, mit einer Astreinphysik, wie die Autos um die Ecke gekurvt sind, so richtig mit Anbremsen und mit Sliden. Und dieses Rally Speedway spielt sich noch heute fast genauso wie die heutigen Rennsumulationen. Und da hat sich jetzt nicht so viel getan, außer im Kreis rumfahren. Außer natürlich die Graffiti-Technik als bombastischer, realistischer und so was. Aber da ist halt viel mehr im Kopf losgegangen. Und wir haben halt damals versucht, Spiele zu machen, eher aus einem technischen Gedanken her. Wir haben irgendein Technik-Demo gemacht, was ganz klasse war. Und daraus haben wir dann einfach uns überlegt, was für ein Spiel machen wir da draus. Und die andere Geschichte, die natürlich aus der Rock-Copy-Szene ganz groß geworden ist, war das Cracken der Spiele, das war ja so eine Art Wettbewerb. Wir waren in München halt schon relativ bekannt, aber gegen Fairlight damals hatten wir null Chance. Das war ja so die Superstars der Szene. Und die mussten sich natürlich irgendwie selbst darstellen. Das ist unser Crack, wir waren die Ersten. Dann haben wir die Demos davor gemacht. Und die Demos waren natürlich technische Meisterwerke. Da gibt es inzwischen auch so ganze CDs, wo die Demos noch drauf sind, die unter Emulatoren laufen und so was.
Also mit Demos muss man gleich erklären. Wir reden jetzt von sozusagen dem in das gruppierte Spiel injizierte Vorspenden, ein Intro, wo man einfach noch mal gezeigt hat, was man kann.
Also aus der V4-Liste funktioniert das so, man legt dir die Diskette ein, die rock-gopierte, und dann lädt man halt laut Anführungszeichen Doppelton Stern.
Crack by Tralala.
Dann kam so ein Intro-Screen, der hier Presented by Fairlight mit Datum und Drum und Dran und meistens noch die komischen Synonym-Namen der Leute, die daran beteiligt waren. Und nach dem Intro, was technisch aufwendig war, kam das übliche Geflacker vom Entpacken von dem gesamten Spiel, weil die ja sehr klein gepackt waren. Und dann hielt das Spiel los. Und diese Intros waren technisch eine kleine Meisterwerke und da haben sich die Leute natürlich dann ausgetobt mit den technischen Spielereien, die die Rechte an die Grenzen zu setzen. Und als der, im Beispiel, wir haben auf dem Amiga ein Spiel gemacht, der Amiga war in der Lage, zwei Ebenen übereinander zu blenden, wo man durch die eine Ebene konnte man durchgucken, und die unabhängig voneinander zu verschieben. Also ein 8-Wege-Scrolling mit zwei Ebenen. Wir wollten unbedingt ein Spiel machen, was damit funktioniert.
Warte mal, das hast du eben schon erwähnt, 8-Wege-Scrolling?
Ja, also wenn der Bildschirm sich bewegt, wie kann man das erklären? Heute ist alles 3D. Damals war alles 2D, 3D gab es sehr selten. Und wenn der Bildschirm sich bewegt und man muss Daten oder eine Landschaft oder was auch immer von außen zeigen, also wenn man jetzt eine Rennstrecke fährt, von oben gesehen, dann muss ja irgendwie, wenn ich den Bildschirm nach unten verschiebe und oben kommt eine neue Strecke rein, dann muss ich die da reintun. Das ist jetzt ein Einwegescrolling, weil sich der Bildschirm nur in eine Richtung bewegt. Mach ich das aber in acht Richtungen, kompliziert sich das Ganze. Das ist sehr, sehr schwierig zu programmieren.
Acht Richtungen jetzt im Sinne von rechts, links, oben, unten und die Diagonalen. Dass der Bildschirm sich nicht in jede Richtung bewegen kann. Also acht Wege sozusagen oben, unten, links, rechts und die Diagonalen.
Genau, das nennt sich dann Achtwegescrolling. Und diese Achtwegescrolling auf der Amiga war das halt sehr schick zu machen, weil die halt auch so ganz große Bilder einfach nur ausschützweise scrollen konnte. Und das konnte er in zwei unabhängigen Ebenen.
Das war dieser Blitter-Chip, oder?
Ja, der Blitter und zusammen mit dem Copper. Und das ging jetzt nicht. Der Copper war der Chip, der zahlenweise den Bildschirm umprogrammieren konnte. Und der Blitter konnte ganze Grafikbereiche kopieren.
Der Amiga war eigentlich überhaupt der erste Homecomputer, der mit solchen advanceden Grafik-Features daher kam, die wirklich von der Hardware unterstützt waren, oder?
Ja, bis auf die Sprites, die wir auf dem C64-Phänomenal waren, war der Amiga der erste, der wirklich einen Grafikprozessor drauf hatte. Den musste man extra programmieren. Und zusätzlich zum Grafikprozessor, den man extra programmieren musste, mit einer eigenen, sagen wir mal, Semisprache, war da noch der Copper daneben, der praktisch für jede Rasterzeile des Bildschirms, also für jede einzelne Pixelzeile, konnte der Parameter in den Registern ändern. Da ist er praktisch, bevor er eine Linie gemalt hat, auf dem Fernseher damals noch, oder auf einem komischen Monitor, konnte der Copper die gesamten Register ändern. Also man konnte die Farben ändern, oder man konnte die Auflösung ändern, oder die Position des Bildschirms leicht verschieben. Dadurch konnte man ganz tolle Effekte machen. Das Einfachste war nachher so ein Wellenmuster, dass der ganze Bildschirm sich wellenförmig bewegt hat. Das machte man ganz einfach, indem man jede Zeile den Bildschirm tippen nach rechts verschoben hat und nachher wieder einen Tipp nach links. Dann hat man das animiert. Das war der Copper und das Revolutionäre am Amiga, dass man verschiedene Chipslatter, die man programmieren konnte, um visuale Effekte zu erzeugen.
Dabei hatte man ja auch schon diesen Realtime-Aspekt mit drin. Die Grafikausgabe, man war ja synchronisiert auf die Ausgabe auf dem Bildschirm. Von daher hatte man eigentlich alles in der Hand, dass man eben flackern, hatte man einfach unter Kontrolle. Und auch vom Timing her.
Ganz wichtig, da waren zwei Punkte. Einmal in Deutschland vor allem. Wir sind immer eine Gesellschaft von Technikern. Wir wollten immer perfekt sein. Ganz wichtig war, dass die gesamten Demos immer in 50Hz liefen. Also in 50 Bildern die Sekunde. Es war verschmäht, dass irgendetwas in 25 Bildern lief. Also in halber Framezahl. Das hat man ja auch gesehen auf Anhieb. Also es musste in 50 Bildern die Sekunde laufen. Das war das eine. Und das andere, es musste halt wirklich die gesamte Rechenpower benutzt werden. Und damals war das halt auf dem Fernseher, bzw. auf Monitoren, die auch mit Fernsehtechnik liefern, liefen nur 50Hz. In den USA, die hatten eine andere Technologie, das war der 60Hz, und das war auch einer der damals der großen Grundprobleme, dass europäische Spiele sich nicht so gut... Du kannst dir vorstellen, du hast für ein Bild eine 50-Sekunde Rechenzeit. In den USA hast du aber nur eine 60-Sekunde. Das heißt, viele deutsche Spiele liefen gar nicht in den USA. Weil du musstest sie ja schneller machen. Du hast jetzt nur eine 60-Sekunde. Und dieser kleine Unterschied war genug, dass viele deutsche Spiele gar nicht liefen drüben. Man konnte sie auch gar nicht programmieren. Da gab es Tricks nachher, das zu tun, wenn jemand den Bildschirm kleiner macht.
Aber andererseits konnten die amerikanischen Spiele relativ leicht auf 50Hz gehen.
Ja, die hatten ein anderes Problem. Und zwar, wenn ein Spiel, das mit 60Hz läuft, in Europa lief, mit 50Hz, lief es ja langsamer. Das heißt, es war einfacher. Die gesamte Interaktivität war verschoben. Da musste man drauf aufpassen. Aber die Tatsache war damals schon, dass die Amerikaner gar nicht in 50 oder 60Hz programmieren konnten. Die waren nie technologieorientiert, ganz selten. Deren Spiele waren ganz anders konzipiert. Eine Ultima brauchte keine 60Hz. Das war völlig egal. Oder die anderen Spiele, die kamen, wie Defender of the Crown, wie sie alle hießen, irgendwann sind immer mehr.
Ultima, das muss man vielleicht noch kurz erläutern, war ja auch so eins der ersten wirklich sehr erfolgreichen Spiele, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe. Kannst du vielleicht mal kurz...
Also Ultima war am Anfang relativ klein, Ultima 1. Aber das fing auf dem Apple II an, in den USA. Design von Richard Garriott. Und es fing eigentlich mit Ultima 3 an, richtig zu explodieren, weil es auch auf mehreren Formaten kam.
Ultima war doch dieses Strategiespiel auch schon. Ein Rollenspiel. Was im Prinzip so auf dem Weg zu World of Warcraft liegt.
Das war der Vorreiter, genau. Die Urväter des Rollenspiels war einmal Wizardry, das lief nur auf Apple II. Das war so ein 3D-Labyrinth-Rollenspiel. Und das erste Spiel, das so eine gesamte interaktive Welt dargestellt hat, war eigentlich Ultima. Das war alles von oben. Wie gesagt, 3D gab es damals noch nicht. Das war von oben gesehen. Da ist man durch eine gesamte Riesenwelt gelaufen und konnte in Städte rein mit Leuten unterhalten. Die haben auch reagiert auf einen. Das war damals neu. Man ist da hingegangen, hat jemand bestohlen. Der hat das gemerkt, sind die Wachen gekommen und haben einen ins Gefängnis gesteckt oder geschlagen. Damals war das relativ neu, dieses Format. In Ultima 3 haben sie es ein bisschen übertrieben. Da musste man sich dann gut benehmen, ein ehrenhafter Held sein und nur Gutes tun. Sonst ist man halt wirklich schlecht geworden. Dementsprechend hatte man weniger Zugriff. Es ging so weit, dass man nachher nicht mehr in Städte gehen konnte, wenn man zu böse war. Weil die Wachen einen erkannt haben. Hier, du wirst gesucht, ich erschlage dich jetzt. Das waren so die ersten interaktiven Welten. Daraus entstanden, das waren neun Teile, bis Ultima 9 ging es, glaube ich.
Es gab diverse, ja.
Ich habe sie alle gespielt. In verschiedenen Qualitäten auch, muss man sagen. Und die erste Revolution war eigentlich dann die Online-Variante davon. Die hieß Ultima Online. Auch vom selben Machern. Und war das erste sogenannte Massive Online-Spiel mit einem erfolgreichen Geschäftskonzept dahinter. Und das war hochprofitabel, dieses Spiel. Und hat die gesamte Ära der MMOGs, wie sie heißen, Multiplayer Massive Online-Spiele, eingeleitet. Und der Spitzenkönig momentan in der westlichen Welt, wohl gemerkt, in Asien gibt es größere, ist World of Warcraft mit zehn Millionen Spielern.
Du hast jetzt gesagt, die Deutschen sind zu Technik verliebt. Und das hat sich auch auf die Spielesszene übersetzt. Also in der Art, und Weise, die man programmiert hat. Und die USA, zum Beispiel Ultima, hat sich mehr am Inhalt orientiert. Haben wir das spielerische im eigentlichen Sinne betont? Kann man das so festhalten?
Die Amerikaner waren immer Spieldesigner und nicht Spieltechniker. Als ich in der Industrie schon Karriere gemacht habe, weil wir viele amerikanische Firmen in Deutschland vertrieben haben, sind die sehr oft auf uns zugekommen, wenn sie technische Hilfe brauchten. Hier läuft unser Spiel nicht auf dem Amiga. Das läuft nur auf einen Megabyte-Speicher, nicht auf 12 Kilo. Das war damals mit Speicherweiterung Jahr und Nein. Wir haben es so programmiert, dass es dann doch lief. Weil sie technisch gesehen nicht fit waren. Das liegt daran, dass die amerikanischen Spielefirmen sehr oft von Brettspielefirmen sich historisch entwickelt haben. Da waren viele Brettspiele-Designer da, die die Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspiele oder ihre Brettspiele in Computerspiele umgesetzt haben. Ein ganz berühmter Zittmeier. Das sind Brettspiel-Designer. Sein Civilization und sein Colonization, was sie alles gemacht haben, sind Umsetzungen von Brettspielen. Da kommt das Ganze her, eher vom Design her. Technisch orientiert waren die Amerikaner in der Richtung noch nie. Das kam erst später.
Was hat diese technische Orientierung, wie hat sich das jetzt in den Spielen niedergeschlagen? Was ist jetzt der Ausdruck dessen?
Dass in Deutschland die Spielkonzepte veraltet waren, aber die Technologien immer besser als der Rest. Wir hatten den typischen Ansatz damals, hier ist ein geiles Spiel, aber ich kann es besser. Ich kann es besser hieß in Deutschland, ich mache genau dasselbe Spiel, nur technisch besser. Was man vergessen hat, ist, das Spiel war schon am Markt. Wenn ihr seins am Markt war, ein Jahr später, interessierte das niemand mehr, auch wenn es technisch besser war.
Weil die Leute am Ende mehr Interesse am Spiel haben.
Und es war ja zuerst da, man hat es ja schon gespielt, warum will ich denn das gleiche Spiel nochmal kaufen? Es war damals sogar eine ganze Zeit lang so, ich glaube es waren knapp 5, 6 Jahre, dass deutsche Spiele kopiert haben. Also kopiert, das wirklich nachprogrammiert. Da gab es einen Arcade-Automaten. Also mein größter Hit am Anfang war wirklich ein Clone des Arcade-Automaten Air-Type. Air-Type war da so ein Ballerspiel, ein ganz tolles, das war revolutionär, an dem Ballerspiel war, es war nicht nur Stubide rumfliegen und alles abschießen, es war ein sogenannter Side-Scroller, ich weiß nicht, ob das was sagt.
Also von links nach rechts wie Defender halt so, wo man die ganze Zeit so endliche Weile.
Genau, und es scrollt automatisch, das heißt, die neuen Gegner kommen alle automatisch rein, man schießt sie alle ab. Das revolutionäre an Defender war, er hatte undockbare Waffen, die man auch wieder loswerden konnte. Und da gab es so einen internen Wettbewerb zwischen mir, einer anderen Cracker-Gruppe und einer dritten, ein Spiel zu machen, was genauso ist. Also wir haben es nachprogrammiert. Und meins sah fast 1 zu 1 aus, aber ich war da schon im Jobwechsel zu dieser Firma. Während die Cracker-Gruppe hatte ihr Spiel schon fast fertig. Das war so ein exzellentes Ballastspiel. Entschuldigung. Und als ich dann zu der Firma gewechselt bin, habe ich dann deren Spiel genommen, habe gesagt, ich verträube euch das, weil ich war ja jetzt an der Winkungsleiter von Rainbow Arts und Soft Golf, wie es damals hieß, das war 1987. Ich bin hingegangen, diese Cracker-Gruppe hieß damals Light Circle, die waren eine der führenden in Köln, und habe dann das Spiel vertrieben. Wir haben das nachher Katakis genannt, weil wir hatten rein zufällig ein anderes Spiel auf C64, was ähnlich war, hat damit dann nichts zu tun, war nur der gleiche Name. Dann haben wir jetzt beides auf den Markt gebracht. Und Katakis war das erste Spiel, das ich produziert habe für die und das war ein Riesenhit auf Amiga. Und aus dieser Cracker-Gruppe, die haben danach noch die eRTAB-Umsetzung gemacht, die offizielle, also aus der Kopie wurde sozusagen der offizielle Auftrag, den Automaten zu konvertieren, damals für Activision, die haben die Rechte gekauft gehabt. Dann natürlich dann mit den Nachfolgeprodukten und Tarrican. Die gleiche Gruppe hat Tarrican genommen, aber um sich zu distanzieren zwischen Cracker und zwischen Kreativen, haben sie sich umbenannt in Factor V. Und Factor V ist einer, der seit 20 Jahren der Top-Programmierteam, die wir haben, sitzen zwischen USA und machen halt Konsolenspiele. Und die kommen aber auch aus dieser Hacker-Cracker-Szene, genau aus dem gleichen historischen Aspekt.
Das hast du ja schon angesprochen. Rechte, so Ideen klauen, kopieren hatten wir schon so ein bisschen. Das hat aber einen zu dem Zeitpunkt erst mal gar nicht interessiert, oder?
Nein, es gab A keine Rechtsprechung, B gab es keinerlei Interessen, weil das Business noch nicht so groß war, dass das auch aufgefallen ist. Und C, es störte niemanden. Es gab sicherlich wieder Probleme. Ich habe selber damals drei Rechtswerte mitbekommen, wo große Firmen mit Anwälten aufgetaucht sind und eingeschritten sind. Das eine war Carthages selber. Carthages kam zu dem Zeitpunkt auf den Markt, wo Activision die Rechte gekauft hat, und jeder hat darauf gewartet. Und die ganzen Zeitschriften, auch die engsten, haben gesagt, guck mal hier, das ist viel besser als R-Type. Und das hat Activision natürlich gestunken, weil die haben eine Menge Geld für die Lizenz gezahlt, und dann haben sie Rainbows verklagt. Und die Einigung war, dass wir denen die R-Type-Konvertierung machen und dafür sie uns nicht verklagen.
Das ist ja noch eine relativ freundliche Ausgang. Das würde ich ja heute nicht immer immer draufsetzen.
Nein, es gibt noch ein anderes Beispiel aus der 1987. Ich kam gerade zur Firma, da war das Spiel fast fertig. Programmiert von Thomas Herzla und Armin Gessert. Zwei ganz alte Hasen. Das hieß Gianas Sisters. Das kennt heute noch fast jeder aus der 1980er.
Ja, das ist sehr beliebt bei den Amiga-Geborenen.
War ein Riesenhit. Wer hätte sich damals schon fast millionenfach verkauft, hätte die englische Werbungentur nicht etwas übertrieben. Die englische Werbungentur ist hingegangen in England und hat in den Zeitschriften Werbung gemacht. Das hieß Giana Sisters Moving Over Brothers. Mit der Anspielung, das ist besser als Mario Brothers. Giana Sisters war ein Mario-Klon. Nur mit Mädchen und einer Grafik. Das hat Nintendo eigentlich gestunken. Ihnen wäre es egal gewesen, dass das Spiel auf PC war. Aber dass sie ihren Mario angehen, war ein Riesenproblem. Es dauerte gerade zwei Wochen, da war das Spiel vom Markt. Da kam die mit ihrer gesamten Anwachtskanzlei an.
Aber es ist trotzdem noch verkauft worden, oder nicht? Giana Sisters hat seinen Kultstatus nur durch Rob-Kopien bekommen?
Im Nachhinein sowieso. Der Initialverkauf war riesig. Es dauerte ein bisschen, aber ich glaube, es war nur knapp ein, zwei Monate auf dem Markt. Dann muss es zurückgezogen werden.
Mit der Argumentation, dass es so ist wie Mario?
Genau.
Nur weil sie selber darauf hingewiesen haben, haben sie sich den Ärger erst eingefangen. Hätten sie das Morning aufgemacht, wären sie vielleicht noch davongekommen.
Nicht nur davongekommen, es wäre Nintendo egal gewesen. Nintendo vergisst nie. Nintendo hat zehn Jahre später noch dieses Thema im Kopf gehabt. Wenn Leute zu Nintendo gehen und sagen, wie haben die Giana Sisters das gemacht, sind sie sofort auf der schwarzen Liste zu sagen. Das ist eine japanische Firma, die hat Mammut-Gedächtnis. Das waren schon Rechtsfälle damals, aber nur weil ein kommerzielles Interesse da war, waren aber eher die Ausnahme.
Ich würde noch mal zurückgehen und kurz beleuchten, wie sich diese Computerspiele-Szene entwickelt hat. Ich nehme an, es gab noch einige andere Leute, wie du das gemacht hast, die sich darauf gestürzt haben. Ich kann mich noch erinnern, in meinem Umfeld gab es Leute, die sagten, Computerspiele. Damals erinnere ich mich auch noch, es gab relativ schnell schon eine Trennung zwischen Leuten, die gerne programmiert haben, und Leuten, die Computerspiele programmieren. Das war zumindest mein subjektiver Eindruck damals. Die hatten auch immer relativ wenig miteinander zu tun.
Ja, weil das eine war einfacher als das andere. Also Computerspiele programmieren ist sehr schwierig, das andere Programmieren ist sehr einfach. Sag ich jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen. Es ist anders, heutzutage muss man es differenzieren. Das wächst immer mehr zusammen. Aber damals war es halt schon so, dass wenn man eine normale Anwendung von jemanden geschrieben hat, war das schon relativ einfach zu machen. Als Programmierer, der sich auskannte. Ein Spiel zu programmieren ist sehr, sehr schwierig, weil es ja alle Ressourcen des Rechners braucht gleichzeitig. Und das ist mit einer Büroanwendung nicht der Fall. Ich habe damals programmiert für eine Firma, die brauchte ein Lageristenprogramm, um ihre Millionen von Schraubentypen zu verwalten. Das war ein großer Schraubenhersteller. Das war vom Anspruch her super gering. Ich sage es mal, Auslastung von meinem Gehirn 15%. Aber die Bezahlung war 15-mal höher als in der Spielebranche. Aber es hat auch keinen Spaß gemacht. Während Spiele programmieren macht viel mehr Spaß, da ist das optische Feedback sofort da. Generell, diese gesamte Entwicklung, diese Unterschiedspiel- und konventionelle Programmierung, ist so stark gewesen, dass die Spieleindustrie in Deutschland sich lange Zeit geweigert hat, sich konventionelle Software-Methoden anzueignen, die mit Erfolg schon bei SAP oder bei anderen großen Software-Riesen im Einsatz sind.
Zum Beispiel?
Ganz normal. Ich meine, Agile Development oder Scrum oder die Projektplanung oder Coding-Standards und viele andere Sachen, Kleinigkeiten. Da sträuben sie sich dagegen, weil sie sagen, das funktioniert bei uns gar nicht. Wenn auch konventionelle Programmierer kommen, die sehr gut sind, Spitzenleute in die Spielindustrie, die kriegen Vorurteile an den Kopf wie sonst was. In die Richtung, die können nichts. Dabei ist es inzwischen so, dass sich das immer mehr angeglichen hat.
Sie haben erst mit 15 angefangen zu proben.
Heutzutage ist es noch schwierig. Wir haben damals immer gelacht, weil es gab Informatik-Studenten, die bei der Bewerbung hier, ich habe Informatik studiert, und dann fragten wir ihn, was er schon programmiert hat, und dann hat er seine Diplomarbeit und seine anderen Sachen gezeigt, aber er kann sonst nicht programmieren. Das ist dann schon so ein Unikum in Deutschland gewesen. Die besten Programmierer, die wir immer hatten, waren immer Handwerker. Die hatten eine klassische Ausbildung. Das waren die besten Programmierer, die ich hatte. Einer war Kunsthofschlosser, der andere Maschinenschlosser. Das waren die zwei besten, die ich jemals hatte. Das ist ein Zeichen gewesen, weil du brauchst jemanden, der sehr flexibel ist, der kann zu dransetzen an Hardcore, zeitkritischen Routinen, den kann zu dransetzen an algorithmischen Geschichten, 3D-Grafikprogrammierung oder andere Geschichten. Wissen Sie zu Systemprogrammierung? Der muss flexibel sein. In Deutschland, wo wir mit sehr kompakten Teams und kleinen Budgets gearbeitet haben, ist es heute ein bisschen anders in den größeren Teams. Aber so ist es. Heutzutage gab es Spezialisten für verschiedene Dinge.
Aber man muss ja eigentlich sehr universell sein können. Also damals, wir und unser Damals, also am Anfang war es ja auch noch so, man hat ein Spiel alleine oder mit einer sehr kleinen Gruppe entwickelt. Das heißt, man musste sich um alles kümmern. Man musste irgendwie die Grafik machen, man musste den Sound machen, man musste das ganze Spiel sich ausdenken, man musste User-Interaction machen, man musste keine Ahnung, bis hinten seine eigenen Fronts designen.
Ich sage nur Manfred Trenns. Manfred Trenns hat damals Turrican ganz alleine gemacht. Er hat den Sound gemacht, die Grafik gemacht und die Programmierung.
Was ist das für ein Spiel?
Turrican war damals auf C64 ein Megahit, den er geschaffen hat. Es gibt heute noch Remakes und keine Ahnung, was davon ist. Es war einer der Megastar-Amiga-Spiel, die entstanden sind damals bei Rainbow Arts. Und warum ging es dabei? Ein cooler Soldat, der mit 8 Wege-Scrolling durch eine Riesenlandschaft. Die noch nie da gewesen ist, war rekordmäßig hoch. Mehr konnte der C64 eigentlich nicht. Das war damals der technische Marsch, den sich alle gemessen haben.
Eigentlich konnte er doch nur 8.
Nein, er konnte viel mehr.
Also er konnte offiziell 8.
Offiziell hat er nur 8, hardwaremäßig verdrahtet. Was man gemacht hat, ist, dass man per sogenannten Raster interrappt. Der Bildschirm wurde ja zahlenmäßig aufgebaut. Aber an einer gewissen Zeile ist ein Interrupt gekommen, wo eine Routine angesprungen worden ist. Und er konnte das Sprite, was er drüber ist, was er schon gemalt worden ist, wieder hernehmen und drunter nochmal malen.
Und das alte ist ja nicht verschwunden, weil es war ja noch da. Weil das nächste Mal die Rasterzeile wieder da oben ist, hat er wieder zurückgeschaltet. Das heißt, man musste irgendwie hinkriegen, dass nie mehr als 8 an einem horizontalen Bereich sind.
Exakt. Spite Multiplexing nannte man das damals. Und bei manchen Trends war der Meister drin. Zudem hat er natürlich noch die normale Grafiker genommen. Das ist eine Charakter-Set. Und hat halt die Sachen da verschoben. Die ganzen Kugeln waren zum Beispiel so gemacht. Die flogen so schnell, da merkt man nicht, dass die immer 8 Pixel weit geflogen sind. Aber das hat man damals so angestellt. Aber das war halt so die Ein-Mann-Show. Das größte Team, das ich damals hatte, waren 7 Leute. Das waren also 3 Programmierer, 2 Grafiker und 1 Designer. Das war schon eins der tollsten Projekte damals, die wir gemacht haben. Das hatte Kosten von 500.000 DM in der Produktion.
Wir sind immer noch in den 80er Jahren, oder?
Das war 1989, genau. Also Ende der 80er. Das war damals Amiga, Atari ST und PC. Das hat sich aber 85.000 Mal verkauft, zum Vollpreis. Und damals unverändert wie heute.
Was war der Vollpreis dann?
89 Mark. Wenn man da mal runterrechnet, 50 Mark mal die 80.000. Das war ein gutes Geschäft. Und das ist heute noch gut. Ich bekomme heute noch ab und an E-Mails von Leuten, die das heute noch spielen. Mean-Ugly Dirty Sportsies, Smuts, war ein Fantasy-Sportspiel. Da hat man gemerkt, dass die Mühe sich gelohnt hat. Auch wenn die Firma nachher ins Trudeln kam. Aber es war ganz interessant, woher das alles kam. Es kam nicht nur aus der Cracker-Szene. Da gab es zwei verschiedene Bewegungen. Das eine war die Cracker-Szene, die selber Spiele gemacht hat. Und das andere waren Geschäftsleute, die in der Spielebranche selber Geschäft machen wollten. Weil der eine mit dem anderen zu reden war ja nicht ganz einfach. Weil da waren die Freaks, die raubkopiert haben und mit sehr viel technischem Know-how geredet haben, meistens nicht kommunikativ waren. Also mit Business-Leuten sehr schlecht umgehen konnten.
Ja, das Nerd-Problem.
Oft über den Tisch gezogen worden ist. Da gab es die andere Seite. Und ich war einer der wenigen, die beides konnte. Ich habe also immer von unserer Gruppe in der Münchner Gruppe die Titel verkauft, weil ich eine freche Schnauze hatte. Und ich konnte mit den Business-Leuten reden. Und das Talent hat mich dann auch dazu gebracht, als ich studiert habe, gerade mal zwei Semester, bin ich halt rausgeworben worden. Physik. Ja, ganz schlimm. Würde ich auch nicht wieder machen. Aber im zweiten Semester, ich habe bei den Semesterferien für diese Firma gearbeitet. Ich habe dann auf den Cracker-Treffen geguckt, wer hatte gute Spiele? Und habe gesagt, ich kaufe dir das ab, wir vertreiben das. Und die Firma war so angetan von dem Job, den ich da gemacht habe, dass sie mich aus dem Studium raus gekauft hat. Ganz normal, ich biete dir das gehalten, Firmenwagen, und dann war die Sache gegessen. Dann habe ich gesagt, okay, gehe ich da halt hin. Und das war damals die Firma Rainbow Arts, eine Tochter der Softgold. Und Softgold war ein Unternehmen der Sunrise-Gruppe. Alles komische Namen, aber halt alte Geschichte.
So hießen sie aber damals.
So hießen sie. Und die waren in Düsseldorf bzw. in Karst. Und da habe ich dann die Titel angeschleppt. Ich war da vier Jahre lang und habe über 50 Titel produziert. Und damals waren halt die Anfangstitel immer nur ein Mann. Nachher waren das so zwei, drei Mann-Teams. Aber das größte Projekt ganz am Schluss waren nachher sieben Leute. Das war die Zeit. Und sieben Leute war schon eine Menge. In den USA saßen schon 20 an einem Produkt zur gleichen Zeit. Wir haben das immer gesehen. Weil Softgold hat etwas erfunden. Die waren ganz wichtig für den deutschen Markt. Die haben nämlich die Lokalisierung erfunden. Das klingt jetzt komisch. Das spiele man auch auf Deutsch-Spanisch. Genau. Die haben amerikanische Titel genommen, haben sie übersetzt ins Deutsche und in den Laden gestellt. Nämlich in Karstadt, Herth, Tihorten, wie sie damals alle hießen. Und haben damit den deutschen Markt entwickelt. Und waren zum großen Teil daran schuld, dass in Deutschland die Spiele so erfolgreich waren. Unter anderem haben wir am Anfang Electronic Arts, Activision, Ocean, die Microprose, das war damals einer der großen Firmen für Strategie und Simulationen, wir haben vertrieben Lucasfilm Games, wie sie damals noch hießen. LucasArts, die ganzen Adventures, die Abenteuerspiele übersetzt haben. Damit ist der Markt entwickelt worden, aber der so stark entwickelt worden, dass die amerikanischen Firmen gesehen haben, der ist so groß der Markt, wie machen das es selber? Das heißt, dann kam Electronic Arts und hat in Deutschland eine Firma aufgekauft, Kingsoft, die Firma, an der wir unsere ersten Spiele verkauft haben, hat gesagt, wir machen das es selber in Deutschland. Und so sind Stück für Stück die amerikanischen Kunden weggebrochen von Softgold, und so ging Softgold sozusagen einen Bach runter.
So, jetzt versuche ich jetzt noch mal kurz, dass wir nicht zu weit, das ist ja alles super interessant, mit der Größe und dem Programmierer-Appeal. Also diese Programmierer, diese kleinen Programmierer-Gruppen waren einfach, ist ja klar, extrem universelle Programmierer, die also wirklich auch eine Menge konnten.
Und sehr hardware-nah.
Was heute noch jemand kann.
Das stimmt. Es gibt ja auch dieses Phänomen, dass Software irgendwie nicht schneller wird. Also mittlerweile habe ich einen Computer, der was weiß ich, wie viele tausendmal theoretisch schneller ist als mein erster Rechner. Aber ich vermisse immer noch so die Snappiness von so ein paar Programmen, die ich vor 20 Jahren benutzt habe. Die habe ich irgendwie immer noch nicht wieder gesehen. Das kann man sich ja im Spielbereich gar nicht erlauben.
Nein, also Microsoft Word ist ja heute immer noch so langsam wie damals. Damals dieses ganze Wordstar. Da kommen ja auch diese ganzen Künstler wie Ctrl-V und sowas. Microsoft Word ist heute immer noch so langsam wie damals. Und das liegt daran, dass immer mehr Schichten drauf gekommen sind. Da gibt es ja immer mehr APIs und Software-Schichten, die dazwischen hängen. Da ganz unten ist DOS, ein BIOS und dann DOS. Und dann kommt da diese Windows Kernel Library. Und drüber ist dann die API für Fenster. Und drüber die API für GUI. Und das verlangsamt das Ganze ja immer wieder. Spieleprogrammierer mussten immer sehr hartweiner programmieren, um die optimale Geschwindigkeit rauszuholen. Weil die Dinger waren damals halt nicht die schnellsten. Um Spiele richtig schnell zu machen, hat man riesen Vorteile gehabt technisch gesehen, wenn man sehr hartweiner programmiert hatte. Und deswegen kannten die Programmierer alle Register auswendig. Von den Hardware-Chips, die haben die Chip-Bekommutation gelesen. Sie kannten das Timing-Verhalten der Chips und wussten genau, dass wenn ich den Chip anfeuere und in dem Augenblick den Chip gleichzeitig anfeuere, gibt es einen Effekt, der eigentlich nicht vorhergesehen ist. Und ich habe einen ganz tollen Effekt auf dem Bildschirm. Das haben die alles gemacht damals. Also ganz verrückte Sachen. Das ist heute gar nicht mehr möglich, weil es gar nicht mehr auf Anrechnern läuft. Damals war ja so...
Und weil man auch gar nicht mehr diese Nähe zum Rechnern gar nicht mehr bekommt, weil das Betriebssystem das einem gar nicht mehr bietet.
Nein, nicht nur das, sondern der Rechner ist ja auch gar nicht mehr schattatisiert. Damals war ja der Amiga schattatisiert. Es gab einen Amiga-Punkt von einer Firma, von denen kam auch das Betriebssystem. Das ist der Vorteil, den Apple heute auch hat. Hardware und Software aus einer Firma, die können eine Menge reißen. Ich sage es mal, die haben jetzt schon das dritte Mal den Prozessor geändert. Und alle Programme laufen immer noch. Das kriegt Intel nie hin oder Microsoft. Das geht auf dem PC ja gar nicht, weil ich habe ja ATI, Nvidia, ich habe einen Intel, einen AMD, ich habe DDR 800 Speicher oder DDR 1033 Speicher und keine Ahnung, was es da alles für ganz tolle Basswörter gibt inzwischen. Wenn ich da hardware-nah reingehe, dann müsste ich ja für 1200 verschiedene Hardware-Komponenten das bauen, programmieren. Das kann ich ja gar nicht. Und deswegen muss da eine API dazwischen sein. Das ist der Vorteil des PCs, flexibler Hardware drunter, deswegen ist er auch billig. Nachteil ist, ich kann nicht mehr hardware-nah programmieren.
Trotzdem laufen ja Spiele da drauf.
Trotzdem laufen Spiele drauf, dank der 3D-Grafikkarten und dadurch, dass Intel, AMD, Microsoft und die ganzen Grafikkartenhersteller gesehen haben, was der Treibender Faktor ist. Das ist die Spieltechnologie auf PC.
Guter Punkt, da muss man auf jeden Fall drauf kommen. Darum wollte ich jetzt auch ein bisschen anspielen. Also nochmal kurz zurückzublättern. Also 80er Jahre geprägt von einem allgemeinen Aufbruch und vor allem auch durch diese Durchdringung des Haushalts mit Computern über diesen Heimcomputer, wie man immer so schön sagt. C64, VC20, der Amiga, auch der Atari ST, zu einem gewissen Maß und noch ein paar andere Sachen, haben sozusagen eigentlich diese Zeit dominiert und dafür gesorgt, dass halt ein Rechner irgendwie zumindest in jedes Kinderzimmer gekommen ist, wenn auch gleich nicht unbedingt in jedes Arbeitszimmer. Und das hat dann eben auch so eine neue Garde von Programmierern hervorgebracht, von dem eben ein Teil gesagt hat, ich will spielen mit meinem Computer und ich habe da irgendwie auch einen gewissen Anspruch. Also solche Universal-Programmierer, ich habe halt immer gemerkt, Leute, die sich wirklich für die Interna interessieren, entwickeln einfach ein ganz anderes Verständnis auch für den Computer an sich und natürlich auch für, wie man ihn eigentlich benutzen will, was dann letztlich auch viel von dem Appeal eines Spiels ausmacht. Aber das ist natürlich nicht alles, weil das ist ja auch eigentlich nur so die Technik-Seite, die du schon angesprochen hast, dass es in Deutschland so stark gewesen sein soll.
Es hat Vor- und Nachteile. Es hat Nachteile, auch zu viel zu wissen, weil man dann zu sehr in der Technik denkt, anstatt komplett losgelöst von der Technik seinem Design-Kopf freien Lauf zu lassen. Es gab viele Sachen in der Entwicklung von meinen Spielen, wo Programmierer gesagt haben, das geht nicht. Und ich musste ihnen dann Wege zeigen, wie es dann doch geht. Weil sie zu sehr in ihrer Kostruktur gedacht haben oder in Hardware-Problemen oder in anderen Sachen. Er hat beides Vor- und Nachteile. Die Flexibilität des technisch orientierten Programmierers ist die, er versteht das gesamte System, er weiß, wo die Fehler liegen sofort, weil er halt teilweise runter bis zur CPU genau weiß, was da läuft. Ein Programmierer, der sehr abgehoben denkt und weit drüber hinaus, er hat auch Vorteile. Er bringt zum Beispiel gewisse Sachen schneller hin, weil er halt nicht so technisch verliebt runtergeht, was immer aufwendiger ist. Und er denkt sehr viel strukturierter oder breitfächiger. Er weiß von Nachteil, wo es die Leute einsetzen, wo ihre Stärken und Schwächen sind.
Wie ist man denn so damals rangegangen an so ein Spiel? Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so ein Baller-Game hacken wollte, das werden sich ja viele heute auch noch fragen, wo fängt man an? Was ist denn der Kern, das Herz?
In den 80ern war der Kern immer Technologie first. Das heißt, man hat gesagt, ich will jetzt ein Ballerspiel machen, also muss erst mal ein Horizontalscroller her. Und dann muss der Sprite-Multiplexer her, eben erklärt. Und ich gucke, wie viel ich schüssig auf dem Bildschirm zaubere. Dann eine Kollisionsabfrage rein. Und erst wenn das alles lief, hat man sich ums Design gekümmert. In den USA war es genau umgekehrt. Da hat man sich zuerst ums Design gekümmert und dann geschaut, mit welcher Technologie kann ich das bedienen. Und das hing den deutschen Programmierern fast ein Jahrzehnt an, dass das so ist. Es ist auch oft so, dass Programmierer keine guten Spiele-Designer sind. Nichts gegen Programmierer, aber es ist öfter so. Es gibt wenig Ausnahmen, weil sie zu sehr in die Ko-Struktur denken. Es ist meistens immer eine Teamarbeit. Damals ging das noch, wenn man Spiele gemacht hat, die so technisch orientiert waren. Ich sage mal, so ein High-End-Baller-Spiel, wo ganz viel auf dem Bildschirm passieren muss, ist technisch sehr anspruchsvoll. Ergo ist ein technischer Programmierer auch ein sehr guter Designer von diesen Spielen. Ist es aber nicht so, spielt die Technik eben nicht so die große Rolle in so einem Spiel, wie in einem Rollenspiel oder ein Abenteuerspiel, dann fangen an Programmierer schlechte Designer zu werden. Da muss man ein bisschen unterscheiden, ist es technisch getrieben oder ist es designgetrieben, das Spiel? Und das sieht man ja heute noch. First-Person-Shoots sind sehr technisch getrieben und die Rollenspiele sind halt sehr inhaltlich getrieben.
Diese Spielescene, die sich jetzt so in Deutschland entwickelt hat, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, war das am Anfang noch eine sehr geschlossene Gesellschaft. Und dann über diese Lokalisierungsgeschichte gab es sozusagen die Aufmerksamkeit der Firmen in Amerika, die gesagt haben, prima, in Deutschland kann man auch Spiele verkaufen, man muss sich nur auf Deutsch machen, kann man das so sagen. Wie hat sich denn das so, ich versuche gerade so ein Verständnis dafür zu entwickeln, wie das so ist. Mein Verständnis ist, am Anfang gab es viele kleine Buden mit zwei, drei, vier, fünf Leuten, die sich irgendwie zusammengefunden haben. Es gab Vertriebsfirmen.
Es gab noch nicht mehr Buden. Buden heißt ja gleichzeitig, es ist eine Firma. Irgendwie eingetragen oder angemeldet oder sowas.
Kellerräume waren es wahrscheinlich mehr.
Es gab Hobby. Alles war rein nur Hobby-getrieben in Deutschland. Die Programmierung an sich, die gesamten Spiele, die Rainbow das vertrieben hat, sind alles von Hobbyisten erstellt worden. Fast durch die Bank. Da gab es keinen Entwickler, der eine Firma hatte, der von uns gearbeitet hat. Das waren alles Studenten, Schüler, Hobbyisten, teilweise auch ältere Leute, die abends feakmäßig programmiert haben. Da kamen die ganzen Spiele her. Man konnte Spiele in einem sehr viel kürzeren Zeitraum erstellen. Da hat man sich mal hingezogen und gesagt, wir brauchen jetzt einen neuen Shooter. Nach drei Monaten wäre er fertig. Das ist ja heute ein Traum. Fast alles von Hobbyisten. Da gab es ein, zwei Geschäftsleute in Gütesloh. Das ist die Historie, die ich kenne. In Gütesloh gab es zwei Geschäftsleute, die befreundet waren, die gesagt haben, wir vertreiben jetzt auch Spiele. Wir stellen sie professionell in den Laden und machen damit auch mit Geld. Sie wollten diese Schüler, Studenten, diese ganzen Talente, die da waren, die Produkte kaufen. Meistens zum Festpreis. Dann haben sie die Dinge dann im Laden gestellt und haben damit Geschäft gemacht, weil durch die Stückzahl dementsprechend Geld reinkam. Die haben sich dann ein bisschen zerstritten. Die eine Firma hieß Rainbow Arts in Gütesloh und die andere hieß Magic Bites. Große Konkurrenz, auch teilweise Abwerbeversuche. Da hat man vor Magic Bites eine Plakatwand hingeschrieben. Hier, wir bezahlen euch besser. Bei uns ist es Paradies, bei euch ist alles so schrecklich. Ganz witzige Geschichten damals. Und dann ist Rainbow Arts aufgekauft worden von dieser Softcore Sunrise-Firmengruppe in Düsseldorf. Ist dann rübergezogen nach Düsseldorf, dadurch war der räumliche Abstand da. Und immer, wenn diese Firmen relativ groß geworden sind, gab es immer Ableger. Da gab es ein erfolgreiches Team, das hat ein paar Hits gemacht und das Team hat gesagt, das machen wir selbstständig. Daraus entstand zum Beispiel die Firma Bluebite. Giana Sisters wurde von Thomas Herzler programmiert und von Armin Gessert. Thomas Herzler hat dann Bluebite gegründet. Das ist die Firma, die die Siedler vertrieben hat. Armin Gessert hat Spellbound gegründet und hat das Parados und ein paar andere Firmen gemacht. Die existiert heute noch, einer der ältesten Entwickler, die wir haben. Das ist dann immer wie so eine Samenexplosion. Und wenn so eine Firma pleite geht vor allem, oder sich aufgelöst hat, wie Bluebite an Ubisoft wurde verkauft, haben sich immer Entwickler drum herum gegründet, aus den Teams heraus. Das ist wie so ein Blumensamen-Effekt, ging das dann. Dann verteilte sich das wieder ein bisschen an den Leuten. Die ersten Entwicklerfirmen, das war Mitte der 90er vielleicht, Anfang der 90er, wo die richtig ersten, ernsthaften Firmen aufkamen. Es gab in den 80er schon ein, zwei Paar Firmen, aber die wurden alle sofort relativ schnell integriert. Also Rainbow Arts damals hat drei Entwickler gekauft. Time Warp, Reline und Golden Goblins. Die waren firmiert als GmbH. Reline waren damals drei Leute oder so. Reline aus Hannover. Und wo waren die anderen?
Gab es Hochburgen?
Hochburgen, eigentliches Ruhrgebiet. Wegen Softgold und Bluebyte. Das war die Hochburg nachher. Das Ruhrgebiet war anhand der Bevölkerungszahl. Und wir hatten ja noch die Mauer. Da war im Osten gar nichts los. Und in Hamburg gab es gar keinen Spiele-Entwickler. Und irgendwann ist es explodiert und es gibt 10-20 Stück da. Das hängt auch davon ab, wie sich die Stadt um die Tonnen kümmert.
Vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen mehr auf das, worum es eigentlich geht. Nämlich die Spiele selber. Unabhängig von dem, wie sich das so businessmäßig entwickelt hat. Was sind denn in deinen Augen die wichtigsten Meilensteine in den 80er- und 90er-Jahren, die wirklich maßgeblich waren? Ich beliebe immer zu Scherzen, wenn es um Computerspiele geht. Ich kenne immer nur drei Spiele, wo man alle erschießen muss. Da, wo man mit dem Auto durch die Gegend fährt. Und da, wo man die Prozessen retten muss. Das ist ein bisschen fies. Ich weiß so, du weißt, was ich meine. Viele Spiele machen auf den normalen Betrachter den Eindruck, als wäre das immer wieder derselbe Scheiß.
Es ist so, dass sich in der Spielebranche Schubladen entwickeln. Erfolgreiche Konzepte werden Schubladen umgemacht. Genauso wie ich in Hollywood einen Gruselfilm, einen Tanzfilm, einen Actionfilm mache. Genau die gleichen Schubladen gibt es bei uns. Wenn jemand sagt, ich mache einen First-Person-Shooter, muss man gewisse Gesetzmäßigkeiten einbauen, weil es schon einen Industriestandard gibt. Man steuert mit AWDS und mit der Maus. Das kann man nicht anders machen. Wenn man es anders macht, verschützt man die Leute. Solche Schubladen gibt es in allen Medien. Es ist selten, dass jemand neue Schubladen erfindet. Es sind die Spiele, die neue Schubladen erfunden haben, die die wesentlichen Meilensteine sind. Auf Anhieb fallen wir da zwei ein. Einmal war es Elite. Das war eines der wenigen ersten 3D-Spiele auf C64.
Das war auch ein Strategiespiel, oder?
Nein, das war eine Raumschiffsimulation.
Das war nicht auch so verkaufen und handeln?
Genau, man hat ein Raumschiff gehabt. Man konnte handeln und verkaufen. Man konnte damit auch Piratenjagen damit Geld verdienen. Da hat sich eine Geschichte entwickelt. Das war ein Riesenuniversum, wo man rumfliegen konnte. Man hatte so, obwohl ein Planet war nur ein weißer Kreis, hat man wegen der immensen Größe des Universums und weil man überall etwas gefunden hat, wie Meteoriten oder Piraten, die Vorstellung, dass die gesamte Galaxie riesig groß ist. Das war das erste Mal, dass jemand gezeigt hat, dass man mit ganz einfachen Dingen Riesenwelten zeigen kann, wo man drin Spaß hat. Das haben wir ewig gespielt. Das war ein neues Genre in dem Fall. Es hat ganz lange gedauert, bis diese Genres wieder aufgegriffen worden sind, weil es so extrem schwer zu programmieren war. Eine Fortführung davon war nachher Wing Commander. Das war das ganze grafisch opulent aufgemodzt, mit Story und ganz tollen Animationen dabei. Es wurde auf 13 3,5 Zoll Ketten ausgeliefert. Da gab es noch keine CD, davon darf man nicht vergessen. Vor allem gab es damals zwei verschiedene Versionen im Handel. Einmal mit 3,5 Zoll Ketten, einmal mit 5,25 Zoll. Das ist eine alte Geschichte. Und das zweite wichtige Spiel, das man nennen muss, ist SimCity. Dass diese Sandkastenspiele erfunden hat oder mit aufgebaut hat. Da gab es doch viele andere. Es gab Mule, das war ein sehr schönes Spiel, wo man zu fit vor dem Rechner gesessen hat. Und gemeinsam gespielt und gegeneinander.
Ich kann mich nur daran erinnern, das mal gespielt zu haben. Aber ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr, worum es ging.
Aber das hatte so eine tolle Musik. Ja, viele tolle Sachen drin. Das war ein Planet, wo man ein paar Zellen besetzen konnte. Und die hat man angebaut. Und das Ganze ist Mule. Weil, um dort Minen zu bauen und andere Dinge zu machen, hat man so eine Art moderner Roboter-Esel gehabt. Und dann konnte man sich alle in der Stadt treffen und bieten um verschiedene Waren. Und da hat die mal verkauft und solche Sachen. Aber kurz zu Fitt spielen, das war schon...
Irgendjemand hat hier ein GSM-Telefon. Ach, wieder ein iPhone. Da kommen wir gleich noch mal drauf zu sprechen.
Und das Mühlewein hat das Meistenstein. Aber genauso wie solche Sachen wie Seven Cities of Gold oder Heart of Africa, das waren alle Spiele, diese Forscher-Spiele, das waren die Grundlagen für den Erfolg von Anno von heute. Wenn man jetzt Anno sieht, einer der Megahits aus Deutschland, die basieren eigentlich auf diesen alten Spielprinzipien. Nur moderner aufgemacht. Eine Mischung zwischen Entdeckerspiel, Forscher-Spiel und Handelsspiel. Das ist so diese Mischung, das ist so ein Spielthema, was in Deutschland immer sehr erfolgreich geht, wenn man es richtig verkauft.
Würdest du das jetzt als, ich meine, ich bin jetzt überrascht, dass du jetzt noch kein einziges Doom oder so genannt hast. Wir sind in den 80ern. Aber gab es noch, ich meine, geballert wurde dann ja nun auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, Castle Wolfenstein war der Urvater der Doom- und Wolfenstein-Serie. Da kam das Ganze her, aber das war noch nicht 3D. Lass mich überlegen, wann kamen die ersten...
Muss ja nicht 3D sein. Mir geht es jetzt auch erstmal wirklich mehr um die Spielekonzepte, ob die nun 2D oder 1D oder was auch immer sind.
Die First-Person-Shooter bedingen ja, dass sie 3D sind. Eine der ersten Dinge, die da kamen, weil es noch keine 3D-Grafikkarten gab, war nur auf PC, auf VGA gab es plötzlich Techniken, einen 3D-Raum sehr schnell darzustellen, ohne eben die verlangsamende Geometrie zu berechnen. Da war Wolfenstein das erste Spiel, das das gemacht hat, oder sehr erfolgreich war. Das war ein Shareware-Spiel von Apogee. Shareware war das erste Rittel des Spiels umsonst. Man konnte es sich einfach irgendwo holen, auf Diskat oder sonst wo, oder auch kopieren. Wenn man die anderen Episoden spielen wollte, musste man dann kaufen. Das war ein Riesenerfolg. Die Gründer von Apogee sind recht reich damit geworden mit dem ganzen Thema. Sie sind heute noch sehr einflussreich in der Shooter-Szene. Wenn man es 3D-Rams anschaut, ist er einer der Apogee-Gründer, Unreal-Macher und so was. Das kommt alles daher. Und Doom war das erste Spiel, was halbwegs sehr schöne 3D-Grafik auf den Bildschirm brachte, ohne 3D-Karte. Und das kann man als den ersten echten Shooter bezeichnen. In Wufenstein war noch ein Tick Rollenspiel drin und andere Geschichten. Aber Doom war das erste, ich laufe hier durch, und letztendlich alles Niederspiel. Das ist grafisch aber immer noch so gemacht, dass die Wände und das Verlies 3D waren ganz toll, aber die Figuren waren immer noch so genannte Sprites, die vergrößert worden sind. Das ging technisch noch nicht anders.
Wie 3D war denn das Spiel eigentlich? Gab es da wirklich eine 3D-Engine, oder war das alles nur getrickst?
Das Rendering war getrickst, aber das Verlies oder der Level, wo man sich drin bewegt hatte, war reale 3D und wurde auch so berechnet. Aber sie haben in dem Fall getrickst, weil sie viele der Berechnungen im Vorhinein gemacht haben. Wenn man sich irgendwo hinstellt, muss man eigentlich nur das auf den Bildschirm bringen, was man sieht in der Kamera. Da haben sie Tricks angewendet, sogenannte BSP-Trees, aber das ist zu technisch.
Das ist nicht zu technisch, ich will das wissen.
Das sind Binary Partition Trees. Sie haben den gesamten Level in Kuchen-Schnitte geteilt, abhängig von der Sichtbarkeit. Wenn ich mich irgendwo hinstelle und irgendwo was sehe, auch durch eine Tür durch ein Stück, haben sie da einfach einen Schnitt durch den gesamten Level gemacht, also geometrisch, und haben das nochmal abgespeichert. Das heißt, ich konnte von jedem Punkt, den ich bin, in diesem großen Datenwust die Koordinate sehen. Und dieser Datensatz hat mir gesagt, welche Teil ich vom Level überhaupt sehe.
Das heißt, die Sichtbarkeit ist sozusagen vorberechnet, weil die ändert sich ja auch in dem Sinne nicht. Und damit man da schnell drauf zugreifen kann und nicht jetzt irgendwie hinten verborgene Kanten und verborgene Flächen berechnen muss, hat man sich sozusagen einzelne Teile in diesen Baum einsortiert.
Genau, es war natürlich so, weil der Speicher limitiert war, konnte man es natürlich nicht so machen, dass man das alles gespeichert hat. Von hier siehst du das, von hier siehst du das. Und die redundanten Objekte, die identisch waren überall, waren schon gemeinsam. Also es war eine relativ komplexe Datenbankstruktur, die da drin war, mit Pointer auf alle möglichen anderen Teile. Von hier siehst du das, von hier siehst du das, von hier siehst du das. Und das war natürlich dann auch so vorsortiert, dass die Reihenfolge schon vorgegeben war, in welche Reihenfolge ich das rendern soll. Und das hat die ganze Sache sehr schnell gemacht. Erstmal überhaupt zu finden, was muss ich rendern, in welche Reihenfolge muss ich es tun. Und dann konnte ich mich konzentrieren, das schön zu rendern. Man hat also die Geometrieberechnung, was ich gerade sehe, die gesamte Weltenberechnung geopfert, um die Qualität der Darstellung zu erhöhen. Das ist so die Balance, die die gefahren haben. Und das Spiel war sagenhaft schnell. Und war so eins der, sagen wir mal, echten 3D-Spiele damals. Das echte, richtige 3D-Spiel, was es damals gab, also wirklich mit 3D-Geometrie und freier Bewegung. Man konnte in Doom sich ja nur limitiert bewegen. Man konnte ja nur über dem Boden laufen, hüpfen. Man konnte aber nicht, sagen wir mal, an der Decke stehen. Oder mitten im Raum schweben oder sowas. Das ging nicht. Weil das hätte die BSP-Trips durcheinander gebracht. Das erste Spiel, was es damals gab, was richtig 3D war, das haben die Programmierer gar nicht verkauft gekriegt. Ganz interessant. Die waren also wirklich bei 3, 4, 5 riesen Firmen, die das alle abgelehnt haben. Und eine Firma namens Interplay hat es genommen. Dieses Spiel hieß Descent. Descent war das erste richtige 3D-Spiel auf dem PC. Und hat sich verkauft wie warme Semmeln. Und die anderen großen Publis, die es abgelehnt haben, die haben das natürlich bereut. Und das erste Spiel, das ich gespielt habe, was 3D beschleunigt war, optional, damals, das war 96, kam die 3DFX. Das war die erste, die Voodoo-Karte. Der erste Grafikbeschleuniger. Wohlgemerkt war keine Grafikkarte, sondern eine Karte, die immer zusätzlich zur Grafikkarte eingesteckt hat. Das vergessen viele, dass es damals so war. Und das erste Spiel, was man dann zusätzlich 3D beschleunigt spielen konnte, war Tomb Raider.
Lara Croft.
Lara Croft, heute noch bekannt. Das ist eines der ersten Computer-Charaktere, der die Vogue zitiert hat oder das Vogue-Cover. Aber es ist eine andere Geschichte.
Ja, Sex-Sales, nicht wahr? Da sind die anderen nicht drauf gekommen.
Die hatten immer nur hässliche Monster. Ja, damals war alles nur durch Schießen überhaupt. Da gab es auch eine andere Geschichte. Das kommt ja alles parallel zu den Arcade-Automaten. Alles, was in der Arcade stand, war nur Ballerspiele. Da kam dann schnell die Überzeugung her, dass nur Ballerspiele gespielt werden. So eine selbstverwirklichende Wahrheit sozusagen. Andere Spiele haben die Arcade-Besitzer abgelehnt, aufzustellen, weil sie nicht gespielt werden, sondern die Ballerspiele so viel. Da gab es eine Firma aus Japan, die ein Spiel hatte, wo man überhaupt nicht schießt, die hatte Schwierigkeiten, das Ding in die Spielhallen zuzustellen. Dann haben die folgenden Deal gemacht, wir stellen den Automaten bei euch auf, ihr müsst uns überhaupt nichts dafür bezahlen. Die einen teilen bei uns. Wir gucken, ob es funktioniert. Dann haben viele diese Arcade-Besitzer gesagt, man kostet kein Geld. Die mussten damals die Automaten kaufen sonst. Die kosten ja ein Vermögen. Dann hat dieser Arcade-Besitzer, der das als erstes gemacht hat, zwei Tage später angerufen und gesagt, euer Automat ist kaputt, dir taugt nichts. Dann ist die Firma dahin gegangen und hat die Automaten aufgemacht. Als sie diese Tür, die sie damals mit den Coins aufgemacht haben, kam die gesamte Geld in den Gegengeräusch. Da ist so viel Geld drin gewesen, dass diese Coins sozusagen übergelaufen sind, auf die Platine gefallen und dann auf die Marken gefetzt. Und da wussten sie, dass die Sache läuft. Und diese Firma hieß Nintendo, das Spiel ist Donkey Kong, der Finder ist Shigeru Miyamoto und ist der Finder von Mario und Zelda.
Alles klar.
Eine ganz uralte Geschichte, aber sie ist wahr.
Ach so hat sich Nintendo überhaupt erst in die Welt gebracht.
Sie haben davor die Filmexperte seit 1800 paar zerquetschte. Und haben durch Spielkarten ihr erstes Geld gemacht. Und haben relativ gut gelebt. Und das erste Produkt, wo sie so viel Geld gemacht haben, dass sie gesagt haben, jetzt wollen wir mal ein neues Produkt erfinden, war eine Konkurrenz zum Rubik's Cube. Kennst du den noch?
Ja, den kenne ich. Den konnte ich sogar lösen.
Ja, ich auch.
Der hat ziemlich schnell auch.
Meistereinig.
Was ist das denn?
1 Minute Design 42, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, ich bin...
Aber nur mit Graffit eingeschmiert, sonst ging es nicht.
Echt Graffit? Ich habe immer... Was habe ich denn genommen? Nein, ich habe Vaseline reingemacht.
Vaseline ging auch.
Und ich glaube, ich war mal bei... Das will ich aber nicht zu sehr angeben, aber ich war definitiv unter einer Minute.
Als ich meine Mutter fragte, ob ich ein bisschen Vaseline haben kann, hat sie sehr, sehr komisch geguckt. Aber es gab eine Konkurrenz, das war eine Tonne. Das war so eine runde Tonne, die man hin und her schieben konnte. Und man musste farbige Kugeln sortieren. Und die war von Nintendo, die hat sich sehr, sehr gut verkauft. Sie waren echt überrascht, weil sie Spielkarten gemacht haben, plus mal ein Spielzeug, und dann plötzlich neben ihrem normalen Geschäft, was sehr gut läuft, sehr profitabel, hatten sie plötzlich jetzt Geld rumliegen und haben gesagt, jetzt gucken wir mal, was wir noch für Spielzeug machen können. Und dann kam halt diese eine Elektronik-Abteilung von Nintendo und hat gesagt, wir machen so eine Art Atari VCS 2600 und haben das alte NES, Nintendo Entertainment System, auf den Markt gebracht. Während in den USA ja jeder glaubte, Spielkonsolen funktionieren nicht, wegen der großen Atari-Katastrophe, die da passiert ist, waren die Amerikaner, oder generell der westliche Markt, der ja sehr abgetrieben war durch die Amerikaner, sehr abwehrend gegen irgendwelche Videospiele in die Richtung, das funktioniert nicht mehr. Weil da viele haben sich da die Finger verbrannt. Während in Japan das Ding sich so gut verkauft hat, dass die Amerikaner aus Unglauben, damals war es noch schwieriger, Daten aus dem japanischen Markt zu bekommen, da waren immer noch, ich sag es mal, ihr wart ja mal unser Feind. Da haben die Japaner gesagt, wir haben doch hier 10 Millionen Stück davon verkauft in Japan alleine, warum wollt ihr das nicht in den USA haben? Da haben die Amerikaner gesagt, das funktioniert nicht, A und B glauben wir euch nicht, dass ihr 10 Millionen verkauft habt. Und deswegen musste Nintendo in den USA ihre eigenen Firmen gründen, um das zu vertreiben, gegen den großen Widerstand. Aber das ist Historie. Wie gesagt, die Nintendo hat diese Spielkonsolenstrategie, oder wie man diese auf dem Markt bracht, neu erfunden. Hat aus den Fehlern gelernt, was Atari gemacht hat und hat sie profitabel gemacht.
Das ist jetzt ein super interessanter Punkt. Da wollte ich eh noch mal drauf kommen. Jetzt haben wir das so kurz abgetan mit der Atari-Katastrophe. Das sollten wir schon noch mal beleuchten. Computerspiele sind groß geworden in der Arcade, wie man so schön sagt. Die Einkaufs-Shopping-Mall, wo diese Kisten rumstanden. Daher kam der Name. Das wiederum geht zurück auf diese Pinball-Games. Wenn man heute Pinball hört, sagt man sofort Flipper. Jeder hat sofort diese zwei Knöpfe im Kopf. Das macht Flipp, Flipp, Flipp. Ich brauchte auch eine Weile, habe das irgendwann mal in der Müllhalle nachgeschlagen. Ich bin erst darauf gekommen, warum das Pinball heißt. Das waren früher Kisten, wo man oben eine Momel reingeschmissen hat. Dann waren da Nägel im Brett. Das war sozusagen der Ball und die Pins. Dann lief das richtig rein oder nicht?
Die japanische Version davon heißt Pachinko.
Das ist ja unglaublich. Ich war neulich in Japan in einer Pachinkohalle. Ich dachte, ich spinne.
Wie auf einem fremden Planeten.
Es ist wirklich unglaublich. Man kommt da rein, das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen. Pachinkohallen sind Spielhallen. Aber es ist nicht so wie hier, wo ein paar verschlafende Leute vor komischen Jokers spielen. Und dann jemals so eine Tasse drücken. Es ist ein unglaublicher Lärm. Ich habe so etwas noch nie gehört. Es war unfassbar laut da drin. Und dann Unmengen an Leuten, die wie paralysiert vor diesen Pachinko-Maschinen sitzen.
Und jede Altersgruppe.
Pachinko, das ist mit so großen, körbeweise Metallkugeln, die sie da oben reinschmeißen. Ich glaube, man kauft diese Körbe. Ist das richtig? Und wirft die rein, dann hat man so einen Drehknopf, mit dem man eine Feinjustierung machen kann. Eine Stärke für was eigentlich?
Wie stark der Ball rausgekickt wird, der dann oben wieder reinfällt.
Und dann durch diese Pins runterfällt.
Die variieren das ganz leicht, weil sie immer sehen, dass die Kugelnfange ähnlich, nicht immer gleich, aber ähnlich. Und wenn sie einen Tick drehen, versuchen sie, die Kugel so zu fasten, dass sie unten in die großen Punktelöcher reinfällt.
Und das ist da superpopulär. Und die Leute sitzen den ganzen Tag da und drehen am Rad. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Wir kamen aber von einem Pinball-Zehnen.
Ja genau, das ist jetzt die japanische Variante. Die Japaner sind einfach wahnsinnig, was Spiele betrifft. Das ist mir da noch mal aufs Deutlichste klar geworden. Aber es hat angefangen in den USA und die erste Konsole war Atari 2600.
Nee, da gab es davor schon andere. Das waren aber ältere. Das erste modulare Konzept, wo Module reinstecken konnten, was sehr erfolgreich war, war das Atari VCS. Davor gab es schon Spiele, die aus dem gleichen Konzept waren. Aber da waren die Spiele fest eingebaut. Da hat man eine kleine Kiste gehabt, die hat man an den Fernseher reingesteckt und hatte zwei Paddles.
Und die konnte dann pongen?
Der konnte pongen, eine Tennis-Variante, eine Hockey-Variante oder keine Ahnung was. Das waren die ersten Varianten davon. Die erste Variante mit Modulkonzept war von Atari.
Das war aber alles recht erfolgreich eigentlich.
Das war nicht nur erfolgreich, das war ein Phänomen. Da gab es Geschichten, da hat sich ein Programmierer Freitag hingesetzt, also damals waren die Spiele wirklich ein Mann, hat sich Freitag mit einer tollen Idee hingesetzt. Und hat das über das Wochenende fertig programmiert. Am Montag ging er in eine Firma, hat das der Firma gegeben, ich habe ein tolles Spiel. Die haben das zwei Wochen später auf den Markt gebracht. Und der Typ konnte sich zur Ruhe setzen. Weil sie einfach davon 10 Millionen Stück rausgehauen haben. Und die haben sich verkauft. Also fantastische Geschichten mit Höhen und Tiefen. Das ging 3, 4, 5 Jahre gut. Und dann kam die übliche Sättigung. Die Technologie war veraltet. Es gab so viele Spiele im Regal. Jeder hat Spiele gemacht dafür. Es kam wahnsinnig viel Schund raus. Ganz so plötzlich wollte die Dinger niemand mehr haben. Und das Paradebeispiel... Wann? Wie soll man das sagen? Der Auslöser, die Atombombe sozusagen, der das Ganze zum Eklodieren gebracht hat, war ein Spiel namens ET.
ET, der Außerirdische ET?
Die offizielle Filmsizenz. Eine Firma hat die Lizenz gekauft, hat ein ET-Spiel gemacht, gottenschlecht, ist egal. Gibt es übrigens sehr selten die Module inzwischen. Aber sie haben davon, muss man sich vorstellen, mehr produziert, als es Atari VCS am Markt gab. Mit Argumentation, es kaufen ja noch ein paar Millionen Leute die Atari VCS Konsole. Die brauchen ja das Spiel dann auch noch alle.
Weil sie haben ein paar Millionen mehr produziert, oder was?
Genau. Und die Sache ist halt die, das funktioniert am Anfang. Man kann sagen, man verkauft am Anfang 10 Millionen Konsolen. Im Folge 20 Millionen, danach 30 Millionen. Dann kann man das machen, wenn man im ersten Jahr rausgehen will, dass man mehr produziert. Aber das Pech, was die hatten, sind genau in diese Szene reingefallen, wo das Atari VCS wirklich abgenippelt ist. Und das ging innerhalb von 2, 3 Wochen wirklich. War das so schlimm, dass Walmart hat gesagt, wir wollen die Dinger nicht mehr, verkauft sich nicht mehr. Alle haben das Ding nur noch abgelehnt. Es ging alles zurück an den Hersteller und zack, weg war es.
Und warum hat es sich nicht verkauft?
Das ist eine normale Zyklusgeschichte. So eine Konsole hält nur 5, 6 Jahre. Sie ist auch nur attraktiv 5, 6 Jahre. Ganz am Anfang ist die Konsole da mit 20 Spielen. Danach kommen die besseren Spiele, dann gibt es 50 Spiele. Dann werden die immer besser, die Konsole wird auch immer billiger. Dadurch kommt ein immer breiterer Markt. Aber es kommen auch mehr Spiele ins Regal. Und dann gibt es den Effekt, dass im 3. Jahr von so einer Konsole kommt so ein Spiel, nehmen wir mal heute. Wir sind jetzt im 3. Da kommt bis Weihnachten ein Spiel raus, das steht da im Regal für 60 Euro. So toll sind die heute.
Xbox 360 mal so.
Genau, Xbox 360. Da steht ein tolles Spiel für 60 Euro im Regal. Aber der Hit aus dem 1. Jahr, der ist ja nicht schlechter. Die Xbox ist ja nicht besser geworden. Das Spiel ist immer noch gut aus dem 1. Jahr, steht für die Hälfte daneben. Welches kaufst du dann? Hast du die Konsole neu gekauft, gehst hin und sagst, ich kaufe mir nicht GTA 5, ich kaufe mir GTA 4 vom letzten Jahr. Das kenne ich ja noch gar nicht. Das ist die Problematik des Software-Verkäufers. Und das Zweite ist natürlich, es gibt so viel Software auf dem Markt, auch gebrauchte Software, dass man aber sagt, du hast auch GTA 4 zu Hause, leistet mir das mal. Ja klar, hier, dann schiebt man das. Und dann kommt der ganze Markt so ein bisschen ans Wanken. Da sind die Margen kleiner, die Konkurrenz im Regal ist größer, die Stückzahlen gehen runter und so weiter und so fort.
Und das ist sozusagen mit dem Atari VCS passiert zu einem Zeitpunkt, als eigentlich noch keiner diesen Markt verstanden hat. Und alle dachten, okay, das war's. Das war jetzt fünf Jahre lang so das Monchichi, was alle haben mussten und jetzt will das keiner mehr.
Genau. Und es gab auch Konkurrenz, das haben wir nicht vergessen. Es gab das sogenannte Intellivision von Mattel. War es von Mattel? Ich glaube schon. Und es gab das Colecovision. Wo das einiges besser war, weil Colecovision, da gab es einen Donkey Kong 1 zu 1 drauf. Diese drei und das sind immer ein Dreiergestirn, die Konkurrenz. Es sind immer drei Konsolen. Es sind nie fünf, es sind auch nie zwei, es sind immer drei, die konkurrieren. Das scheint irgendwie so eine Marktdynamik zu sein, wo die funktioniert. Das ist ganz witzig. Und diese drei Konsolen haben einmal konkurriert. Sie gingen, als sich die Markt kaputt gemacht. Da gab es dann Preiskriege und viele andere Sachen. Und dann ging das so schnell runter der Markt, dass sich viele Firmen die Finger dran verbrannt haben, hat auch viel Geld dann im Nachhinein verloren. Was sie gewonnen haben davor, haben sie natürlich vergessen, aber es ist halt so üblich in der Branche, dass sie gesagt haben, Spielekonsolen funktionieren nicht und sie haben alle die Finger davongelassen. Bis Nintendo kam. Und Nintendo hat die Dynamiken analysiert. Wie kam es überhaupt dazu, dass Atari kaputtgegangen ist da dran? Und haben gesagt, wir müssen verhindern, dass eine Marktschirmmedaille da ist. Also lassen wir nicht jeden programmieren. Jeder, der programmieren will, muss über uns gehen. Punkt 2. Die Überproduktion der Software-Module, dass jemand da mal kurz 10 Millionen Stück in den Laden stellt, müssen wir verhindern. Also muss jeder bei Nintendo produzieren. Es darf niemand Nintendo-Module produzieren, außer Nintendo selber. Und das Dritte ist, ein knallhartes Lizenzgeschäft draus machen. Das heißt, selbst wenn jemand ein gutes Spiel hat, und da eine Menge Geld reingesteckt hat, aber das sich nicht verkauft, muss es garantiert sein, dass Nintendo trotzdem noch Geld gemacht hat, damit die nicht pleite gehen daran. Deswegen ist es so, wenn ich heute ein Konsolenspiel mache, auf der Xbox oder auf den Nintendo Wii, völlig egal, da muss ich erstmal ein Wirkungssystem kaufen, die sind sehr teuer. Ich muss eine offizielle Lizenz erwerben bei Nintendo. Ich muss durch das Genehmigungsfahnen gehen. Die lassen ja nicht jeden ran. So, jetzt sagt Nintendo, du darfst entwickeln. Dann ist man auf deren Entwickler-Webseite und kann Entwickler-Kits bestellen, kosten Heidengeld. Da kann man erstmal 50.000 Euro sich da hinstellen und dann hat man noch nicht mehr was gemacht. So, dann entwickelt man da, steckt sein Entwicklungsgeld rein. Da muss man durch einen Approval-Prozess durch. Das heißt, man geht zu Nintendo und sagt, hier ist mein Spiel und die lassen das durch ihre sehr knallharte Testabteilung laufen. Und sobald da ein Fehler ist, geht er sofort zurück. Stopp. Man muss sehr viel liefern dahin, um diesen Approval-Prozess durchzumachen. Das ist sehr zeitaufwendig. Damals musste man ein Video beilegen, damals gab es Video-Kassetten, heute nicht mehr, das zeigt, wie das ganze Spiel komplett durchgespielt wird. An einem Video kann man das ganze Spiel komplett durchgespielbar sehen. Das muss man mitliefern, ohne dass...
Um zu beweisen, dass es geht.
Nicht nur, dass es geht, sondern dass die Tester sehen, wie es gemacht wird. Wie ist es gedacht, durchgespielt zu werden? Daran erkennt man auch, dass einige Spieldesigns auf Konsole absichtlich so gebaut wurden, damit man es gut auf Video durchspielbar machen kann. So haben sich wenige Spiele verkauft, die komplett freie Welten haben. In die Richtung, ich habe hier ein Rollenspiel, da kannst du hingehen, wo du willst. Das kann man ja gar nicht auf Video zeigen. Deswegen gab es solche Spiele sehr wenig auf Konsole, aus dem Grund, wegen dem Approval-Prozess. So hat man das durch den Approval-Prozess durch und Nintendo sagt, jetzt ist es so weit, ist es super, muss man diese Module oder die CDs oder was auch immer, je nach Konsole, bei Nintendo bestellen. Ich sage jetzt also, ich habe mein Spiel auf der Wii fertig, dann bestelle ich die. Normalerweise kostet eine Produktion von der CD 1,20 Euro, mit Verpackung, Anleitung und so weiter. Ich muss Nintendo aber 10 Euro zahlen, weil die ihre Lizenzgebühr damit reinrechnen. Im Vorhinein. Ich muss ihnen das Geld geben, erst wenn das Geld eingegangen ist, produzieren die und schieben dir die 500.000 Stück, die du bestellt hast, die ins Lager. 500.000 mal 10 Euro, so mal kurz 5 Millionen Euro. Ich habe das Ding aber noch nicht im Mediamarkt und im Kaufhof. Das kommt noch ob drauf. Das ist der Grund, warum so wenige Filme in der Lage sind, Konsolen spielerfolgreich zu vermarkten, weil es sauteuer ist. Das Ganze sieht jetzt so aus, als ob Nintendo, Sony oder Microsoft, die haben genau das gleiche System, Monopolisten sind. Nein, das ist reiner Selbstschutz, dass dieser Markt nicht implodiert auf ihrer Konsole, dass zu viele Schrotttitel da sind, dass eine Marktüberflutung da ist. Was genau passiert nämlich, wenn du Electronic Arts Activity, wie sie alle heißen, freien Lauf lässt, dann schiebt Electronic erst mal kurz alle Medienmärkte nur mit ihren Spielen zu. Und schon gibt es eine Überpopulation und Überangebot, und das Ganze geht dann in den Bach runter. Um diesen Markt stabil zu halten, muss das so funktionieren. Das ist ein interessantes Konzept, das hat Nintendo entwickelt, damals erfunden, jeder hat sich darüber beschwert, aber alle haben bewundert.
Welches damals ist das, um jetzt nochmal eine Zeitmarke zu setzen?
Das Nintendo Entertainment System kam raus, ich glaube 1988 oder so. Das war aber schon 3 Jahre später, als es in Japan rauskam. Das Super Nintendo Entertainment System, das war das erste, was weltweit gelounge worden ist, teilweise mit einem Jahr Versatz, weil Nintendo sich das noch leisten konnte, kam Anfang der 90er raus und hat den Homecomputer den Todesstoß versetzt. Das kam genau dann und dann ist Amiga ST und Tefinistich mal zusammengebrochen, als das kam.
Stimmt, die sind auf einmal so alle verschwunden. Obwohl die sich so lange gehalten haben. Das ist ja auch ein Wunder. Der C64 hat sich noch eine Weile, ich weiß nicht, der ist glaube ich noch Mitte der 90er Jahre verkocht und nicht mehr in diesen Mengen.
Es war aber kein Markt mehr. Es gab keine neue Software mehr von größeren Anbietern. Das ist immer das erste Anzeichen. Man geht aus großer Anbieter raus auf so einen Markt, wenn sich die Verkaufszahlen zu niedrig werden. Da war es ein typisches Zeichen unserer Industrie. Es kam das Super Nintendo, wo man ein extrem gutes Geschäft machen konnte. Das heißt, die Leute haben eher investiert im Super Nintendo statt dem Computer 64, wo der Markt am stagnieren war. Und es kam ein ganz neues Format auf, nämlich der PC. Darf man nicht vergessen.
Es ist interessant, dass der Home-Computer an sich nicht unbedingt als Spielecomputer geplant und gedacht war. Ich kann jetzt nicht in die Psycho-Combo-Dora reinschauen.
Du hast ernsthafte Anwendungen auf der Kiste gemacht, glaube ich.
Ich? Ich habe natürlich auch gespielt auf meinem C6460. Aber ich hätte ihn mir nicht nur gekauft, wenn ich da nur hätte spielen drauf gehört. Ich persönlich fand Spielekonsolen bis vor kurzem langweilig, weil man nur mitspielen konnte. Für mich ist klar, dass viele Leute das ganz anders sehen. Für die ist Spiele eine ganz andere Geschichte. Insofern sind Konsolen eine besondere Sache. Das ist auch schon angeklangt mit dieser ganzen Marktgeschichte. Das sind ja überhaupt mal Computer, die über mehrere Jahre hin unverändert verkauft werden.
Das klingt nicht so viel, fünf Jahre. Man darf nicht vergessen, wenn ich mich jetzt mal hinsetze und ich gehe mal fünf Jahre zurück, in das Jahr 2003, wie gut war denn die Grafik, die wir damals hatten? Wie gut waren denn die PCs, die wir damals hatten? Und das mal vergleichen, das ist ein Riesengenerationssprung. Und das merkt man bei einer Konsole. Nach fünf, sechs Jahren ist die Technologie halt veraltet. Aber sie ist so billig zu produzieren zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil die Chips alle integrierter werden, ein muschiges Gesetz und das Ganze zusammengezählt. Das heißt, diese Konsole steht im fünften Jahr für 99 Euro im Laden anstatt für 500, wie es am Anfang war, oder 399. Und der Preisverfall ist eine ganz natürliche Chip-Produktionsentwicklung. Und die Konsolen haben den Vorteil, es ist eine Plattform, die stabil ist, immer gleich, technisch gesehen. Ergo können die Programmierer immer besser lernen, mit ihr umzugehen. Ich habe eine stabile Plattform, auf der kann ich mich perfektionieren. Und im dritten, vierten Jahr mache ich perfekte Spiele auf dieser Plattform. Auf einem PC geht das nicht, weil die Plattform sich laufend verändert. Habe ich heute begriffen, wie D Wie habe ich heute begriffen, wie DITX 8 funktioniert, ist ein Jahr später DITX 9 draußen und ich kann alles über einen Haufen werfen. Und jetzt kommt DITX 10 mit Vista. Jetzt muss ich schon wieder alles neu lernen und neu machen. Das ist die Problematik von einer dynamischen Plattform. Macht sie interessant, macht sie dynamisch, kommen tolle kreative Geschichten raus, aber Stabilität hat auch einen riesen Vorteil. Die Spiele werden einfach besser. Deswegen kommen immer sehr viele kreative Impulse in der letzten Hälfte dieses 5-6-Jahres-Zyklus an eine Konsole raus. Diese ganzen Musikspiele wurden erfunden.
Weil sie dann am besten verstanden sind dann auch.
Die Konsole wurde verstanden, und man sucht jetzt, weil der Markt ja auch schon angefangen hat, sich zu sättigen oder zu überfüllen, man sucht jetzt auch Nischen raus, die noch nicht bedient sind. Und versucht, dadurch, dass der Preis auch niedrig ist, andere Leute anzusprechen. Für 500 Euro würde ein normaler User daraus sich das Ding nicht kaufen. Aber für 149 Euro, dann kauft sich mal Papa auch so ein Ding, wenn das richtige Spiel da ist. Und dann kann man anfangen, für so einen Preis auch Leute zu bedienen, die normalerweise halt keine Hardcore-Spieler sind. Und Nintendo hat eine ganze Konsole in diesem Publikum gewidmet, nämlich die Nintendo Wii. Das sind fast alles nur Casual-Gamer, die das spielen. Während Sony mit der PS2 die Gredche geschafft hat, sie haben auf einmal diese Hardcore-Sport-Simulationen oder Rennsimulationen, sie haben die Casual-Spiele wie Singstar und das mit dem Itoy und sowas alles gemacht. Die haben jetzt alles angefangen damit und es war ein riesen Erfolg, um eine breite Zielgruppe anzusprechen, nämlich vom normalen Casual-User über normalen Gelegenheitsspieler bis zum Hardcore-Gamer. Und der Trick ist es, alle drei anzusprechen. Und das schafft momentan keine der drei Konsolen.
Ich habe eine Wie. Das ist die erste Spielekonsole, die ich mir... Du hast sie bestimmt alle, aber ich betone das, weil ich... Wie schon gesagt, ich bin einfach... Diese drei Spiele, dieses Ich schieße alle ab, und irgendwie die Prinzessin und so weiter, das hat mich einfach nicht gezogen. Aber dieses Tennis-Ding, das hat mich gekauft.
Ganz genial, wirklich. Kannst du empfehlen, wie fit.
Habe ich jetzt dieses Wochenende das erste Mal ausprobiert. Das ist lustig.
Das ist supergeil.
Findest du das großartig? Das ist großartig.
Meine Kinder spielen das bis zum Umfallen.
Ja, für Kitz ist das spitze.
Nee, auch für Erwachsene.
Ja, ich bin so ein bisschen an diesem Slalom verreckt. Ich war eh noch gerade frustriert, weil ich irgendwie...
Warte mal ab, bis du Yoga-Übung machen machst. Einhändlicher draufstehen mit irgendwelchen Handübungen. Es geht darum, dass...
Gute User-Interfaces sind auf jeden Fall auch ein heißes Thema gerade, oder?
Das ist das große heiße Thema. Und da kann man ein bisschen rüberschielen auf die Konsole. Weil die Konsolen haben ja angefangen mit so einem Pad, mit so einem Steuerkreuz und zwei Knöpfen. Das war der Anfang auf dem Nintendo Entertainment System. Der Super Nintendo hatte schon vier Knöpfe. Und dann fing Nintendo an, sogenannte Shoulder-Buttons ein, das man auf der Schulter von dem Controller noch zwei Knöpfe hatte. Und umso besser die Controller wurden, umso besser wurden auch die Spiele auf den Kisten. Und dann kamen die ersten 3D-Applikationen auf Konsole, nämlich mit dem Nintendo 64 und der Playstation 1.
Da gab es dann auch Knöpfchen unten?
Da gab es auch Knöpfchen unten. Oder Nintendo auch erfunden einen Analogstick.
Diesen kleinen Stick, den man in jede beliebige Richtung...
Genau, und den man auch messen konnte, wie weit man ihn drückt. Deswegen analog, nicht digital. Das ist notwendig für 3D-Spiele. Sony kapiert das nicht und hat es erst im Nachhinein nachgeliefert. Nintendo waren immer die Innovatoren der Controller. Immer das, was die Kommunikation zur Konsole verbessert hat, hat fast immer Nintendo rausgebracht. Der Abschluss ist natürlich die Wii. Da hat ja niemand an geglaubt. Es gab nur ganz wenige Insider, die gewusst haben, Nintendo ist eine Firma, die macht das seit 20 Jahren. Die wissen genau, was sie tun. Als die Wii angekündigt haben, hat Microsoft sich schon totgelacht in die Richtung, so eine alte Technik auf den Markt bringen, ich habe nie eine Chance.
Alte Technik inwiefern? Ach so, die Konsole selbst?
Die Konsole selbst, da ist ja nichts anderes drin, als ein doppelter Gamecube. Also ein Gamecube, hochgetaktet, mehr Speicher, verbessert, das ist ja alles, was da drin ist.
Aber kann man schon billig bauen?
Kann man sehr billig bauen, sehr billig produzieren und man kann den Aufwand woanders reinstecken, nämlich den Controller, das haben sie getan. Und das hat die Leute ganz schön umgehauen. Und jetzt muss Microsoft und Sony ganz schön umdenken. Aber das ist der übliche Konsolen-Krieg, wer gewinnt jetzt? Wir haben als...
Aber Nintendo hat furchtbar abgeräumt, oder? Wir sind wirklich dermaßen an einem vorbeigezogen. Also diese V-Mode, das muss man auch echt nochmal erwähnen. Das ist für dich so ein Großart, wenn du das Teil nicht kennst. Halt dieser Steak irgendwie ganz einfach. Viereckig, also rechteckig.
Wie eine Fernbedienung.
Wie eine Fernbedienung, genau.
Hat kein Bluetooth.
Doch. Bluetooth ist das. Das pärt hier sogar mit meinem Macintosh.
Genau, das Pärren mit der Konsole, ja. Aber das ist die optische Bewegungssensurik nicht.
Er hat Bluetooth für die Kommunikation mit dem Gerät. Aber die eigentliche Geschichte ist natürlich der Beschleunigungs-Sensor, der da drin ist, gepaart mit dieser Kamera, die auf diese Infrarot-Leiste blickt, sodass das Ding sich innerhalb des Raums ausrichten kann und im Weiß, immer wieder, wenn er dran vorbeikommt, auch kalibrieren kann. Das funktioniert so dermaßen gut. Das ist so ein Voodoo. Und die haben es einfach geschafft, das Ding auch zu einer universalen Fernbedienung zu machen. Also man kann das in alles mögliche Sachen reinbauen. Jetzt gibt es ja dieses supergeile Mario Kart, wo man das einfach in so ein Plastirad reinmacht. Dann sitzt man da wie ein Idiot mit so einem kleinen Plastikrad. Es funktioniert halt auch einfach sofort. Und das haut mich total um. Soll es ja nicht wirklich das Thema sein. Aber das ist ein großer Fortschritt auf jeden Fall von dem Joystick, den der Atari 2600 hatte.
Was haben wir daraus gelernt? Wir haben daraus gelernt, dass unsere Spiele, von der Bedienung her, obwohl sie immer einfach, besser wurden, die Spiele, wir haben ja die Bedienung von Spielen wie Strategiespiele und Shooter und sowas perfektioniert. Bis sie wirklich so gut waren, dass besser geht's einfach nicht. Aber was wir vergessen haben, diese Steuerungen sind immer noch so kompliziert, dass es, sag mal, meine Mutter nicht kapiert. Also wenn nicht meine Mutter vor Warcraft 3 sitzt und Strategiespiel, obwohl das ein perfektes User-Interface hat, die würde nicht eine Einheit bewegt bekommen. Und das haben wir vergessen, dass es eine ganze Generation von Leuten jetzt nach uns gibt oder halt nach den normalen Spielern, die eben nicht gelernt haben, wenn ich einen Stick habe und ihn nach rechts drücke, dann geht das Ding auch nach rechts. Das müssen die alles lernen. Ganz einfach Kontrollmechanismen. Und die Wii hat das beigebracht. Die ist wieder zurück zur Mutter Natur, wie ich mal sage, wo gewisse Kontrollmechanismen neu gelernt werden und so natürlich sind, dass sie den natürlichen menschlichen Bewegungen nachgaren werden. Das ist perfekt. Besser geht es nicht.
Derzeit sind also die Xbox und die Playstation, jetzt Playstation 3, also die Playstation war ja bis vor kurzem die meistverkaufte Playstation 2 Konsole und ist jetzt meines Wissens von der DS, von der Nintendo DS überholt worden in den Stückzeiten.
Das ist schon länger, Nintendo DS, da kann man ja nicht vergleichen, also das eine ist Handheld, das andere ist Konsole. Also Nintendo hatte immer die Dominanz.
Darauf wollte ich aber hinaus, dass jetzt sozusagen diese kleinen Handheld-Geschichten, wer hat das pioniert, Sony eigentlich mit oder war die DS vor der PSP? Nintendo auch. Ok, also kleine, mobile, ja ok, das gab ja den, wie hieß das erste Mobile-Detail von Nintendo?
Die Game & Watch-Dinger waren die ersten. Wir reden hier von Anfang der 80er. Meinte ich jetzt auch nicht.
Nee, nee, später.
Game Boy.
Der Game Boy, genau.
Der erste Game Boy.
Das war im Prinzip so das erste Handheld. Das war auch ein super Erfolg, oder?
Das war ein Riesenerfolg.
Und dann, die DS ist im Prinzip jetzt so die moderne Version davon.
Genau, noch erfolgreich, ja.
Auch wieder mit so einem ganz neuen Ding, mit zwei Bildschirmen.
Und Touchscreen.
Und Touchscreen. Ich hab's noch nie benutzt, muss ich sagen.
Mit Mikro und mit, genau.
Und das ist auch interessant, es verkauft sich ja vor allem auch, genauso wie die Wii, eben auch an diese Leute, die eben nicht eigentlich diese normalen Computerspieler sind. Von den Kindern jetzt mal abgesehen.
Sie haben es erweitert.
Diese Brain-Tester.
Genau, sie haben es geschafft, einmal die Leute anzusprechen, die so ihre Kunden waren, nämlich die Mario und Zelda Spieler, sag ich mal. Und sie wollten aber jetzt noch mehr Leute ansprechen, haben sich überlegt, was wollen die denn haben? Und haben mit einmal dem Brain Trainer die Sachen erweitert. Und zum anderen fangen sie jetzt auch an mit den anderen Serious Games, wie man sie nennt. Deswegen bin ich jetzt gerade in Berlin, in der Konferenz ist er hier. Da kann man jetzt Englisch lernen, Mathe lernen und viele andere Sachen machen. Die erweitern es immer weiter. Da gibt es ganz tolle Geschichten, die es da gibt. Psychologieüberratung, es gibt jetzt ein Nichtraucherspiel. Also man kann da lernen, nicht zu rauchen in einem Spiel. Aber damit erweitern sie sich unter ihren Kundenkreis. Weil Nintendo hat rausgefunden, beim Game Boy vor allem, das ist keine Hardware, die man sich kaufen will, wenn man mal spielen will, sondern man kauft sich das, wenn man ein Spiel spielen will. Es gibt ein gewisses Spiel, davon habe ich gehört, wie sagen wir den Brain Trainer, deswegen hole ich mir das Spiel und ich kaufe mir ein DS dazu, ein Nintendo DS. Es ist nicht so umgekehrt wie bei vielen anderen Sachen, wo man sich sagt, ich hole mir jetzt eine Konsole, weil ich die ganzen Spiele daraus spielen möchte. Sondern es ist umgekehrt, bei Nintendo DS ist es so, da kauft man sich eine Konsole, weil man das Spiel spielen möchte. Und das ist ganz wichtig, um die Zielgruppe besser anzusprechen. Deswegen müssen sie in die Breite gehen, was ihre Themengebiete angeht.
Das ist bei der Wii aber auch ähnlich, würde ich sagen. Ja, dieses Tennis-Ding, das war eigentlich der Grund. Wenn man sagt, super, damit kann ich dieses Tennis spielen, das ist endlich mal was, was Spaß macht, kaufe ich. Und da habe ich noch gar nicht darüber nachgedacht, dass man da später auch mal andere Spiele drauf spielen könnte. So weit habe ich noch gar nicht gedacht. Da hat mir das schon gereicht. Ich war auch ein bisschen scharf auf diesen Controller, den kann man auch auf dem Computer schön benutzen. Es gibt ja zahlreiche tolle Super-Anwendungen, zahlreiche Internet-Videos auf YouTube, wo die Leute so demonstrieren, wie sie damit Musik steuern.
Oder ein 3D-View tracken oder sowas.
Genau, oder sich dann einen Projektor daraus zu bauen. Also großartige Ideen. Da hat Nintendo auf jeden Fall was gerissen.
Man darf aber nicht verschweigen, dass es auch Probleme gibt mit der Nintendo Wii. Die Probleme sind vor allem bei Software-Herstellern, die nicht Nintendo heißen. Die meistverkauften Spiele auf Nintendo sind von Nintendo. Es gibt noch Kaufspiele, die diese Verkaufszahlen erreicht haben, von anderen Herstellern, wie Electronic Arts usw. Es ist extrem schwer, in diesen Markt so reinzukommen, dass man den gleichen Erfolg erzielt. Woran liegt das? Weil die großen Firmen wie Electronic Arts sind es gewöhnt, ein Spielkonzept zu bauen. Sie machen das auf PC, Xbox, PS3, Wii. So machen die das um. Um das Risiko zu streuen, müssen sie auf vier Märkte gehen, damit die Verkaufszahlen hochgehen. Da gibt es aber eine Konsole, die funktioniert ganz anders als die anderen und die heißt Wii. Man muss ein Spiel speziell für die Wii schreiben, damit man dort erfolgreich wird. Und das ist schwierig. Man muss alles neu lernen. Man weiß ja gar nicht, was funktioniert. Wie ist das positive Feedback? Auf welche Reaktionen kann ich gehen? Wie ist die Sensorik? Das muss man komplett neu lernen. Das Gesamtspiel ist umrumstricken. Das ist schwierig.
Es ist eigentlich eine neue Generation des Spiels, oder?
Ja.
Die da eingeleitet wird.
Ich hätte mir nicht gedacht, dass ich vor dem Fernseher rumhampel an welche Gymnastik mache. Die Maus mal 10 cm zu bewegen, ist ja schon viel. Aber das muss man unterscheiden. Die Bedienung ist intuitiv und sehr gut. Ich habe mir überlegt, dass ich meinen Eltern zu Weihnachten schenke. Die sind jenseits der 60. Die würden damit Spaß haben. Denen könnte ich nie einen PC oder Xbox hinstellen. Das ist das Geheimnis davon. Aber es heißt auch, dass andere Medien wie PC oder andere Konsolen lernen können, dass die Bedienkonzepte verallgemeinert werden sollen. Ich sage nicht, dass jeder vom Rechner rumhampeln muss. Das gilt universell. Ein Strategiespiel mit einer Maus ist viel besser zu bedienen als mit einer V-Mode. Aber generell neue Bedienkonzepte und neue Spiele, die die reale Welt mehr integrieren in die Konsole. Wenn ich jetzt schon Bewegungen integrieren kann in das Spiel, ist das schon ein Riesenfortschritt. Aber jetzt gehen wir darüber hinaus, auch Sound, Stimme, Voice mit zu integrieren. SingStar ist ja so was. SingStar ist das Spiel, wo man zu einer Karaoke singt. Die Qualität des Singens wird von dem gemessen. Das ist eine Art Sing-Battle.
Die Qualität, wie gut man die Töne trifft.
Das wird gemessen und man kriegt Punkte. Dann gibt es viele andere Sachen. Es gibt den ganzen Hits, die man schon kennt. Es gibt auch verschiedene Songthemen. CD ist schon da draußen. Ganz phantasische Sache. Super Partyspiel. Du warst noch nie auf einer Party, wo das gespielt worden ist. Dann warst du auf dem falschen Party.
Ich bin so Karaoke und so. Da bin ich zurückhaltend.
Es gibt Karaoke-Bars, die SingStar spielen. Der nächste Schritt ist Guitar Hero. Das ist die andere Geschichte.
Das ist Luftgitarre im Modernen.
Aber es gibt eine richtige Gitarre dazu zu kaufen. Es gibt auch eine Rockband.
Kann man da wirklich Gitarre spielen lernen?
Nein, kann man nicht. Das ist nur so tun, aber lustig. Die Musik ist auch besser, wenn man gut spielt. Das ist klasse. Das macht echt Spaß. Wenn man solche Sachen immer mehr integriert in die Spielerei, kommen da immer noch Mischformen raus, die fantastisch sind. Da warte ich schon drauf.
Es könnte sein, dass in 10 Jahren die Chöre in Fußballstadien besser klingen als Langzeit-Effekte.
Regenssingstattraining.
Was kann man zu den anderen Konsolen sagen? Wir hatten jetzt die Ur-Konsole, den Atari, und dann Nintendo mit seiner ganzen Serie von Super NES. Dann gab es die Nintendo 64. Die habe ich mir zwar nicht gekauft, aber da war ich kurz davor, und zwar nur wegen Mario Kart.
Mario Kart sofort, jeden Tag gespielt.
Das ist so eine Sucht, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Dann gab es den Gamecube und halt jetzt... Die Wii. Die Wii, das ist wirklich eine super Serie, die sie hingelegt haben. Jetzt hat Microsoft und Sony ihre eigenen Versuche gestartet. PlayStation war natürlich super erfolgreich. Warum? Warum war die so erfolgreich?
Weil sie den Erwachsenenmarkt angesprochen haben, was Nintendo nicht getan hat. Nintendo war damals eine Konsole für 8- bis 16-Jährige. Und Sony ging mit dem Anspruch hin, wir wollen aber 16- bis 30-Jährige haben. Und da war das Gamecube des Erfolges. Da war damals der größere Markt. Das Gamecube ist natürlich alle anzusprechen. Aber generell hat Sony mit der Hardcore-Spielerei den viel größeren Markt angesprochen. Da gab es ernsthafte Sportspiele, E-Sports, Metten und wie sie alle hießen. Und die ganzen Rennsimulationen, Two-Braiders, Horrorspiele und keine Ahnung was. Und natürlich dann auch die Shooter. Die hat Sony auf sich gezogen, hat dadurch eine ziemlich große Menschenmasse angezogen. Mit der PS1 erst mal erfolgreich, obwohl die technisch schlechter war als die anderen, mit der Playstation 2 dann verfolgt. Aber man darf nicht vergessen, Sony ist auch immer noch am Lernen. Die Playstation 2 war technisch schon sehr kompliziert. Die war auf gut Deutsch scheiße zu programmieren. Sehr, sehr kompliziert. Die Teams haben alle sich beschwert, wie kann man so eine Konsole bauen. Im Nachhinein haben sie natürlich gelernt. Im zweiten, dritten Jahr kamen die Spiele, die sehr gut waren, weil die Leute die Technik beherrscht haben. Aber Sony hat daraus nicht gelernt, dass sie eine Konsole machen müssen, die nicht nur technisch anspruchsvoll ist, sondern auch, wenn es geht, einfach programmierbar. Und haben mit der PS3 noch eins draufgesetzt, indem sie es noch komplizierter gemacht haben. In die Richtung, man muss schon schizophren sein, um, keine Ahnung, 8, 9 Prozessoren gleich zu programmieren. Da hat Microsoft es schlauer gemacht. Die haben es relativ schnell gelernt. Die haben zwar auch Fehler gemacht mit der Xbox One. Die waren sehr einfach zu programmieren, weil es war nichts anderes als ein modifizierter PC in der Box. Mehr war die Xbox One nicht. Aber, was sie unterschätzt haben, ist, die Dynamik der Konsole funktioniert nur, wenn die Hardware im Preis fällt. Das heißt, ich muss die Hardware immer billiger produzieren jedes Jahr. Sonst rechnet sich das am Schluss nicht. Weil ich verkaufe am Anfang die Konsole mit Verlust. Die ist teurer herzustellen als der Ladenpreis. Nur mit der Zeit geht der Preis runter, weil die Chips immer mehr integriert werden, die dann immer billiger zu produzieren sind. Statt 40 Chips in einer Konsole habe ich plötzlich im Jahr 2 nur noch 20 Chips. Das kostet die Hälfte zum Bauen. Und irgendwann ist diese Verkaufskurve so, weil man der Verkauf mit der Konsole hochgeht, dass das Ding mit Gewinn verkauft wird. Den realen Gewinn mache ich mit der Software, nicht mit der Hardware. Sie haben nur einen Fehler gemacht. Sie haben diesem Ding eine Festplatte verpasst. Und eine Festplatte ist das einzige Teil, was eben nicht diesem Preisverfallsgesetz folgt. Da geht nämlich die Datendichte hoch und nicht der Preis runter. Und das ist so die Problematik. Ich meine, wer kriegt heute 120 Megabyte Festplatte? Man kann sie nicht mehr kaufen. Aber das Ding war da drin.
Es könnte sich ändern, wenn alles auf Flashram wechselt.
Genau. Das große Geheimnis wäre Flashram. Aber dieses Konzept wusste Microsoft nicht. Da gibt es ein sehr interessantes Buch. Opening the Xbox heißt das oder Inside the Xbox. Eines von diesen kann man auf Amazon mal suchen. Da steht das drin, da hat jemand das dokumentiert, welche Fehlentscheidungen Microsoft dazu geführt hat. Und witzigerweise, Sony hat ja auch immer komplexere Technologien gemacht. Sony hat diesen Fehler kopiert und hat eine Festplatte in der PS3 drin. Was hat Nintendo in ihrem Ding drin?
Aber sie könnten doch die Festplatte in einem zukünftigen Modell durch Flash-RAM ersetzen, oder?
Zu dem Zeitpunkt war Flash-RAM superteuer. Wir erinnern uns, die Konsole wurde vor fünf Jahren entwickelt. Da hat ein Gigabyte-Ding für deine Fotokamera...
Welches, die PS3?
PS3 wurde ja vor fünf Jahren angefangen zu entwickeln.
Ach so, vor fünf Jahren haben sie angefangen.
Genau. Wenn man sich da eine Entscheidung trifft, wie mache ich jetzt noch Flash-RAM rein? Zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo ein Gigabyte 500 Dollar kostet, geht das nicht. Jetzt kriegst du einen Gigabyte für fünf Euro Medienmarkt. Aber jetzt geht das. Aber Leute, die die Erfahrung haben mit diesem Markt wie Nintendo, was haben sie da eingebaut in ihre Wii? 512 MB Flash-RAM mit einem kleinen Schlitz, wo du einen Gigabyte-Stick reinstecken kannst und kannst den gesamtangelauten Spieler reintun. Die haben es gemacht. Und das ist diese Sache, dass die Dynamik zwischen Hardware, Preisverfall, Marktsättigung und sowas alles muss man verstehen, um erfolgreich eine Konsole auf den Markt zu bringen. Und witzigerweise wissen das teilweise die größeren Firmen immer noch nicht, weil sie in anderen Ebenen denken.
Aber was ist denn jetzt so schwer zu programmieren an der PS3? Liegt das an diesem Cell-Processor, den sie dort verwendet haben, diese Multicore-Geschichte?
Hast du mal Multicore programmiert?
Na, ich habe Multisredding programmiert. Das ist schon nicht ohne Herausforderung.
Das kannst du jetzt schon mal vor, du musst auf einen Quad-Core das Ganze machen. Und so programmieren, dass eine Applikation alle vier CPUs zu 100% ausnutzt. Das ist ja schon eine Herausforderung.
Das ist nicht besonders bekannt, wie man das macht.
Die Xbox hat drei Prozessoren. Und das ist schon schwierig. Und die besten Spiele auf der Xbox, lassen die Prozessoren maximal aus. Es ist also immer so eine geniale Verteilung, dass die gesamte Rechenpower immer zur Verfügung steht. Auf der PlayStation 3 habe ich acht. Normale Spieleprogrammierer können das nicht. Ich habe Untersuchungen vom MIT gelesen, diese Superuni drüben in der Forschungsinstitution in den USA. Es gab damals einen Rechner, der hieß, lass mich nicht lügen, Connection Machine. Das war einer der ersten Rechner mit 65.000, 166 Prozessoren. Hochparallel. Die hatten das gleiche Problem und damals schon untersucht, warum können normale Programmierer dieses Ding nicht programmieren? Weil sie eben anders denken. Und die besten Programmierer, die sie haben, finden können für diese Kiste, waren Kinder. Weil die parallel denken können. Weil umso erwachsener man wird, umso sequenzieller denkt man. Ich als erwachsener Mann und du auch, sagst du, ich habe hier ein Problem, jetzt gehe ich das erst mal an. Ich mache zuerst das, dann das, dann das, dann das, dann das, dann habe ich das Problem gelöst. Das ist aber genau das Falsche für Multiprocessing. Multiprocessing heißt ja, du machst das, du machst das, du machst das, und das führt dann am Ende zur Lösung. Und das ist sehr schwierig zu programmieren. Und da müssen viele, viele Teams komplett umleeren. Und das wird eine Weile dauern, bis die PS3 komplett ausgenutzt ist. Von der Rechenpower.
Interessante Sache, aber was ist denn gut an der PS3? Mal vielleicht so...
An der PS3 ist gut, dass sie von Sony ist, weil die Konsolen immer mehr zum, sag mal, Home-Theater-Provider werden. Ich sage jetzt mal, die nächste Generation von Konsolen wird als Harddisk-Recorder herhalten, als Blu-ray-Player, was die PS3 jetzt schon kann, ein Riesenmarktvorteil, als Internet-Hub für meinen HD-Fernseher. Ob ich jetzt Filme gucke per Demand, oder ob ich da neue Spiele runterlade, oder mir auf YouTube Videos anschaue, sei dahingestellt. Völlig egal. MP3-Player. Das Ganze von meinem Rechen noch live per Bluetooth oder per Wireless rüberkopiert. Diese werden diese multimedialen Geschichtennagen und die Sony, die PS3 schon nah dran. Die hat eine Festplatte, die hat einen Blu-ray-Player drin, die ist online, die hat die CPU-Power dafür. Und Sony ist ein multimedialer Konzern. Sie haben eine eigene Musik-Sparte, eine eigene Filmsparte und eine eigene Konsolen-Sparte und können ihre eigenen Inhalte auf der PS3 liefern. Spontan, sofort, theoretisch sogar parallel zum Kino, zum Release, was Microsoft nicht kann. Die haben die Inhalte nicht. Die müssen erst die Deals machen damit. Und das ist die Kraft von Sony. Sony ist ein multimedialer Konzern und können in einer multimedialen Konsole die Inhalte selber liefern.
Aber Sony gehört ja auch nicht alles. Ich meine, die haben zwar das eine oder andere Filmstudio sich einverleibt, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass sie wirklich die totale Kontrolle über den Markt haben.
Nein, nicht den Markt, aber es kommen schon bedeutende Filme raus, die sie dann exklusiv in gewissen Formaten rüberbringen können, genauso wie Sony Music. Da gibt es schon gewisse Inhalte, die sie bringen können und promoten können über diese Plattform, die diese Plattform stärkt.
Aber bisher haben sie sich nicht gerade besonders intelligent gezeigt, meine Damen. Wir sind sie ja von Apple doch schwer überfahren worden, wie eigentlich alle. Bevor wir darauf kommen, müssen wir nochmal über das iPhone sprechen. Was ist gut an der Xbox?
Die Xbox ist die beste Konsole für sogenannte Hardcore-Spiele. Weil? Wenn du Shooter spielen willst, es gibt die best Militär-Shooter da drauf, weil amerikanische Teams es einfacher haben, auf die Xbox zu kommen als auf die Sony. Das heißt, wenn du mal Rainbow Las Vegas gespielt hast auf die Xbox 360, ein super geiler Taktik-Shooter. Eine ganz einfache Geschichte, Las Vegas sind von Terroristen eingenommen worden und ganz Las Vegas wird von Terroristen als Geisel genommen. Einfach ein Horrorszenario USA. Und du bist die Elite-Einheit, die dir rein muss und diese Geiseln befreien. Ein Casino nach dem anderen. Und das sind sogenannte Taktik-Shooter. Das heißt, wenn du da einfach reingehst und alles ummetzelst, dann verlierst du, das geht nicht. Du musst taktisch vorgehen. Du musst Deckungen benutzen. Du musst um die Ecke schauen, Blendgranaten werfen. Du musst gucken, dass du teilweise die Leute auch unverletzt draufholst. Die Terroristen wollen Informationen von denen. Ganz hervorragend gemacht. Sowas gibt es momentan nur auf der Xbox. Metal Gear Solid kommt jetzt dann auf der Sony. Das ist das große Konkurrenzspiel dort. Aber diese Dinge sind hervorragend. Es gibt kaum Kinderspiele auf der Xbox. Kaum. Es gibt eins, aber das ist genial gut. Viva Pinata kann ich jedem empfehlen, der eine Xbox zu Hause hat und Kinder in die Richtung Papa, ich will auch mal spielen. Viva Pinata ist ein Geniestreich von einem ganz uralten Nintendo-Studio. Viva Pinata.
Was muss man da machen?
Einen Garten anpflanzen. Das hört sich super interessant an. Das sind immer die schrägen Ideen. Man richtet den Garten erst mal her, pflanzt da Pflanzen an. Dadurch werden verschiedene kleine, süße Insekten und Würmchen angelockt, die ganz lieb sind. Die paaren sich dann und bringen neue Kreaturen her. Die sind dann wiederum der Lockvogel für andere größere Tiere. Man hat einen Garten voller, toller, geiler Viecher, die alle eine Süße als das andere sind.
Lebenschaffen.
Genau, ein eigenes Biotop. Das ist das Viva Pinata. Das ist für Kinder, die, wenn es geht, lesen können. Also 1. Klasse aufwärts ein super Spiel.
Die Xbox hat deiner Meinung nach vor allem den Vorteil, dass sie an der amerikanischen Spielekultur mehr dran ist und sich leichter programmieren lässt.
Genau, alle Sportspiele, alle Rennspiele, alle Hardcore-Spiele, die ganzen Dinge. Und vor allem, die Xbox hat etwas pioniert. Das ist die Xbox One, was in der Xbox Two perfektioniert worden ist. Und das ist ein Onlinespiel. Eine Xbox, die stellst du dir ins Wohnzimmer, tust einen Stecker rein, tust hinter dein Internet rein, machst sie an und lies online. Du tust den Kopfhörer auf und kannst sofort mit dem Rennen mit dem anderen Typen quatschen. Versuch das mal auf dem PC zu konfigurieren. Profis sagen ja, wieso, ist doch ganz einfach. Aber ich sage immer, meine Mutter kann es nicht. Meine Mutter kann aber eine Xbox anschließen. Und da kann sie es. Onlinespielen perfektioniert ist auf der Xbox. Muss man sagen, das haben sie perfekt gemacht. Man kann alle Demos runterladen. Man kann sich die Videos anschauen von den neuen Spielen, die releases, die kommen. Es gibt einen Marketplace, wo man kleinere Spiele runterladen kann. Auch so Retro-Spiele wie Geometry Wars. Muss du unbedingt mal angucken. Gibt es auch auf Steam für einen PC. Das kommt von der Xbox her. Das haben sie groß gemacht. Wie promote ich über Internet meine Xbox-Konsole? Du hast ein Spielerprofil, das sie da einsehen kann. Kannst auch auf deine Webseite draufkleben. Dieses ganze Community-Geschichten-Syndrom, Voice-Chat und die ganzen Sachen. Sehr gut gemacht. Sony hat das verpennt. Die probieren das gerade jetzt erst. Sie haben ihre Virtual-Level noch nicht draußen. Die Wii hat das drin sehr limitiert, weil Nintendo übervorsichtig ist wegen Kindern. Das ist nicht möglich, einfach reinzustecken und dann mit einem Autorennspiel zu kommen, mit einem anderen zu reden. Das geht nicht, weil sie wollen verhindern, dass jemand über die Nintendo Wii an Kinder ankommt. Das gehört nicht zu egetiven. Wer mal auf Xbox Live gespielt hat und weiß, was da teilweise für komische Leute rumfliegen, aber hey, die ganze Menschheit besteht voller komischer Leute.
Aber besonders viel Geld verdient hat Microsoft nicht mit der Xbox.
Sie sind das Hamilton profitabel.
Sie haben jetzt mal Quartale gehabt, wo sie nicht Minus gemacht haben. Die haben noch nicht das Minus der letzten Jahre wieder drin.
Nein, die ist ja abgeschrieben, die Xbox One. Aber die Xbox Two an sich, die Entwicklung, ist jetzt schon positiv. Sie sind jetzt schon im positiven Ast und machen jetzt schon Geld damit. Heißt, sie haben sehr viel gelernt. Und das sieht man ja auch. Man glaubt, dass das Ding höllisch laut ist und zu heiß wird. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Das lernen sie auch noch, dass das Thema verbessert wird. Aber Microsoft, das ist immer, ich habe ja ein Jahr für die gearbeitet in den USA, muss man sagen, dass sie, wenn sie in den Eimerk reinwollen, es so lange probieren, bis sie es richtig machen. Die Abteilung, wo ich Teil davon war, die hat die Spieleabteilung von Microsoft, damals Microsoft Games, das waren nur 100 Leute, inzwischen sind das Jahrtausende da. Die haben alle drei Monate den Laden restrukturiert, um sich neuen Gegebenheiten anzupassen, um diesen Markt anzugehen. Und da haben die eine E-Selbstgeduld. Nach zwei Jahren wird er immer noch neu strukturiert, neue Leute rein, andere Leute raus, die Abteilung umbauen, bis sie den Markt haben. Es sei denn, irgendwann sagen sie einfach mal...
Aber so viele Märkte haben sie sich ja bisher noch nicht erkämpfen können. Außer ihrem Betriebssystem und Office-Markt gibt es nicht so viel Profitables.
Sie hatten mal andere Märkte. Damals war der Hardware-Markt wie Mäuse, Keyboards etc. sind sie ganz groß rein gegangen. War auch sehr gut. Aber damals war das ein großer Markt. Jetzt ist Logitech Nummer eins. Logitech war am Anfang Schrottware, auf gut Deutsch und inzwischen. Die haben gelernt.
Microsoft hat da auch ganz gute Sachen gemacht.
Und hat dann auch Federn gelassen. Sie haben Joysticks gebaut. Force-Feedback und sowas. Sie versuchen es mit MP3-Playern über ein gutes oder schlechtes Problem. Microsoft ist immer dieses Konzern-Denken. Das heißt, wenn sie so einen Tune-Player rausbringen, so einen MP3-Player, dann ist es dann gleich immer so in Windows Microsoft integriert, dass es zum Negativ dieses Mediums wird. Und das ist das große Problem von Microsoft. Auf der anderen Seite aber haben sie einen riesen Durchhaltevermögen.
Na gut, aber der Tune, der geht nirgends wohin.
Nee, der geht nirgends wohin. Nein. iPod rules. Aber wie gesagt, die Xbox, die erste war ihr Feldversuch, die zweite ist profitabel und wir sind jetzt gerade im goldenen Jahr der Konsole. Also dieses Jahr wird so viel um das mit Konsolenspielen geschoben, wie nie zuvor. Da werden sie einen Haufen Geld machen. Ab nächstes Jahr geht es schon einen Tick abwärts und 2011 wird es schon wieder die neue Konsole.
Hm, wer kommt denn dann als nächstes raus?
Microsoft, Sony, Nintendo. Warum?
Ach so, ich meine, die Wii ist ja nun gerade erst gekommen.
Gerade erst gekommen? Fünf Jahre halten die Konsolen, genau. Und Nintendo waren die Letzten, die kamen.
Genau.
Xbox war die erste.
Also als nächste ist jetzt wahrscheinlich Microsoft dran.
Theoretisch müsste Microsoft wieder als erstes sein, weil sie die ersten waren mit dem Xbox. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es Tendenzen dazu, die Konsolen einen Tick länger leben zu lassen, weil die Entwicklungszeiten immer länger werden. Auf der PlayStation 1 konnte man ein Spiel in einem Jahr machen. Das geht auf der Xbox jetzt nicht mehr.
Was ist denn jetzt mit dem PC-Markt? Also PC-Markt verkaufen sich ja heute auch. Oder man könnte vermuten, vielleicht vor allem wegen Spielen. Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall hat man das Gefühl, dass die Hardware-Entwicklung extrem vorangetrieben worden ist. Weil einfach der Bedarf nach Spielpower so da war. Würdest du das unterschreiben?
Ja, würde ich unterschreiben. Die Sache ist nur die, die den Geschwindigkeitszuwachs, den wir gehabt haben, den konnte man immer nachverfolgen an optischen Veränderungen der Spiele. Also es gab mal eine Zeit auf dem PC, ich sag es mal, 1990 bis 2000, da haben die Spiele vom letzten Jahr sehr viel schlechter ausgesehen, als die Spiele, die jetzt gerade im Regal standen. Rein nur vom optischen, wenn ich die Spiele an meinem PC installiere.
Weil immer wieder so ein neuer, grundsätzlicher Shader-Effekt dazugekommen ist, der einen riesigen Unterschied gemacht hat.
Nee, da haben wir noch nicht so lange. Damals gab es die noch nicht, aber generell wurde die Auflösung höher, mehr Polygone wurden da, neue Schattierungseffekte etc. Die Sache ist die, dass der optische Unterschied, die optischen Sprünge waren sehr hoch. Das heißt, ein Spiel vor einem Jahr sah halt wirklich noch schrottig aus. Aber im Vergleich. Und diesen optischen Anstieg, diesen Fortschritt, der verlangsamt sich momentan. Also ein Spiel jetzt vor drei Jahren sieht immer noch relativ gut aus. Im Vergleich zu heute. Klar, wenn ich jetzt Crysis daneben stelle, der Top-Vertreter, was Grafik angeht, klar sieht das alles schlechter aus. Aber es sieht noch gut genug aus. Das war fünf Jahre davor, nicht der Fall. Fünf Jahre davor war es so, dass du ein Spiel, das ein Jahr alt ist, nicht mehr im Laden stellen konntest.
Das heißt, es ändert sich gerade was?
Es ändert sich gerade was, ja.
Und was hat das für Wirkung?
Die Auswirkung ist, dass die Technologiekurve langsam abflacht. Das heißt, die Spiele sehen irgendwann mal alle perfekt gleich gut aus. Das heißt, die Umdenke geht zu mehr Inhalt.
Zu mehr Inhalt oder auch zu anderen Interaktionsmodellen, so wie bei der VCR?
Egal was. Andere Interaktionsmodelle, andere Inhalte, neue Methoden, Spiele zu verkaufen. Der PC ist ja immer so, der leidet immer sehr drunter, der PC-Markt, wenn der Konsolenhype groß ist. Das ist eine Welle. Der Hype ist jetzt letztes Jahr, dieses Jahr und nächstes Jahr wird der Konsolenhype sehr groß. Aber der Konsolenhype danach wird sehr klein, weil die Konsole sich nicht mehr so gut verkauft, den neu ist und nicht da. Dann ist der PC-Markt wieder groß. Weil jeder sagt, hier auf PC gibt es die tollen Sachen. Und jeder dieser Generationswechsel von Konsolen, ich sage es mal von Nintendo 64 auf Gamecube, hat der PC immer etwas gefunden, was ihn weiterentwickelt. Da gab es die 3D-Karte, hat den gesamten PC-Markt vorgebracht. Danach gab es das Internet, ich sage es mal, Team-Based-Online-Spiele, wie Counter-Strike und viele andere Sachen. Hat den PC-Markt riesig nach vorne gebracht. Da waren die gesamte Top Ten-Wartung aus solchen Spielen voll. Und diese Generation, mein Telefon, sind die Messe von anderen Spielen, die den PC-Markt oben halten. Würden die Messe von anderen Spielen nicht da sein, wie Guild Wars, Edge of Conan, World of Warcraft, wäre der PC-Markt um 20% geschrumpft.
Wie groß ist denn der Anteil von PC in den ganzen Spielemarkt? Ist das die Mehrheit oder ist das die Mehrheit? Wenn man jetzt sagt, ein Spiel verkauft sich n-mal, wie viele Prozente gehen dann im PC-Bereich?
Das kann man nicht so sagen. Viele Spiele, die auf Konsole sind, kommen gar nicht auf PC. Weil die Hersteller das nicht zulassen.
Das heißt, es ist ein ganz anderer Spielemarkt?
Ja, ein ganz anderer Spielemarkt. Weil A ist natürlich die Eingabemethode anders. Tastatur und Maus ist was anderes als ein Gamepad. Punkt 2 ist, Spiele müssen speziell für Konsole entwickelt werden. Und die Bedienbarkeit. Und wenn ich das portiere auf dem PC, funktioniert das nicht immer. Und, das ist ganz wichtig, die sogenannte Aufmerksamkeit-Spanne des Spielers ist anders. Auf dem PC kann ich von einer Stunde ausgehen. Wenn ich mich an einen PC setze und spiele, kann ich den Spieler für eine Stunde vereinnahmen und ihm innerhalb dieser Stunde ein Erfolgserlebnis geben. Auf einer Konsole muss ich das Spiel so bauen, dass es in 20 Minuten passiert. Das ist kürzer. Ich mache die Konsole mal kurz an, spiele ein bisschen, bis ich in einer halben Stunde zum Zug muss. Das geht mit dem PC nicht.
Dafür bootest du auch nicht so lange.
Dafür bootest du nicht so lange. Aber wie gesagt, das ist ein großer Unterschied vom Design her und vom Anspruch der Spiele her. Ergo funktionieren nicht alle Spiele von Konsole auf PC und umgekehrt.
Und man hat auch ein einfaches Entwicklungsmodell. Du hast ja vorhin ausführlich beschrieben, wie komplex der Vorgang ist, den man da machen muss, bis man überhaupt auf einer Konsole eine Software veröffentlichen kann. Auf dem PC kann jeder. Das bringt dann auch mehr Innovation mit sich.
Und mehr Schrott, also beides.
Ja klar. Und was ist gerade so die Innovation? Also gibt es irgendwas, was sich gerade so mal abzeichnet?
Nein, wir messen mit Online-Spielen. Also eigentlich geht der... World of Warcraft. Ja, World of Warcraft ist natürlich Spitzenreiter, aber es gibt in Asien viel größere Massive-Online-Spiele. Die kennen wir noch nicht. Aber generell ist der Online-Markt auf dem PC deshalb am explodieren. Und da sind die Bereiche noch gar nicht abgesteckt. Wir haben noch gar nicht alles entdeckt, was man dort machen kann. Es gibt da Beispiele. World of Warcraft ist natürlich die Königsklasse. Da ist ein Spiel, das macht Milliarden Umsätze jedes Jahr, ist seit drei Jahren in den Top 10 und ist der Star. Aber, ich darf nicht vergessen, die Entwicklung war sehr teuer. Das waren an die 50 Millionen US-Dollar, die da reingeflossen sind. Plus halt alles, was drum rum ist. Es gibt natürlich auch kleinere Spiele, die großen Erfolg haben. Es gibt in Frankreich einen kleinen Laden, der hat ein Spiel auf Flash-Basis gemacht, auch ein Massive-Online-Spiel. Nicht in 3D, halt nur in Flash. Die haben inzwischen fast 5 Millionen Spieler. 5 Millionen Spieler.
Die online sind.
Die online sind, das heißt Dofus. Kannte damals kaum jemand, aber seit 4 Jahren konsequent online. Da geht es jetzt hin. Es gibt im Onlinespielmarkt eine Fragmentierung. Es gibt auf der einen Seite die sogenannten Klein-Base-Spiele. Ich muss mir so einen Gigabyte runterladen, und dann kann ich mit großem Aufwand das Ding erspielen. Nature of Conan, World of Warcraft, was ich auch im Laden kaufen muss. Ich kann es mir nicht runterladen. Als Konkurrenz dazu die Sachen, wo ich mit den Kleinen im Internet runterladen muss. Ich kann umsonst spielen. Hier und da kann ich mir dazu kaufen, womit der Geld macht. Dann gibt es dann die neuen Messe für andere Spiele, die browser-based sind, die im normalen Explorer laufen. Das sind drei Märkte zwischen...
Im normalen Webbrowser?
Genau, im normalen Webbrowser. Ob Internet oder Opera oder Firefox, die sind dahingestellt. Diese Spiele sind sehr casual-gamer-orientiert, die Browser-Games. Die World of Warcraft sind sehr hardcore-orientierte Games.
Da brauchen wir auch viel Zeit für.
Ja, aber die Spiele nur noch das.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich hatte hier auch schon mal eine Ausgabe von Chaos Radio Express, wo wir so in die Untiefen von World of Warcraft eingestiegen sind. Da kam schon gut bei Robert, wie viel Zeit man da in der Regel investieren muss.
Es gab ein interessantes Statistikprogramm, in dem man die Zeit eingeben kann. Das haben wir vor einer Woche entdeckt. Da kann man die Zeit eingeben. Man kann in World of Warcraft slash Plate eingeben. Dann gibt er die Anzahl der Tage und Stunden wieder, wie lange man online war. Das kann man da eingeben. Dann sagt er einem, wie viel Zeit seines Lebens man in World of Warcraft verbracht hat. Würde man zum Minimum McDonalds-Lohn, hätte man da gearbeitet, hätte man sonst so viel Geld verdient. Und Rekord sind momentan 45.000 Euro in unserer Gilde. Die hätte man in der Zeit verdienen können. Aber wie gesagt, das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Aber man macht bei McDonalds nicht so viel Spaß wie in World of Warcraft.
Und macht dick, wenn man da arbeitet.
Ob World of Warcraft so viel schlanker macht, weiß ich ja nicht.
Aber generell ist es so, dass der PC-Markt sich immer mehr in Richtung Online bewegt. Die Team-Based-Shooter lernen immer mehr dazu. Wer Call of Duty 4 gespielt hat, da kommen jetzt so Rollenspielelemente rein. Je länger ich Call of Duty 4 spiele, umso mehr Sachen schalte ich frei. Ich kriege noch eine Goodie. Plötzlich habe ich Goldene Colts und tolle neue Fähigkeiten. Das wird immer mehr kommen in diese kurzweiligen Spiele, wie Shooter und andere Ex-Spiele oder auch Autorennen. Dann kommen die großen Rollenspiele, die virtuellen Welten auf uns zu und die Casual-Online-Spiele. Aber der Kern ist, dass ich mit vielen tausend Leuten miteinander und gegeneinander spielen kann. Da haben wir noch lange nicht ausgelotet, was alles möglich ist. Da ist momentan der große Trend vom PC hin.
Jetzt gibt es ja diese neuen Handheld-Plattformen, hatten wir ja schon angesprochen. Neu sind sie nicht wirklich. Das entwickelt sich natürlich auch weiter. Nintendo DS ist ein großer Erfolg mit dem ganzen Brain-Kram usw. Aber was hier schon die ganze Zeit dazwischenfunkt, ist ja jetzt auch eine interessante Plattform. Das iPhone schickt sich jetzt an, auch eine Spieleplattform zu werden. Was hältst du davon?
Ich halte es sehr viel von, vor allem, weil hier die Nintendo-Methode des haptischen Interfaces eingebaut ist. Die einfache Bedienbarkeit. Ich habe schon experimentelle Videos gesehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast. Da haben drei Leute zusammen Pong gespielt mit drei iPhones. Durch die Luft auch. Im Netzwerk. Das ist der Anfang, wo die Leute experimentieren, wie man mit so einem Gerät interessante Spiele machen kann. Man kann nur noch die Kamera mit integrieren in das Spiel. Das Bluetooth, das Netzwerk, das Online, das Beschleunigungssensor, das Lautsprecher und das Mikrofon. Da sind alle Dinge drin, die ich brauche, um ganz interessante Dinge zu tun. Da wird viel Tolles, Experimentales gemacht werden, was Vorreiter werden wird für Spiele, die dann irgendwann mal auf diesen Geräten... Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass diese Geräte zusammenwachsen. Ich hatte damals, als ich... Da hatte ich mein Palm-PDA. Ich hatte mein Telefon und meinen MP3-Player und keine Ahnung, was in der Hand. Da habe ich auch einmal gesagt, ich habe nur ein Gerät, was das alles kann. Jetzt habe ich mein iPhone, das macht meine MP3s. Ich kann meine Lieblings-DVD-Serien draufgucken. Ich kann telefonieren, online gehen. Mein Kalender, E-Mail ist alles drin, was ich brauche. Ein Gerät, so wie ich es immer haben wollte. Wenn man das alles zusammenschaut, und die Ein- und Ausgabemethoden dazusieht, dann kann ich ganz fantastische Spiele machen. Ich habe ja 10 Millionen iPhone-User weltweit, mit denen ich dann kommunizieren kann. In 5-10 Jahren werden alle diese Handys...
Und GPS ist jetzt auch noch mit dabei.
Und GPS ist auch noch mit drin. Location-Based Entertainment. Da ist ja eine große Zukunft eventuell. Muss mal gucken, ob man das auch haben will.
Ja, das ist... Alter, da könnte ich mir schon eine Menge vorstellen. Man läuft durch die Stadt und dann kann man natürlich irre Sachen machen.
Also ich hab mir immer vorgestellt, dass der erste Spiel, den ich machen würde, wäre wirklich ein Location-Based Game, wo man durch die Gegend läuft und durch seine Handykamera guckt. Und anhand der Richtung, wo er guckt und GPS-Koordinaten, blättet er Dinge in das reale Bild ein, die aber nur in dieser virtuellen Parallelwelt sind. Zum Beispiel, dass ich nur durch mein Handy die Vampire sehen kann.
Augmented Reality. Da fehlt aber noch der Kompass in dem Gerät.
Ja, das kriegen sie hin durch die Emulation. Und keine Ahnung, was Motoren sind, sollen wir mal schauen. Oder so eine Art Matrix-Parallelwelt, dass man nur die Viecher erkennt, wenn man da durchguckt oder so. Aber da gibt es viele Sachen, die man da machen kann.
Das ist wie bei John Carpenter. Kennst du diesen alten Science-Fiction-Film, wo er die Sonnenbrille irgendwie aufsetzt und dann sieht er, dass die Hälfte der Leute sind Aliens? Obweier, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das sehen will. Das wurde vorhin so ausgeführt, das wusste ich auch noch gar nicht, wie Nintendo das so macht. Dass dieser Approval-Prozess so umfangreich ist. Das ist ja jetzt auch in der Diskussion bei Apple.
Die machen es ähnlich, damit es nicht so viel Schrott gibt. Da gibt es natürlich einen Aufschrei. Ich muss es genehmigen lassen und ich kann nur in euren Job wenden. Aber damit schützt die Qualität des Marktes sich, damit es nicht kaputt geht. Das müssen die Leute sehen, dass sie eben nicht Schrott verkaufen können. Nachher gibt es dann die ersten Leute, die Pornos mit anbieten. Das will dann Apple nicht, weil das auch dem Images-Gerät schadet. Dementsprechend halt dann auch der Marktdurchdringung. Ich habe mit vielen gesprochen von Sony Ericsson. Ich habe mit Nvidia gesprochen. Die sagen alle, danke Apple, dass ihr das iPhone gebracht habt. Ihr habt uns wachgerüttelt, wie Telefone eigentlich aussehen sollten. Man muss sich hier vorstellen, wenn ich mein erstes Handy nehme, das war von Sony, das war das erste Handy mit Lithium-Ion-Akku. Das war richtig so ein Knochen. Das Vergleiche mit dem Handy heute, das hat sich ja kaum was geändert. Die Bedienung ist immer noch gleich. Scheiße auf gut Deutsch.
Ist sogar schlimmer geworden, wenn du mich fragst. Damals waren sie noch halbwegs schnell zu bedienen.
Ich hatte das Nokia N95 mit 320 Applikationen drin. Da blickt doch keiner mehr durch. Dann ist es mir immerhin gegangen, hat das Ganze vereinfacht. Jetzt sind alle aufgewacht und sagen, okay, in die Richtung müssen wir gehen. Wir werden mit einem großen Tara in 5-10 Jahren da sein, dass diese ganzen Dinge viel einfacher zu bedienen sind und viel mächtiger. Die Technologie macht einen Riesenfortschritt. Durch den Anspruch, dass diese Dinge tragbare, komplette Computer sind, werden immer mehr Leute es schaffen, andere Dinge zu integrieren, Strom zu sparen. Wie jetzt Nvidia einen kompletten 3D-Chip zum Beispiel. 3D-Spiele auf dem Ding sind irgendwann überhaupt kein Problem. Das haben sie jetzt schon auf ihrem Prototypen gezeigt. Das Ding hält vier Stunden durch oder fünf. Das ist länger als die PSP von Sony. Gut, aber da geht es dann hin. Ich freue mich schon, wenn ich in dem Ding ein bisschen mehr anstehen kann.
Vor allem, man muss nicht so viel Geld investieren. Was hast du gesagt? Bei Nintendo muss man erst mal 50.000 Dollar auf den Tisch legen, bevor man da überhaupt mal darf.
Die 50.000 Dollar, dafür kriegt man natürlich auch was. So einen Wii-Titel brauche ich schon 20, 25 Leute dafür. Jeder braucht so ein Entwicklungssystem. Mal 3.000, 4.000, 5.000 Dollar plus die Rechner plus die Software. Das ist natürlich billiger auf so einem iPhone. Aber es ist vergleichbar mit einer Game-Boy-Entwicklung. Beim Game-Boy ist es viel günstiger. Die Entwicklungs-Sets sind nicht ganz billig, aber immerhin 1200 Euro für ein so ein Ding. Da brauche ich dann auch nur meine sieben Leute, um so ein Spiel zu machen. Und beim iPhone brauche ich jetzt vielleicht nur einen, nachher vielleicht zwei, drei, vier, kommen in irgendwelche Regionen. Eine Game Boy DS-Entwicklung kostet heutzutage zwischen 400.000 und 500.000 Euro nur die Entwicklung von einem Spiel. Auf dem iPhone wird sich das in einem Moment einpendeln zwischen 50.000 und 250.000 Euro, je nachdem, wie groß es ist.
Die man jetzt selber aufwenden muss, um so ein Spiel zu entwickeln?
Nein, generell. Wenn ich jetzt als Firma hingehen würde, ich will jetzt ein gutes Spiel auf dem iPhone entwickeln, da ist es von Action-Spielen für 50.000 Euro gut, Puzzle-Spiele sind einfacher, die zählen nicht. Ich will ein Real-Time-Strategie-Spiel machen, wie Warcraft. Da würde es vielleicht 50.000 Euro kosten. Würde ich dann eine Messe für ein Spiel machen, oder ein Spiel, das ich online spielen kann, wäre es dementsprechend inskalierbar nach oben sein. Aber immer noch relativ günstig.
Aber man muss nicht so viel in die Plattform investieren. Apple nimmt ja gerade mal 100 Dollar, dann hat man ja eigentlich alles.
Dann hat man alles, genau. Es werden sehr viele kreative Applikationen von Einzel-Campagnen kommen.
Siehst du das so, dass das iPhone, das Apple, jetzt tatsächlich in diesem Spielemarkt auftaucht? Dass sie wirklich als Player dort auftreten?
Also sie werden das Ding sicherlich nicht als iGaming-Ding auf den Markt bringen. Aber es ist für sie ein wichtiger Bereich, für den die Leute auch spielen wollen. Und vor allem, sie haben jetzt auch gezeigt, dass sie wollen, dass das Ding billiger wird. Gut, in Deutschland noch nicht. Aber es gibt Länder, da kann man für 160 Dollar ein iPhone kaufen, ohne Vertrag. Und man hat das Ding in der Tasche. Und dann haben sie aber einen breiteren Markt, die User-Basis, und dann ist es ganz klar, dass die Leute auch spielen wollen. Vor allem mit den Online-Fähigkeiten. Und da braucht es nur einige Applikationen, die jeder haben will. Und plötzlich haben sie alle das iPhone.
Dadurch könnte ja auch, ich meine, die Programmierung für das iPhone ist im Prinzip immer nahezu identisch, wenn man jetzt mal von den Sensoren und dem Touchscreen absieht.
Du weißt, welcher Prozessor da drin ist.
Ist ein ARM-Prozessor drin.
Welcher war der erste Homecomputer mit dem ARM-Prozessor?
Das war der Archon.
Der Archon, der BBC Micro, genau.
Also es war kein ARM-Prozessor, sondern es war der Archon-Prozessor.
Aber es war die gleiche Firma, Archon Risk, Dingsbums oder Micro-G, wie der hieß damals. Archon Risk Machines. Und das war ein gigantisch geiler Prozessor. Ich habe damals das Assembler gelernt von dem Ding. Der hat Dinge ganz anders gemacht als der 6502. Der kannte ja kein Branching, der ARM-Prozessor.
Nicht?
Nein. Was er gemacht hat, ist, du hattest vorne vor jedem Befehl die Flags. Du kennst das noch, dieses Brand. Genau, und bei dem ARM-Prozessor, das war ja ein 16-Bit- oder 32-Bit-Prozessor, da waren die ersten 8-Bit für die Flex reserviert und wenn du sagtest, Branch-on-Carrier hat da praktisch die Befehle, wo das Carrier-Flag nicht gesetzt ist, ignoriert und hat sich einfach übergangen.
Ah, verstehe, das heißt man hat für jede Instruktion die Information, wann das, unter welcher Bedingung die da nur ausgefilft werden soll.
Genau, und hat sozusagen so Bits gesetzt davor, wann und wann. Und da, dass er, sagen wir mal, rasend schnell durch den Speicher geht, ja, war das Ding so schnell.
Ist das jetzt bei der Arm-Architektur immer noch so?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch so ist. Das ist inzwischen Arm 9 oder wie das immer ist, aber ich schätze mal, die Bate ist ähnlich geblieben. Deswegen sind die so schnell und so spät.
Ich muss mal einen Podcast über Arm-Architektur machen. Ach Gott, so viele Podcasts, die man noch machen muss. Aber wie auch immer ist auf jeden Fall, ich habe so 3D-mäßig das eine oder andere schon gesehen auf dem iPhone, dass...
Eine alte PC-Grafikkarte.
Das kann was, das Ding.
Die ganz raffiniert arbeitet. Eine Grafikkarte, die zahlenorientiert arbeitet.
Zeilen?
Ja, Zeilen. Wir haben damals die Grafikkarte auf dem PC gehabt. Die Firma wollte in den PC-Markt rein, hat es aber nicht geschafft.
Welche Firma? Von welcher Firma reden wir jetzt?
Wenn ich das noch wüsste.
Die jetzt im iPhone. Wir reden jetzt konkret vom iPhone.
Wir reden von der iPhone 3D-Grafikkarte, die da drin ist. Die hat 3D-Kapazitäten.
Ja, die hat 3D-Kapazitäten. Deshalb gibt es ja auch OpenGL da drin. Ich überlege mir gerade, ob ich überhaupt weiß, welche Grafik...
Diese Grafikkarte hat... Die heutigen Grafikkarten haben ja einen Frame-Buffer von 512 bis 1 GB. Das liegt daran, dass die gesamten Texturen drin liegen, plus der sogenannte Frame-Buffer. Also das Bild, was dargestellt wird, muss bis zu 3- oder teilweise 5-mal in Speicher liegen. Weil wegen Triple-Buffering, noch NtL-Jasign und Filterungen, keine Ahnung, weswegen brauchen die so viel Speicher. Die haben damals eine Grafikkarte vorgestellt, die einen minimalen Frame-Buffer brauchte, weil die nur zahlenorientiert gearbeitet hat. Das heißt, sie hat den Frame-Buffer nur von einer einzigen Zeile halten müssen. Und diese Pixel-Information, die sie gehabt hat, damit konnten sie rumspielen. Damit konnten sie ganz tolle Geschichten machen. Und das soll die Grafikkarte sein, die da drin ist. Die Power-VR-Architektur, genau, das war die Seite.
Imagination Technologies, formerly Videologic.
Die hatten wir damals und dann konnten wir ganz tolle Sachen machen vom Rendering her. Ohne einen großen Frame-Buffer zu haben. Und das ist glaube ich der Trick, weil ohne Frame-Buffer brauche ich weniger Speicher, ich brauche weniger aufwendige Chips und dadurch frisst das Ding nicht so viel Strom.
Ja, das ist die Technik. Genau, jetzt erinnere ich mich auch, also die sind ja Zulieferer für fast den ganzen Embedded-Markt. Also ganz viele von diesen Embedded-Prozessoren benutzen diese Grafik. Also jetzt im Falle von Apple ist es ja der Marvell-Arm, wobei ja jetzt auch gemutmaßt wird, dass Apple jetzt auch Mr. Jobs durchklingen lassen. Die haben sich ja gerade diese PA-Semi-Bude gekauft. Und mittlerweile wurde es auch bestätigt, dass sie halt jetzt tatsächlich mit diesem Team sich ihre eigenen Prozessoren entwickeln. Die werden bei arm bleiben. Die gehen nicht auf Intel-Item.
Nee, aber ich glaube auch, dass die...
Die werden sich dann hoch integriert einen Prozessor bauen, der einfach all das kann, was sie eben brauchen, genau für ihre Anwendung.
Also ich sehe bei Apple noch solche Sachen wie... Ich übertreibe es mal, ein iPod-Nano. Quatsch, ein iPhone-Nano. Also ein iPhone ohne den ganzen Klumpen hat schon rum.
Wie ohne Bildschirm?
Nee, schon mit Touch und drum und dran. Aber kleiner, sexier und eher Multimedia-fokussiert. Und nicht Office-orientiert. Das Ding ist ja ein Internet-Multimedia-sonst-was-Ding. Aber ich sage es mal, ein iPod, den normalen, mit Telefon drin. Dass sie in die Richtung gehen und dass sie das nicht... Ein iPod Touch, der ist groß. Aber ich stelle mir vor, das Ding ist halb so groß. Aber ich kann trotzdem alle meine Videos anschauen.
Da habe ich meine Zweifel, ob sie da noch kleiner gehen. Da würde ich ja fast eher sagen, sie werden eher noch größer. Aber naja, wir wollen jetzt ja auch keinen Apple-Podcast aus dem Chaos-Radio Express machen. Trotzdem ist das natürlich interessant im Hinblick auf Computerspiele. Auch deshalb, weil ja der Macintosh eigentlich derzeit in der Computerspiele-Welt kein Rollenspiel kann man sagen. Aber in dem Moment, wo man halt für das iPhone entwickelt, darauf wollte ich vorhin hinaus, benutzt man dieselben APIs und Entwicklungswerkzeuge. Man muss auch Macintosh sowieso schon mal auf dem Tisch haben, um das zu machen. Das heißt, man kann wahrscheinlich 80-90 Prozent des Codes sofort wieder verwenden, muss dann noch ein anderes User-Interface drauflegen. Aber Spiele haben ja in der Regel, die benutzen sowieso relativ wenig von dem Native-Environment. Von daher ist es vielleicht sogar noch weniger. Das könnte dazu führen, dass das iPhone auch den Spielemarkt für den Macintosh wieder neu belebt.
Es ist möglich. Also der Macintosh-Spielmarkt funktioniert momentan ziemlich seltsam. Es gibt drei hochspezialisierte Firmen weltweit, die Rechte für Spiele aufkaufen und die selber umsetzen auf Macintosh und die dann dort vertreiben.
Weißt du, die drei?
Da müsste ich nachgucken. Es gibt so einen Ober-Guru in den USA, der macht das Ganze alleine. So ein Ding portieren für eine Firma. Ich muss mal nachschauen, wie die heißen. Ich habe es vergessen, aber das sind die wenigen, die sowas tun. Es gibt einen Star-Entwickler, der Macintosh unterstützt 1 zu 1. Das ist World of Warcraft, Blizzard. Alle Spiele von Blizzard laufen auf beiden Plattformen. Da sind es aber die wenigen, weil man muss es ja von Anfang an unterstützen, um das so zu tun und das machen auch nicht viele. Und die Problematik beim Apple ist halt, dass er sehr business-orientiert ist und dann auch nur einen ganz gewissen Markt anspricht. World of Warcraft hat deswegen so einen großen Mac-Durchsatz, weil sie es halt von vorn unterstützt haben. Aber es ist schwierig. Ich glaube nicht, dass es den Mac-Inter-Spiele-Markt beleben wird. Das, was es eher beleben wird, sind die dann Betriebssystemen, unabhängigen Online-Spiele, die kommen werden. Das ist völlig egal, auf welche Plattform wir laufen. Ob auf PC, Mac, iPhone, Wurscht, Hauptsache, Process- oder Internetzugang.
Was hält denn die Spiele-Entwickler davon ab, jetzt auf andere Plattformen zu gehen? Ich meine, Spiele auf Computern findet im Wesentlichen eigentlich unter Windows statt, kann man so sagen.
Da, wo es Geld ist, gehen die Spielehersteller hin.
Ja, aber wie groß muss denn ein Markt dann sein? Ich meine, der Macintosh-Markt hat ja im Vergleich zum PC-Markt immer den Vorteil, dass Leute sind, die eigentlich gerne auch ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgeben, überhaupt generell bereit sind.
Ja, bei weniger Spielen.
Ja, aber vielleicht weniger spielen, das kann man sagen. Aber das kann sich jetzt erinnern, weil der Appeal ja mehr zu jungen Leuten geht.
Ich sage immer, auf Macintosh spielt man deswegen weniger, weil man ja eigentlich genug Spielzeug schon auf dem Tisch stehen hat. Das ist immer so meine Sache. Die Sache ist die, wenn ich heutzutage ein Spiel entwickele, gibt es eine einfache Faustformel. 5000 Euro pro Monat, das sind alle Kosten drin. Das ist eine einfache Faustformel, wie man ein ungefähres Budget aussehen kann, wie teuer ist ein Spiel. Ich brauche heutzutage, um ein Spiel zu machen, ein Minimum von 25 Leuten. Nimm 20, das sind das 1,2 Millionen Euro pro Jahr. Die hast du jetzt einfach mit den 20 Leuten. Du brauchst heutzutage, um ein gescheites Spiel zu entwickeln, 2 Jahre. 2,5 Millionen Euro kostet ein Spiel in der Entwicklung. Wie viel muss ich dann verkaufen? Ich mache dann ein Spiel, das ich weltweit verkaufe, im Schnitt 22 bis 28 Euro, abhängig vom Gebiet, aber im Schnitt 25 Euro Gewinn, Einnahmen. Ohne Marketing jetzt rein, nur was unten drunter bleibt. Dann muss ich meine 100.000 Stück verkaufen. Wer verkauft heute noch 100.000 Stück? Wenn man in Deutschland sieht, die Top 10, da sind nicht viele Spiele, die 100.000 Stück verkaufen.
Aber es gibt welche.
Es gibt welche. Es gibt Leute, die verkaufen ein paar Millionen weltweit. Aber das ist, wie gesagt, zwei Spiele von einem Publisher, die müssen dafür zahlen, dass acht andere Spiele weltweit nicht performen.
Aber ist dann eine mögliche Zukunft, wie man schon gesagt hat, Browser-Games spielen derzeit eine relativ große Rolle? Auch in Deutschland?
Es reicht in Deutschland, weil Deutschland hat sich einen Weltmarktanteil von 60 Prozent gesichert, was Browserspiele angeht. Wir scheinen das irgendwie gefunden zu haben. Das hat damit auch zu tun, dass wir Browserspiele weltweit publishen können, ohne einen Publisher zu haben.
Aber warum ist jetzt ausgerechnet Deutschland mit Technik-Verliebtheit kann das jetzt nicht viel zu tun haben?
Aus dem Grund, weil Deutschland hat immer darunter gelitten, dass wir, also um Geld zu machen in der Spielindustrie, muss man natürlich verkaufen, es geht weltweit. Und deutsche Publisher waren bisher fast nie in der Lage, das zu tun. Du musstest immer zu internationalen Publishern gehen. Und internationalen Publishern, da gehst du dann praktisch mit der weltweiten Konkurrenz vor die Tür und sagst, nimm doch mein Spiel. Und das sind die Deutschen relativ unerfahren in der Richtung, bzw. die haben die Erfahrung gar nicht gehabt. So, und die deutschen Publisher sind sozusagen die erste Mauer gewesen, warum sich das deutsche Spiele-Entwicklermarkt nicht so entwickelt hat, wie hätte sein sollen. Es gab mal eine Zeit, da war der sehr gesund, das lag aber daran, dass der deutsche Markt sich selber bedienen konnte. Also man konnte für den deutschen Markt Spiele machen und so viel verkaufen, dass jeder gut Geld gemacht hat. Die Zeiten sind aber vorbei, weil die Entwicklungskosten so teuer geworden sind. Ja, irgendwann sprengst du das mal die Millionengrenze und schon kannst du in Deutschland nicht mehr genug verkaufen. Das zweite ist, dass der Markt schagniert ist. Wir haben damals von Hitspielen drei, vier, 500.000 Stück verkaufen können, nur in Deutschland. Jetzt gehen Hitspiele, selbst das USA, in Deutschland kaum über 100.000 Grenze. Das liegt an Rob-Propien, das liegt an Onlinespielen, das liegt an vielen Sachen. Und das ist so die Problematik. Und die Browserspiele erlauben es uns weltweit, ohne den Hintern aus dem Büro zu nehmen, mein Game zu publishen.
Aber wie verdient man denn damit Geld?
Browserspiele hat so genanntes Micropayment. Man macht also erstmal, holt die Masse rein ins Spiel, die haben Spaß dran, komplett umsonst das Spiel. Und da gibt es aber, wenn ich jetzt in das Spiel mal gefangen bin, und ich spiele mit anderen und gegen anderen, gibt es da plötzlich Methoden, wie ich gewisse Dinge schneller kriege. Ich kaufe mir einen Zeitvorteil. Und den Zeitvorteil kann ich mir kaufen, indem ich dort eine virtuelle Währung kaufe, mit richtigem Geld. Und diese virtuelle Währung kann ich im Spiel ausgeben, für bessere Gegenstände oder einen Zeitvorteil, oder ich level schneller, oder ich kann mein Haus bauen. Das nennt sich Micropayment. Die Summen, die da gehen, sind meistens in Eurobeträge. Ich zahle mal 2, 3, 5 oder 10 Euro ein, mehr nicht. Und nicht gleich 50 Euro, wie im Spiel im Laden. Der Trick dabei ist, dass wenn ich mal 5 Millionen Leute habe, die mal ein Spiel spielen, davon vielleicht 5% mal zahlen. Aber die 5% zahlen im Verhältnis mehr, als wenn ich von allen 5 Millionen Leuten Geld haben wollte. Die Masse macht es, genau, und das geht nur, wenn ich weltweit rausgehe. Und das kann ich aber, ohne einen Publisher zu haben, ohne großen Aufwand, weil ich online publishe. Das kann ich alleine von Deutschland aus.
Das geht aber dann beim iPhone natürlich auch wunderbar. Ich meine, da mit niedrigen Preisen zu rechnen, die Spiele für den iPod haben alle 5 Dollar gekostet.
Ja, hier sagt man zwischen 5 Dollar und aufwärts. Ich habe jetzt schon das erste Spiel für 19 Dollar gesehen, von dem man da angekündigt hat.
Ja gut, aber das wird sich einpendeln, also diese 5-Dollar-Geschichte. Sogar ich, der Spieleagnostiker, habe mir dann auf dem iPod auch tatsächlich für 5 Dollar so ein paar Teile gekauft. Das ist schon mal so einiges. Wie ist denn da so dein Stand zu Raubkopien, diesen blöden Namen? Man hat schon gesagt, dass das ein Problem für die Szene ist, aber auf der anderen Seite wissen wir auch, das ist auch etwas, was Sachen populär macht.
Das schneidet sich aber ein bisschen, ich kann ein Beispiel geben. Es gibt Hitspiele, die sich weltweit nachweislich sehr gut verkauft haben. Die haben mit Mio-Not in Deutschland eine 100.000-Grenze geschafft. Das gleiche Hitspiel, genau vergleichbare Qualität von einem Spiel nur mit einem 100%igen Kopierschutz, weil nämlich Online-Aktivierung drin war, hat sich plötzlich 480.000-mal verkauft. Wir reden hier von einem Unterschied. Company of Heroes als der besten Strategiespiel der letzten Zeit hat sich weltweit hervorragend verkauft, nur in Deutschland nicht. In Deutschland haben wir von diesem Spiel 20.000 Stück verkauft. Und das ist das bestwerteste Strategiespiel aller Zeiten fast, neben Warcraft 3. 20.000 Stück ist nichts, ist lächerlich. Der Grund war die Rob-Kopie. Im Vergleich dazu Half-Life 2.
Warum kannst du dir da sicher sein?
Sicher sein kann ich deswegen, weil die Amerikaner den Fehler gemacht haben und haben die ungeschützte Version zwei Wochen vorher in den USA rausgebracht. Und jeder, den du gefragt hast, hat es schon gespielt und dann kam der Beweis. Sie haben ein paar Monate später die Spielerweiterung rausgebracht. Also das ist eine Szenarioerweiterung. Diese Szenarioerweiterung hat aber einen Kopie-Schutz drauf und hat geprüft, ob du ein Original hattest oder nicht. Und diese Erweiterung hat sich komischerweise 80.000 Mal verkauft. Wie kann es sein, dass sie eine Erweiterung mehr verkauft als das Originalspiel? Half-Life 2, auch ein Starspiel, im gleichen Niveau, nur an das Genre, hat sich in Deutschland über 480.000 Mal verkauft. Und warum? Weil Half-Life 2 über Steam aktivierbar sein muss. Du musstest es online aktivieren, sonst ging das Ding nicht.
Steam ist was?
Steam ist die Download-Plattform von dem Half-Life-Hersteller. Und um spielen zu können, musstest du es dort aktivieren. 100% Kopie-Schutz, das ging gar nicht anders. Und siehe da.
Ist das so der Trend, Online-Aktivierung?
Ja, generell online ist der Trend, ob es jetzt Spiel ist oder Aktivierung, ist egal. Aber es gibt einen 100% Kopie-Schutz. World of Warcraft ist genau der gleiche Grund. Es kann ja nicht kopiert werden, wenn man es von den Piratenzwervern absieht. Aber ist der gleiche Grund.
Man braucht halt einen Account.
Man braucht einen Account, genau. Und dadurch brauchen wir CD-Key.
Das heißt, das Problem Robkopien löst sich demnächst automatisch. Einerseits durch Online, andererseits durch Online-Sales und verschlüsselte Bineries, wie das jetzt bei der iPhone-Plattform ist ja so, dass man halt, man kriegt ja eine persönliche Kopie, die für einsetzt ist.
Das war bei den Handys, das war für ein Handy ja genauso. Also hier geht es dann über einen Account, glaube ich. Und bei den Handys war es ja so, dass die auf dein Telefon gemünzt waren mit deiner Nummer und du konntest diese Spiele vom Handy zu Handy nicht rübernehmen. Musst du neu kaufen. Und das ist, da geht es sowieso hin. Aber generell war Piraterie immer ein Teil von unserer Branche. Vor- und Nachteil. Nachteil, weil es die Sales gedrückt hat. Vorteil, weil wir viele, viele Talente aus der Piratenzene geholt haben. Und auch, weil gegenseitig viel gelernt worden ist. Und die Piraterie hat halt nur überhand genommen, weil sie vom Spezialistenkreis nur wir-können-das-kopieren-und-craken zum Massenphänomen geworden ist. Und zum Massenphänomen, weil halt auf Computerzeitschriften draus stand, so kopierst du Geschütze, DVDs und Spiele. Da kann selbst meine Mutter das durchlesen und kopieren. Und wenn es dann so weit ist, dann ist es plötzlich so schädlich, dass es den Markt kaputt machen kann. Und das war am Amige ja auch passiert. Am Amige wurde mehr kopiert, als nachher verkauft. Die Verkaufszahlen gingen alle runter und die Anzahl der Kopien gingen alle hoch. Das hat den Markt kaputt gemacht. Das wird da jetzt nicht sein, weil es jetzt Methoden gibt, das zu verhindern. Man kann es ja nicht verhindern, es ist verloren. Aber Leute, die kopieren, sagt man ja auch, sind dann nicht unbedingt die Käufer. Aber ich sage mal, die Masse macht es. Wenn 10 Millionen Leute nicht mehr kopieren würden und nur 100.000 Leute von diesen 10 Millionen würden es sich dann trotzdem kaufen, wären es 100.000 mehr verkauft. Der Ergo könnte sich das Ding auch billiger verkaufen.
Das heißt, die Preise werden runtergehen für Spiele?
Nein, die haben im Gegenteil, sie werden teurer. Erinnerst du dich noch an 80er Jahren? Hast du mal ein englisches Originalspiel gekauft im Laden? Also ich weiß es noch, ich bin in den Laden gekommen.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, was ich damals... Das habe ich nicht, weil ich mir gar keine Spiele gekauft habe.
Das hast du kopiert, ja.
Die paar, die ich gespielt habe, habe ich mir kopiert. Mein Interesse war einfach echt gering.
Wir haben damals die Kultspiele, die wir unbedingt als Spiele wollten, selber noch im Original gekauft, weil da ja immer was Tolles drin war. Und irgendwie fühlt sich das besser an. Ich sage es mal Ultima 3. Habe ich mir damals gekauft, hat gekostet 129 Mark. Und sowas bei allen Spielen. Amiga-Spiele haben 59-79 Mark gekostet, PC-Spiele 89-120 Mark, abhängig davon, ob Englisch-Original oder ob die offizielle deutsche Variante. Ergo, im Vergleich zu heute, haben sich die Preise seit über 20 Jahren nie geändert.
Ja, aber wenn jetzt so die Zeit der Online-Aktivierung ist und Raubkopien keine Rolle mehr spielen und den Markt nicht kaputt machen, dann kann es ja auch, man hat ja auch den Nachteil, dass sich ein Spiel nicht durch Raubkopien mehr herumsprechen kann. Das ist ja auch ein Marketing-Instrument.
Brauchst du nicht mehr, weil du hast das Internet.
Okay, das kann sein, aber vielleicht, naja, okay.
Du hast das Demo im Internet, du kannst alles mögliche anschauen. Die Problematik, die dagegen spricht, ist die explodierenden Entwicklungskosten. Bei den Entwicklungskosten haben wir einen exponentiellen Anstieg seit Jahren. Seitdem ich in der Branche bin, geht die Entwicklungskosten nicht stetig, sondern es gibt eine exponentielle Funktion. Wir reden davon, dass ich ein PC-Spiel mal gemacht habe für 500.000 Mark. Mein letztes Projekt waren 2,6 Millionen Euro. Wenn ich heute einen Top-PC-Titel planen müsste, ginge das nicht unter 10 Millionen Euro, wenn ich keine Ahnung stinke.
Aber es muss ja nicht immer dieser Top-Titel sein. Wenn man sieht, Browser Games sind auf einmal ein Riesenmarkt, das sind weder Top-Titel noch Riesen-Entwicklungssachen.
Aber Browser Games ist gerade der Start. Jetzt kommt dann irgendwann die Konkurrenz, wird wach. Und alle machen jetzt Browser Games. Ergo wird die Qualität hoch und dann geht plötzlich Material schlachtlos und die Entwicklungskosten gehen hoch. Die Leute gehen natürlich nur dahin, für die Spiele, die am besten sind, am komplexesten und schön aussehen. Und plötzlich musst du dann doch deine 30 Leute für ein Browser-Rollenspiel anstellen, um das gescheit zu machen. Und da ist die Problematik. Wir sind jetzt gerade am Anfang des Browser-Game-Marktes. Das ist so wie damals ein Amigaspiel zu dritt. In fünf Jahren wird das anders aussehen. Da machen wir auch mal eine Millionenproduktion mit einem Browserspiel. Und die Penetration, also der Wachstum des Marktes an sich, ist leider eine lineare Funktion. Und da beißt sich das ein bisschen.
Also in einer normalen Software-Entwicklung löst man ja das Problem durch Standards.
Oh, das wäre schön. Ein Traum.
Also mir ist schon klar, also jetzt gerade in diesem Wettlauf der letzten 10, 15 Jahre, da ist das natürlich schwierig gewesen. Weil nach zwei Jahren hatte man eine neue Grafikkarten-Generation mit komplett neuen Features. Und da muss man sowieso erstmal wieder alles neu......
einen neuen Prozessor, dann kam MMX und wie es alles hieß. Und keine Ahnung, was alles...
Genau, das wird sicherlich auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise weitergehen. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass ich das jetzt... Tja, welchen Eindruck habe ich eigentlich? Verlangsam, bzw. sich auch ein bisschen manifestiert. Also, dass Prozessoren jetzt mehrere Cores haben, das wird jetzt auf die nächsten absehbaren Jahre einfach der Multiplikator sein.
Weil...
Die Prozessoren werden nicht schneller, sondern man muss lernen, mit mehreren Cores zu arbeiten. Genauso ist es jetzt bei den Grafikkarten. Gut, da weiß ich jetzt nicht, das Feature-Set als der Karten selber scheint sich für meinen Unwissen auch ein bisschen einzufahren. Die werden jetzt nur noch ein bisschen leistungsfähiger und programmierbarer.
Genau, ich hatte es ja vorher schon erwähnt, dass die Grafikkarten, ich sage mal, die optische Veränderung der Grafik hat sich verlangsamt. Das ist ja genau das, was ich meine. Also, wenn ich jetzt die Grafikkarte, die in zwei Jahren rauskommen würde, vergleiche mit der heutigen Top-Nvidia-Karte, würde ich nicht so den großen Unterschied sehen. Oder ich sage mal, wie mein Lieblingsspruch immer, meine Mutter würde ihn nicht erkennen. Genau.
Und jetzt gab es, da können wir mal wieder kurz bei Apple reinschauen, auch sehr interessant. Die haben ja jetzt gerade angekündigt, dass ihr nächstes Betriebssystem keine neuen Features haben wird. Schöne Formulierung, also es sind natürlich Features mit drin, aber sie werden es nicht über Features verkaufen, sondern sie gönnen sich jetzt mal eine Verschnaufpause und ändern ihre Architektur. Und das sind jetzt genau diese beiden Sachen. Auf der einen Seite wollen sie halt ein großes Framework bereitstellen, um eben Multicore-Programmierung einfacher zu machen, um den Programmierern diese Parallelisierung zu vereinfachen. Und sie sind jetzt dabei und fügen einen neuen Standard mit rein. So wie ich gerade gelesen habe, findet das durchaus auch Anklang. In der Hardware-Szene OpenCL sozusagen das Computing, die Computing-Language für solche hardwarebeschleunigten Subsysteme. Mit Grafikkarten kann man dazu ja eigentlich gar nicht mehr so sagen. Das sind mehr so parallel Prozessor-Power, die man da so im Rechner mit drin hat. So wie ja OpenCL auch es schon geschafft hat, bestimmte Standards zu setzen, geht halt der Trend eigentlich zu Standards. Könnte das nicht dazu beitragen, dass Spielerentwicklung mehr als es bisher getan hat, auch wirklich auf etablierten Frameworks aufsetzen kann? Oder gibt es dann zu wenig Differenzierung?
Die Spiele sind sehr anfällig, dafür Standards aufzugreifen. Weil es die Entwicklung vereinfacht und beschleunigt. Und dadurch nehmen Spieleentwickler vor allem Standards, die sich durchgesetzt haben, sehr gerne und sehr schnell auf. Wie haben wir jetzt schon Standards? Wie haben wir jetzt schon, ich sage es mal, Unreal Engine. Es gibt Dutzende Spiele auf der Unreal Engine. Oder auf der Engine von ID, auf der Quake Engine. Es gibt toste von Spiele da draußen. Und da gibt es viele andere Technologien, die lizenziert sind, was der autonormale Verbraucher gar nicht sieht. Wie haben die Sound-Standards schon im Spielen drin? Da gibt es dann zwei Bibliotheken. Es gibt die Miles und es gibt diese...
Open Mile.
Nein, nicht Open Mile. Es gibt noch eine andere, die Spielehersteller benutzen. Diese Dissensieren, genauso wie Animationsbibliotheken und viele andere Sachen, Standards, die sie schon durchgesetzt haben, weil sie dort drin sind, genauso wie Dread X. Ist ja sehr schnell adaptiert worden, egal welche Variante oder welche Version. Außer diesen Dread X 10 Vorpaar. Aber das müssen wir halt Microsoft lassen.
Ist das ein Vorpaar?
Hast du Dread X 10 auf Windows XP am Laufen?
Ich benutze das nicht.
Ich sage ja, es geht nicht. Es geht nur auf Vista.
Ich benutze das eh nicht.
Und jetzt musst du ein neues Bezirkssystem kaufen dafür. Das ist ja egal. Aber jedenfalls gibt es diese Standardisierung schon. Wenn es eine Standardisierung gäbe, die das Ganze machen, trotz der Flexibilität dem Programmierer lässt, überall reinzugehen, wo er rein will, dann nimmt er das sofort auf. Die Problematik ist, die meisten Standards kastrieren dann immer gewisse Sachen, die aber viele Programmierer brauchen. Ich sage es mal, wenn du jetzt eine Dread X-Variante hättest, die dir nicht erlauben würde, direkt selber Shader zu programmieren, dann würde sich das nie durchsetzen. Das muss aber sein.
Verstehe, also man hat sozusagen zu wenig Unterscheidungsmerkmale am Ende und kann nicht alles rausholen?
Man kann diese Dinge nicht tun, die dann doch eine technische Lösung brauchen. Spieldesign-Sachen. Sag mal, wenn du ein Spiel machst, wo 100.000 Viecher über dem Bildschirm laufen müssen animiert, dann musst du das irgendwie technisch lösen. Und wenn das durch einen Standard, wenn der Standard da im Weg steht, dann wird der Standard einfach weggeschmissen.
Aber ich meine, jetzt sind wir im Prinzip wieder beim Anfang unseres Gesprächs. Ist es denn nicht eigentlich jetzt an der Zeit, mehr Kreativität walten zu lassen und neue Sachen wie Location, also die aktuelle Ortung mit einzubeziehen, Internet mit einzubeziehen, neue User-Interfaces auszuprobieren, einfach gute Ideen zu haben und kleine überschaubare Spiele zu machen und damit einen neuen Markt loszutreten?
Das sagen wir schon seit fünf Jahren. Und da gibt es ein Riesenproblem.
Und das ist?
Der Mensch steht sich da selber im Weg, seine Gewohnheiten. Also, um das mal, klingt so philosophisch, ja, ich sage es mal. Die gesamte Industrie ist seit 20 Jahren so gewachsen, dass es in gewissen Themengebieten gewisse Erfolge mit den Formeln zu erwarten hat. Und deswegen macht man das so. Und da von diesem Weg wegzugehen, brauchst du sehr viel Mut und sehr viel Geld. Also, wenn ich sagen würde, ein Investor würde mir ein paar Hundert Millionen aufs Konto gehen und sagen, mach einen neuen Publisher auf, der Electronic Arts schlägt. Mal als Beispiel, ja. Was würde ich denn tun? Ich würde sagen, ich mache eine Sportserie auf, ich mache den coolsten First-Person-Shooter der Welt, das beste Autorennen der Welt. Und in diesen Kategorien denkt man, warum man Marktsegmente erobern muss. Aber dann bin ich wieder in den neuen Schubladen, die jeder schon kennt. Wie soll ich mich differenzieren? Würde ich ihm jetzt sagen, du, ich mache jetzt keine Rennspiele, keine First-Person-Shooter und keine Sportspiele, obwohl das Geld liegt? Ich mache jetzt ganz kreative, künstlerische, ganz neue Sachen. Nur Will Wright Spiele, sage ich mal. Der Spawn-Sims, die er gefunden hat, die Sims. Der würde mich verrückt halten. Würde nicht gehen. Ergo brauchst du immer einen gewissen Anteil von Standardgeschichten, die man macht und einen Tick in Innovation. Aber wenn du zu sehr in die Innovation gehst, dann gehst du gegen die Gewohnheit des Spielers.
Ja gut, wenn man ein Publisher sein will, aber wenn man jetzt wirklich nur ein cooles Spiel programmieren will, dann muss man ja nicht gleich alles nachgucken, wenn etwas da ist.
Wer finanziert es dir?
Ja, keine Ahnung, wenn man niedrige Einstiegskosten hat.
Einstiegskosten überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber ich meine, diese ganzen Libraries und Frameworks, von denen du gesprochen hast, die sind ja da. Die Android-Engine ist frei, oder? Die kann man einfach so benutzen, oder ist das eine Lizenzgeschichte?
Nein, 500.000 Dollar kostet die.
Gut, aber vielleicht gibt es ja auch ein paar freie, die auf was taugen.
Aber du, pass auf, ich gebe dir mal einen Porsche-Motor und stelle den hier ins Wohnzimmer. Und ich warte von dir in zwei Jahren, weil ich den coolsten Sportwagen von dir habe. So viel zu Technologie. Es nützt die beste Technologie nicht, wenn du da nicht ein gescheites Spiel draus machst und die Erfahrung darauf hast. Also Technologie und Standards ist nur eine gewisse Basis, es ist ein Werkzeug. Da ist noch viel, viel mehr oben drauf, was viele Programmierer oben drauf packen müssen, um da ein funktionierendes Framework draus zu machen.
Aber was sagt man jetzt dem interessierten Chaos Radio Express-Hörer, der eigentlich schon ganz heiße Finger hat und unbedingt selber mal ein Spiel umsetzen möchte?
Die beste Methode, selber ein Spiel umzusetzen, ist, wie ich gesagt habe, dort, wo du die Masse hast, und das ist im Internet. Ich sage immer, wenn du eine coole Idee hast, machst du es in Flash oder machst es in anderen Technologiesachen oder völlig wurscht. Handy-Programmierung ist doch sehr old-fashioned. Kannst du auch auf dem iPhone machen. Eine große Chance für Spiele programmieren, kreative Spiele zu machen, und man kann sie selber in den iPhone Store setzen. Ist doch wunderbar. Und wenn sich rumspricht, dass das Spiel geil ist, das ist die Problematik übrigens, da zählt nur die Qualität, nichts anderes. Da verkaust du plötzlich 100.000 Stück für 5 Dollar und du sagst, oh geil. Ist wunderbar. Das ist die neue Methode des Internets oder generell dieser neuen mobilen Geräte. Ich kann sie selber publishen, ich kann selber da raus, ohne dass ich... Ich sag dir eins, wenn ich vor 5 Jahren zu einem Publisher gegangen wäre, und ihm gesagt hätte, du, zu der coolsten Metalliker-Musik kannst du hier auf 5 Tassen Gitarre spielen, zu 5 farbigen Klötzchen, die in den Bildschirm reingelaufen kommen, finde ich supercool, der hätte Publisher mich rausgeschmissen. Und heutzutage heißt das Ding Gitar Hero und ist in einer Million-Dollar-Industrie. Und das ist der Unterschied. Kann ich das auch im Markt durchsetzen? Und bei traditionellen Publishern ist es sehr schwierig, es sei denn, sie machen es selber und sie sehen das Potenzial. Ich meine, aktivistisch hat das aufgekauft, Gitar Hero, war eine andere Firma, die einen Patent da drauf hatte. Oder ich publishe das im Internet oder durch andere solche Massenmedien, werde dadurch bekannt und werde dann in die traditionellen Publisher gezogen.
So, jetzt haben wir hier schon eine lange Reise unternommen. Und natürlich gibt es noch, also ich sehe für diese Sendung definitiv eine lange, lange Liste in unserem Blog mit Kommentaren und Fragen, wie, warum habt ihr denn nicht darüber gesprochen, warum habt ihr nicht darüber gesprochen, warum habt ihr nicht darüber gesprochen. Da machen wir vielleicht noch mal einen Teil 2. Eins muss ich jetzt allerdings dort nochmal ansprechen, vielleicht so zum Schluss. Das ist diese Debatte um Killerspiele, die hängt dir sicherlich schon zum Hals raus. Weiß ich nicht, wie weit du sie selber geführt hast, aber das will ich schon nochmal ansprechen. Diese Sache mit der Verantwortung und dem, tja, keine Ahnung, wie man an diese Frage eigentlich rangehen soll. Aber es wird halt immer diesem...
Es wird thematisiert.
In Computer-Spielen wird etwas unterstellt, was irgendwie im Fernsehen und im Kino keiner hinterfragt. Gewalt habe einen Einfluss.
Moment, jetzt wird es interessant. Das hoffe ich. Ich finde die Killerspiel-Debatte geil.
Weil?
Sie zeigt, dass wir ein Massenmedium geworden sind. Jedes neue Medium in der Geschichte der Menschheit, was zu einem Massenmedium geworden ist, wurde in gleicher Weise diffamiert und angegriffen. Und meistens von denen, die in anderen Medien tätig sind oder sich selber angegriffen fühlen, das als eine Bedrohung für ihr eigenes Medium sehen. Letztens ein super Beispiel gehört. Als Gutenberg den Buchdruck erfunden hat, wurde er von den ganzen Gilden der Buchschreiber und Buchkopierer, die es damals gab, angegriffen, verteufelt und verhext und versucht zu verjagen. Ein ähnliches Beispiel. Meine Großmutter hat es mir erzählt. Ich gehe jetzt meine Geschichte zurück.
Die Gutenberg-Story hatte ich auch schon in einem Podcast.
Das interessiert Geschichte der Typografie. Meine Großmutter hat mir eine Gewaltdebatte erzählt. Sie hat mir gesagt, macht ihr nichts draus. Zu meiner Zeit haben Politiker versucht, Rock'n'Roll zu verbieten, weil das im Bunde mit dem Teufel ist.
Das ist er auch.
Es war wirklich so. Die Politik hat sich ernsthaft in großen Krisengesprächen damit beschäftigt, Rock'n'Roll zu verbieten, was die Jugend verderbt. Heute lachen wir darüber. In 10 Jahren lache ich auch darüber, über die Gewaltdebatte. Um Arabella Kiesbauer zu zitieren, darf ich das? Kennst du die? ProSie-Moderatorin. Damals im Fernsehen.
Ich gucke ja kein Fernsehen.
Notsendung. Spielfilm wurde verschoben. 2015. Ich mache Fernsehen, wenn man Spielfilme guckt. Nein, es kommt wegen aktueller Schulschießereien. Eine Debatte mit Arabella Kiesbauer als Moderatorin über Gewalt und Computerspielen. Und ganz am Schluss sagen sie, dass sie sich für eine interessante Debatte noch weiterführen muss. Aber wir zeigen jetzt den verschobenen Spielfilm Die H2.
Ja klar, es ist auf jeden Fall eine Debatte, die von vornherein mit falschen Vorzeichen geführt wird. Auch das Fernsehen musste sich diese Diskussion anhören. Jedes neue Medium. Das Internet als solches hat ja auch genauso darunter zu leiden. Hat denn die Debatte schon Schaden genommen? Es gab ja eine Diskussion um Verbote. Gibt es Verlagerungen von Programmierern aus Deutschland heraus?
Nein, gar nicht. Im Gegenteil, es hat uns gestärkt. Es gibt jetzt zwei Verbände in Deutschland, den BIU und den Game-Verband. Es hat den Game-Verband sehr gestärkt. Bundesverband. Interaktive Unterhaltung oder so was. Und den Game-Verband, das ist der Verband der deutschen Spiele-Entwickler. Es sind noch viele andere Leute drin. Das hat die gestärkt, weil sie zusammengerückt sind, mit der Politik überhaupt diskutiert haben. Und dadurch mehrere Dinge gemacht haben. Zum einen, die Politiker haben gesehen, hey, die Spiele-Entwickler, das ist eine coole Industrie. Das sind ja wie viele Jobs habt ihr frei? Über 2000 Jobs. Wieso bekommen die Leute nicht mehr? Die haben gesagt, es gibt keine Ausbildung. Wie? Wir können Ausbildung anbieten für euch. Und plötzlich kamen ganz andere Themen auf den Tisch, die tierisch beschleunigt werden, weil die Politik plötzlich ein Interesse in diese Industrie hat. Die Politik ist ja nicht blöd.
Die haben vorher gar nicht geschneit, dass es eine ist.
Nee, haben sie nicht. Sie wollten auch wie spielen. Das ist doch irgendwie alles amerikanisch, ausländische Spiele und Import und keine Ahnung was. Und plötzlich sehen die, da ist eine Riesenwirtschaft in Deutschland, die einen Riesen-Nachwuchs-Bedarf haben. Wir haben weltweit eine Stellung in Deutschland. Da ist natürlich auch viel Titeln wie Anno Crisis und Siedler zu verdanken, aber auch vielen anderen Firmen. Und plötzlich kommt da Spielentwickler-Reden mit Politik. Das ist noch nie passiert. Damals habe ich mit jemandem geredet, über Hauptkopiererreihe und sowas alles, aber über solche Sachen noch nie. Und plötzlich kommt der Dialog zustande und es stärkt beide Seiten. Und da ist die Gewaltdebatte, ist da ein... Ich meine, die Wahlen sind doch demnächst, oder nicht? Also, nein.
Lässt dich kalt, sozusagen?
Lässt mich völlig kalt. Und nee, im Gegenteil, ich finde es geil, weil es wirklich zeigt, dass die anderen Medien uns als Bedrohung sehen. Und ich sehe das ganz genauso. Weil die interaktive Unterhaltungsindustrie, wo ich Teil davon bin, sind meiner Meinung nach das Medium der Zukunft und werden irgendwann mal dem Fernsehen und dem traditionellen Serienmedium nur noch eine Nische überlassen.
Jetzt muss ich da nochmal kurz auf die Raubkopierdebatte zurückkommen, weil wenn es jetzt so gestärkte Interessenverbände gibt, die jetzt auch mit der Politik reden, was erzählen die denn der Politik in Bezug auf Copyright-Verfolgung?
Es gibt Gespräche, was diese neuen Rechtsschutzgesetze der EU, die haben ja irgendwie ein neues Copyright-Gesetz verabschiedet oder wollen, die Europäische Union, da gibt es Änderungen, auch Patentrecht ist ein sehr interessantes Thema, wo die Verbände da mit der Politik in Verbindung treten und dort dann versuchen, ihre Interessen zu wahren.
Weil ich meine, die Medienindustrie, das ist ja natürlich jetzt auch etwas, wo ich eine große Bedrohung drin sehe, durch diese ganze Aufgehitzte. Oh Gott, unsere Daten sind nicht sicher. Wir müssen halt jetzt alle möglichen Verfolgungen einleiten, bis hin, wir wollen Zugriff auf die gesammelten Daten der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ja, das ist ja ganz reale Bedrohung. Das findet statt. Die ganze Rechtshilfe, die dort eingefordert wird.
Rechtshilfe, Strafverfolgung gegenüber von Gelegenheitsdelikten und Rechte, das ist natürlich ziemlich grenzwertig teilweise. Und ich muss sagen, das regelt sich aber an selber. Da gibt es auf der einen Seite natürlich die Abschreckungen. Ich meine, ein paar bei Gefängnissen, die Kinobäume, die kennst du ja, bis hin zu richtigen Massenverklagen von Leuten, die auf P2P-Netzwerken Sachen herunterladen. Klar kriegen sie eine Rechnung von 150 Euro auf den Tisch von irgendwelchen Anwälten, weil sie halt in die Daten gekommen sind. Aber sie haben durch das Runterladen auch eine Straftat begangen. Ist ja ganz klar.
Ja, aber hilft es jetzt der Spieleindustrie groß, dagegen vorzugehen? Ich meine, wenn wir jetzt eher sagen, Online-Aktivierung...
Es geht ja nicht dagegen vor. Es geht rein nur, das zu thematisieren, Bewusstsein zu schaffen. Weil witzigerweise, wenn ich einen Film kopiere, ist es eine riesen Straftat, die im Kino angepiesen wird mit vier Jahren Gefängnis und keine Ahnung wie viel. Und steht auf jeder DVD drauf, kopiere ich ein Spiel, ist dir das keine Sau? Und ich frage jetzt, warum?
Ja, weiß nicht.
Ist ja nur ein Spiel. Und ich sage auch, wieso ist das nur ein Film? Aber da ist eine Industrie, die hat einen gewissen Status. Die hat sich das erarbeitet, diesen Status zu haben. Die Spielindustrie, die war immer so, ja, Spiele machen, das ist so, nur so ein Hobby. Und ernst genommen zu werden, ist der erste Schritt überhaupt dort, ich sage es mal, einen vernünftigen Mittelweg zu finden.
Also ich würde da auf jeden Fall, ich würde mich da sehr freuen, wenn die Spieleindustrie, da sie ja nun im Gegensatz zu der Medienindustrie, mit der wir es bisher zu tun haben, extrem Computer- und Internetliterat ist. Das sind ja eigentlich alles Leute, die Technik, Technologie, Computer und Internet wahrscheinlich alles sehr früh so mit der Muttermilch aufgenommen haben. Das ist so die Zeit, über die wir jetzt gerade geredet haben. Leute, die in den 80er Jahren ihre wesentliche Prägung auch erfahren haben. Da würde ich mir ja schon wünschen, dass man an der Stelle da auch ein anderes Verhältnis zu den Realitäten sieht. Weil wir wissen alle, wie es ist. Klar, wenn man es so kriegen kann und es geht, macht man es halt. Natürlich ist da nicht immer das Unrechtsbewusstsein so stark mit drin. Aber da muss man halt andere Methoden finden, dass das dann eben auch nicht geht.
Also wir sind da nicht in dieser Raukopi-Diskussion drin, sondern uns geht es eigentlich nur a. um Rechteschutz. Das heißt, dass andere Firmen unsere Rechte nicht angreifen können. Und b. um die ehrwitzigen Patentrechte. Die spielen wirklich daran, hindern, standardisierte Verfahren zur Erstellung eines Spieles zu verwenden, weil sie sonst Patentgeld an irgendeinen Mumpitz-Konzern zahlen müssten. Darum geht es eher.
Software-Patenten.
Software-Patente ist ein Riesenhindernis, gut in Europa jetzt nicht, aber in den USA. Die Angst, von einer Firma verklagt zu werden, nur weil sie etwas benutzt wird, wo sie dachte, das ist doch normal so zu tun, ist natürlich riesengroß. Apple hat sie jetzt selber spüren müssen.
Woran?
Die ist verklagt worden, wegen dem iPhone.
Ja, die werden alle naselang wegen allem möglichen verklagt. Ja, ist klar, aber ich meine, so läuft das, ne?
Visual-Wise-Mail war das Patent. Wie, keine Ahnung, 100 Millionen hat das von einer alten Firma gekriegt. Jetzt hat da NTT und Apple verklagt. Jetzt mal, das wird noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, aber dann geht halt da dieser Patent-Handel los. Dafür haben sie ja dann sich irgendwie noch andere Patente, die sie dann so im Gegensatz meist austauschen können, wenn es um die großen geht. Wenn man kleiner dazwischen geht, läuft es natürlich anders. Das heißt, Software-Industrie ist auf jeden Fall gegen Software-Patente, so grundsätzlich in Europa, in Deutschland. Kann man das so sagen?
Also die meisten Spiele-Entwickler, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, waren selber die Spiel-Industrie gegen Software-Patente, ja.
Ja, ich habe jetzt nichts mehr auf meiner Liste, Teut. Das war ja sehr interessant.
Wenn Fragen sind, ich kann die gerne beantworten. Wer mal ein bisschen Interesse hat, reinzuschnuppern, kann gerne auf meine Webseite mal ein paar Vorträge runterladen. Da sind so die, der Zyklus unserer Industrie ist dort erklärt. Die Webseite ist www.teut.net. Da sind ein paar Vorträge drauf, die aktualisiere ich halbwegs. Die Webseite ist schrecklich, muss ich updaten, ich weiß. Kommentiert das bitte nicht, sondern guckt nur die Vorträge an, wenn ihr da drauf seid. Da sind interessante Themen, da die schon ein bisschen einen Einblick geben. Ich aktualisiere das mal demnächst mit so Games-Mark-Überblick und weil ich bin jetzt sehr viel unterwegs auf Vorträgen, wo andere Branchen Interesse haben, mit uns in Kontakt zu treten, sage ich mal, so mit den Aliens. Und ich bringe denen bei, wie sie mit uns reden, oder was sind wir überhaupt, wie funktionieren wir. Und den Konflikt zu lösen, weil wir ein bisschen inkompatibel mit anderen Medien sind, das ist so momentan meine Aufgabe, sozusagen der Botschafter dazwischen.
Also eine Sache fällt mir jetzt noch ein, weil du auch angesprochen hast, Berlin sei ja auch ein starker Standort. Es gibt ja hier so eine Games-Academie. Damit bist du ja sicherlich irgendwie vertraut.
Ja, die Games-Academie hat einen Standort auch in Frankfurt. Angefangen haben wir es in Berlin. Es ist ein sehr schönes Ausbildungszentrum, wo viele Talente schon gefördert sind. Es gibt allerdings, neben der Games-Academie, muss man immer wieder bestehend, gibt es noch mehrere. Es gibt die BITS in Hagen, die einen Uni-Lehrgang macht, auch Game-Design und viele andere Sachen. Es gibt die Mediendesigner-Hundschule in Düsseldorf, die Ausbildung macht zum Game-Designer, zum Producer, zum Spieleprogrammierer. Es gibt in Hamburg-Bestrebungen in der Richtung. Es gibt in Köln eine Uni-Bestrebung. Es sind viele Orte, die leider nicht so bekannt sind. Es gibt nicht so zentrale Anlaufstelle. Und wir haben keine standardisierten Berufsbezeichnungen. Das ist das andere Problem. Es gibt viele Orte, die sich um Ausbildung kümmern, auch die IHK und viele andere Dinge, wo es Möglichkeiten gibt. Aber es ist noch nicht so...
Aber es geht los. Ich wollte das jetzt noch mal ansprechen. Was kann man jetzt auch so interessieren? Wir haben jetzt hier einige Hörer. Ich denke, der eine oder andere wird mit dem Gedanken gespielt haben, vielleicht auch in die Spieleprogrammierung zu gehen. Es gibt auf jeden Fall Möglichkeiten zur Weiterbildung. Und die taugen auch was.
Ausbildung, Spielebranche, Google ist die eine Möglichkeit. Es gibt jedes Jahr in Berlin die Spielekonferenz. Die Covades, die Weißgrad, die kommt nächstes Jahr wieder. Wo ist das? In Berlin.
Wo findet die statt?
Parallel zu den Berliner Medientagen.
Also wo?
Die war jetzt in der, wie hieß die Halle hier?
Covades.
Covades, genau. Wo geht's hin? So heißt die. Und da gibt es viele andere Veranstaltungen. Es gibt auch vor der Game Convention, die in der Nähe seines Begriffs sein würde, in Leipzig. Die Spielemessen sind drei Tage davor. Da ist die sogenannte GCDC. Nicht ACDC wie die Bands, sondern GCDC, die Games. Das ist eine große Entwicklerkonferenz, wo eine Menge los ist. Und da gibt es viele Anlaufstellen.
Diese Games Convention geht aber jetzt nach Köln?
Ab nächstes Jahr erst, ja.
Warum eigentlich? Weißt du das?
Habe ich nicht viel davon. Das ist die Industrie. Die Game Convention wurde von Industrie gegründet, bzw. mitinziiert und dann der Messe Leipzig überlassen. Wie? Die haben das hervorragend gemacht. Leipzig ist ein super Standort, weil er günstig ist. Selbst Jugendliche können da mal eine Nacht bleiben, ohne Probleme zu haben. In Köln wird das alles nicht möglich sein. Deswegen glaube ich, dass in Köln die Messe nicht so erfolgreich sein wird, über die Zeit. Aber das ist meine politische Meinung. Ich hätte sie gerne in Leipzig gelassen. Sind die Mädchen auch hübscher?
Ja, das ist natürlich auch ein Argument. So, Teut, das war's. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Das war jetzt eine schöne, lange Sendung. Oh, weier, 2 Stunden 40 Minuten haben wir jetzt schon zusammengequasselt. Wer hätte es gedacht? Aber lange Ausgaben sind beliebt bei Chaos Radio Express. Das ist das, was ich von den Kommentaren und dem Feedback immer wieder mitnehme. Trotzdem, stellt es nicht ein, schickt E-Mail oder kommentiert im Blog zu dem Eintrag zu dieser Sendung auf blog.chaosradio.ccc.de oder schickt halt trotzdem eine Mail, wenn ihr der Meinung seid, das ist der bessere Weg an chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich freue mich immer sehr über Feedback. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, konkret jetzt zum Inhalt der Sendung, schreibt was ins Blog. Ich werde heute noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass er da vielleicht auch mal für die nächsten Tage einen Blick drauf wirft. Ja, und das war's. Ich bedanke mich noch mal herzlich, dass es jetzt geklappt hat. Welche Konferenz steht jetzt hier eigentlich an, in diesen Tagen?
E-Learning.
E-Learning hat jetzt nicht so direkt was mit Spielen zu tun.
Weil die wissen, dass wenn man lernen will, will man auch Spaß haben. Vor allem, wenn man jetzt online oder in Spielen lernen will. Und den Spaß haben sie nicht so ganz begriffen, wenn man nicht hinbeikommt.
Das ist gut. Super. Ja. Hab ich noch irgendwas vergessen? Bestimmt. Ich bedanke mich auf jeden Fall fürs Zuhören. Wir hören nochmal das iPhone. Ja, du musst unbedingt das 3G-iPhone holen, dann stört es auch nicht mehr beim Recording.
Du, wenn der Upgrade-Plan da ist von der Telekom, sofort.
Das war's. Tschüss und bis bald von Chaos Radio Express.